o
it day one officially off
E3 twenty twenty one I'm B.
C. and joining me today to
discuss everything we've
got coming up including
yourself forward and the
Gearbox panel good
tamoor hussein. Hello has
gone. And phil hornshaw Hey.
So yes we're very early in
the day but there was lots
of good stuff to look
forward to most notably
Ubisoft's forward which is
starting in a couple hours
so we've got our pre show
I'm gonna head over to the
estate- to Greg Milledge
Jacki Jing and golden boy
and a very on
michael highgam high and
might be making an
appearance or even soft and
then Gearbox are also
happening today is the
wholesome games direct it
is a packed day- so let's
kick off because my talking
about Ubisoft's because
absolutely nothing. Has
leaked already is it is the
weekend the classic weekend
of E3 where everything kind
of comes out of the
pipelines and boggles a
broken and everyone is just
kind of well sees on the
news on Twitter before the
CS pop actual press
conferences so let's kick
off with Mario plus rapids
sparks of hope hi I'm what
happened with this one-
what. What can we expect
late today. Sometimes it be
a own and the Nintendo.
Website J. O. you guys 1
one of those right. And-
yeah. This is a sequel to
the beloved Ubisoft and-
Nintendo crossover RPG-
yeah it just appeared on
Nintendo dot com I believe-
nice been taken down now so
it's no longer there but
Mario plus rabbits foxes
hopes for Nintendo switch
and yeah looks like it's
all out there that would
have been a nice surprise
considering that people
have been calling for a new
one of these files. A whole
load of time I'm but yeah
the intent is to frequently
can so. Where yeah I didn't
anything this would have
been a really nice surprise
because I don't think I
think when. Mario plus
Robbins was initially
revealed everyone was a
little bit taken aback by
cause itching it just seems
like such a weird
combination within the game
came out it's- and it was
actually genuinely. So much
fun. I will say though one
hell of a learning curve- I
hope that are something
that is fixed. Phil what do
you expect to see from
Marcus Roberts today and
are you excited that the
games getting a sequel. I'm
extremely excited so yeah
this was one of those
sleeper hits the when the
switch dropped for me I was
like aw rabbits. And it was
amazing I had a great time
and it will actually
elevated the humor of the
rabbits. In a way that I
hadn't expected at the time
like mixing that with the
Mario characters- you know
those guys they're real
loud they can get kind of
annoying. But I really felt
like that game nails. A
certain kind of humor that
was going for it really
enjoyed it so. It looks
like this is going to get
even weirder even just from
the leaks I think it was
cover art shot. Looks like
you know. It's leaning into
like Mario galaxy stuff and-
I'm all for it I'm totally
into that. Get as weird as
possible get as- rapidly as
possible thank go for it.
Yeah when you mention the
humor because to me rapids
was sort of always in the
same vein as minions. I'm
so frying Mario Rabbids
definitely- I think that
kind of I N. dot with the
humor supposed to be made a
little less grating. So we
going to be seeing more of
that hopefully today if not
today when the definitely
Nintendo's press conference
which is on Tuesday- but
that's not the only game
that has leaked ahead of
you. This press convert
unfortunate Rocksmith plus-
it's gonna be well I've got
the kind of leads press
release I think was an
email blast that went out-
so Rocksmith. Ten years old
at this point which I can't
believe it being it's ten
years old- but it's going
to be a brand new
subscription service. And
this one is actually I
think my Gibson. Yeah the
Gibson- branded guitars
accidentally this one I
still have. You played work
Smith do you enjoy it. I
you know I tried it out way
way way way way back when
it first came out because I
wasn't really big. Guitar
hero fan I was like oh I
should be able to transfer
these skills somehow right.
Hello not at all. So I'm
I'm excited that rockstar
is coming back as a thing
that I've always kind of.
Wish I could do is learn
the guitar. Tried high
school. Played to Green Day
songs never played again-
and if this can like get me
into it I will pay that
subscription please yeah.
It always seems like a
great idea and it always
seems like just close
enough to video game things
for me to like really get
into it the way I get into
things like rock band and
not. And guitar hero. So
I'm down. I was gonna say
because yeah it did have
that Gaming elements- I
want to say it was called
like the guitar cage or
blockade or something like
that where you could kind
of. Practice your barcodes
by just playing sort of a-
kind of similar games you
want to say. Space Invaders
or something- time do you
expect to see more vox may
I have this year E3 it's
been. Pretty quiet for a
while. Yeah I didn't I
didn't know I expect to see
a Rocksmith Gaming I it
makes sense that Ubisoft
would try because like the
first game as you know
mileage may vary on how
much fun you have. Alvin
people coming to it as a
guitar hero style game
probably bounced off pretty
quickly when they learned
that. It's mostly way more
serious business but- as it
stands like taking full why
is an incredibly versatile
and rainy powerful tool to
teach people how to. Play
the guitar. I'm and
obviously the ability to
kind of work with a whole
bunch of peripherals gave
it a bit of an edge. I am
kind of excited for it to
come back I feel like.
Ubisoft probably sees a
market in probably sees the
value in always having a
Rocksmith game available.
To some degree or another-
people are always going to
be interested in learning
to play the guitar and if
they have. If they can make
it so they have the
definitive guitar learning
experience. That is. That
is pretty. Compelling in
terms of the business
decision and also as an
entertainment package. And
if they can weave it into
a- I EA use of forcible-
subscription style almost
like a platform. Bandai is
even. Better for them
because- funny what they do
they want that S. of
revenue as as of to a time
all. Care so I didn't
expect to see it but now
that it's- it makes perfect
sense. You know people who
knows how many people have
purchased the guitar in the
in the year and a half two
years of lockdown. And
throwing them wanna be's
and being like this will
teach you- sounds like
incredibly friendly small
move from the- I was gonna
say maybe you- you spend
just enough time practicing
guitar in your own home.
Lending 1 double and then
you can take that out on
the road with you. I would
like to open up and you can
see friends again. Okay so
it's that's it for the
leaks- unless god something
else's legs while we've
been. Shot let's talk about
how he was. He's I've got
the new slack channel. The
next. Justin gave- but you
actually usually pretty
good about saying what they
have they always keep a
couple of surprises up
their sleeves unfortunately
looks like two of those
surprises me these but we
do know I have that in
their pre show today- we're
going to be seeing some
awful on a so the game has
just gone on Xbox GamePass
and- yeah what is it yeah 5
season two achei Maraj.
Kicks off or just has
kicked off- June tenth so
the party kind of show a
little bit of that- I am
honestly. I enjoyed what I
played a phone on a but not
enough to keep up with it.
I'm kind of amazed it's
still going as strong as it
is I'm love to see it but I
am I generally didn't kind
of expect that. To keep
that for them to keep up.
I'm dying to be supplied.
Unfortunately no. But I was
looking into. What's going
on. First of all five years
since for R. I. pleaded
yeah. And really enjoyed it
and- you know. Life
happened and now I'm like
oh wow he- for honor is
doing some cool stuff and
with GamePass you know I
would be willing to get
back into it especially if
there's a lot of new
content there's a cool new
events going on the Russia
that sounds. Interesting I
guess it's a big fire
themes drought situation so
like that makes for more
fighting- and you know I
really liked for honor when
I played it wasn't any good
at it but I feel like I
could be one day. So I'd be
willing to get back in
there especially on
GamePass. Tom Arnold. I've
not played it in a long
time but like everyone else
so I really liked what I
played I think that. The
fact that they've been it's
raining on and- delivering
more content on it is going
to be. I'm very beneficial
I suspect that this
whatever we get will be a
trailer for. The new season
but also kind of like a- is
what you missed in for
honor to kind of whet
people's appetite. I'm you
know and again looking at
it from a business
decision- we had microsoft
talking about. The impact
all of- GamePass owned
games that all. Introduced
straight into all are
introduced at. Any point in
two GamePass and a house in
up lifting- impact on
actual sales of the game as
well as DLC. So for a game
like for honor which is
probably has got a decent
to healthy- I'm kind of
cool to play is. I'm
dropping in there. And well
only mean that benefits
from the increased interest
outgrow is plant based even
if not a lot even if it's
just a small fraction of
Instagram. That's probably
enough for yourself and
there's a decent chance
that. That transfers over
into. Buying more money for
I'm- DLC and also the word
of mouth if you've got
three friends that are on
GamePass playing for honor.
And you know you're the
fourth or fifth friend and
you don't have GamePass.
There's a decent chance
you'll you'll get the
following just by the came
out right which works in
Ubisoft favor to. So lost
my decision. Being made by
pointing out that and-
hopefully the new content
is like exile but you way I.
Like I. Gonna download once
a gets to a GamePass. And
see what's up and- probably
bounce off because there's
some killers in that I've
been playing for five years
and- mop the floor with
you. Nonstop that's- every
Ubisoft mafia yeah I was
gonna say but then again
I've seen you play soccer-
and bloodborne so I think
you probably you've
probably got the reaction
time for I do not. Hell
yeah. I was kind of breezed
past what else we can
expect from the use of pre
shows so updates on
trackmania. The crew to
brawl Halas of their
announcing a brand new
crossover football how they
decide kung fu panda- but
interestingly. Watch dogs
legions gonna watch dogs
legion is going to be that-
so sizings creams updates a
kind of in the manger but
watchdogs legion which
just. Had a kind of fairly
significant update
obviously out of the
multiplayer mode. The
riding in a kind of.
Zombies mode we can play by
yourself or with friends at
school legion of the dead-
and then they have other
kind of exciting stuff
coming down the pipeline
for August the writing like
invasion mode extraction.
T. V. P. modes- and then
there is going to be kind
of- story DLC later. Down
the line bloodline store
DLC. As well as it. To have
like eight and PS. In your
game. Right from one's to-
are you despite you know
loving London having lived
there for a long time I did
bounce off which dosage and-
quite quickly I just didn't
really. I didn't kind of
enjoy bouncing from one
character to another I kind
of prefer to have a
protagonist- Phil did you
enjoy what starts the
engine did you I. You kind
of surprised to see the
displacement in use of
showcase today. I mean a
little bit- it does kind of
feel like watch dogs is
settling into a sort of
Nish- having played that
multiplayer- you know it it
it feels like a very
specific draw and I think
that might be. Why watch
dogs is falling into the
spot in the pre show as
well like it's not
necessarily bringing you
know huge troves of players
but people who are into it
are really into it and I
could see them. Really
getting into that so I mean
what I want to check that
out having. Played the
multiplayer little bit it
gets tough it is very
difficult you really need
to have a wide. Who knows
what they're doing and- is
willing to goof off but
also really willing to
coordinate if you want to
get anything done. Enzymes
mode probably. Looks like
to me it's gonna be kind of
that same level of like
yeah this is running for a
minute you can write on the
cars and stuff. But now we
need to get serious and-
you know you need else for
that right so like this
isn't maybe going to blow
the doors off for. Ubisoft
in general but there are
people who are really into
that experience and- you
know having friends who
want to get into it and
have. Run it a couple
times. Yeah it's pretty. So
so you know I'm I'm into
the semis idea and- I think
that that is it. A niece
that doesn't always
necessarily get served of
having it like really
intense- good feet open
world experience but
needing that squad- and so
I mean to I think that
could be a cool thing for
them to kind of lean into.
I'm gonna move us along
because the actual showcase
the use of his promising is
already pretty packed so
let's kick off with a
rainbow six. Extraction
formally rainbow six
quarantine- I think my
favorite thing about that
was that the name thank the
kind of rebranded the name
had actually just been.
Outage a long time ago and
just no one so if realized.
Time what your predictions
we know going to see a-
game played more trailer
is- are you excited for
extraction. The new
playlist yes. Yeah I'm very
excited for extraction- I
we talked about this
previously in a and another
stream I don't remember
what it was or when it when
it was because time is a
flat circle and confusing
now but- lucy james
fundamentally is a Razer
any. Shop sure- and it's a
satisfying and it's like
them call mechanics of it
off fantastic so the tricky
thing flora is it's really
hard to get into it the
learning curve is steep and
people on there all no
forgiving- view comments I
told- and you know you
generally have to find new
people thought that you you
kind of jump into waves
alongside all or you find
people that you trust to
kind of guide you and
that's a tricky thing to
do. However the idea of
taking those same call
mechanics and spinning into
a cooperative game boards
universities you know a I.
enemies that is incredibly
like compelling to me I
love playing siege I love
the idea of playing
extraction with people who
always have liked the idea
of siege but perhaps on up
for. Getting you know
through the Holocaust does
learning it and then or
perhaps light on into the
idea of getting killed
immediately and then sing
the rest of the round out
because you call on you
know play- but playing a an
extraction where you're
always in it is still
playing you know with
friends and then you may be
thinking about moving over
to seize because you found
a similarity in and- prove
any kind of- a
understanding of how it-
the coal mechanics worked
out super exciting. I think
this is gonna be I hope
this is gonna be a big
chunk of the use of forward
I'd love to see them break
down mechanical stuff and
break down this is how to
the destruction is going to
factor into this this game
where you're fighting
zombies or or affected or
whatever it may be has how
you know the operators are
going to behave and how
they might be familiar or
different and ultimately.
More most importantly has
how the cooperative part of
it is going to work and how
it's going to be fun for
you instead of like a very
you know straight laced
armies are zombies game so
I hope we get to see plenty
of this game this is one of
the games. Are most excited
for in the showcase. Yeah I
mean it's the man- I mean
one. Just one John. Sub
tweet to me- as I was. Dan
and I am the person who did
give up when we briefly. As
it as a group decided to
play rainbow six siege
because- I would just die
and get annoyed- because
obviously you can't just
like immediately respond
you can still help- but I'm
I'm very interested to see
what the loop is going to
be the extraction- because
you know it's a it's a team
game I want to be the
person who is contributing
more. And not just the
person who was swearing a
lot over Mike because they
immediately died- but
another game but we're
definitely gonna see a lot
of today is far cry six. So
it recently had- sort of-
behind closed doors
presentation- where they
showed off some. New
gameplay mechanics-
obviously. Junco Esposito
was at the- some game fast
the other day. What more
can we see your this game
today I don't I don't mean
for that to sound mean but
it just seems very weird to
have an embargo you show
off so much of the game and
then kind of have another
thing just you know
literally like a week or
two after Seville what
you're expecting to see
today. I'm I'm hoping that
we'll get a little bit. Of
a better sense of like this
it what seems like they're
crafting. Going on with
like the building weapons
and- calling them out of
weird. Stuff around the
island I would. I'm not
really a big fan of
crafting in. Far cry in
general usually feels like.
You know hunt down nine
boards and then make a
wallet and- it's just not.
Something I really enjoy-
but this seems like much
more of a creative. Kind of
approach at least from what
I gather from the trailers
and the other coverage and
stuff so. I'm hoping that
that is true and we can
like learn how we're gonna
actually be kind of.
Leading into. Pulling stuff
out of the world actually
making cool stuff out of it
not just like ticking off a
list. For crafting which is
what it's been like. For
last few games- also I
would just like to. Hear
more about you are in
general and sort of where
the story is going. You
know- Giancarlo Esposito.
Had that interview with
Geoff Keighley and- he said
some interesting stuff
about his character and I'm
interested in. That and you
know the risks recent
discussion of. Whether or
not this game is going to
be political. According for
political ends like- when I
that's a weird already a
leader very loaded
discussion obviously but
what I do want to hear
about is sort of like the
view point of the game and
what kind of world it's
building you know and
there's interesting stuff
there it sounds like. Hello
has an interesting
perspective on this whole
idea so that's one I'm
interested in is the
storytelling of far cry is
always- it has its nuances
and has its interesting
directions and stuff and I
want to see more of that.
So I'd be down for anything
that's going to be kind of
like giving us a sense of
where we are in this world.
What this world's gonna be
like and the nuances of the
characters- involved and
it's not just like up it
was the bad guy go it's
Christian. I want to hear
about you know his take on
the character and how that
fits into the larger
experience of the game.
Yeah I'm- interested in- in
the sun. Character I know
there's a lot of
speculation when- **** six
was revealed that that
could be. Voss a young
young boss but I think just
I mean. I don't think it is
but I he is but I think
just his positioning where
you have his. His father
who is this dictator who
doesn't see himself as a
dictator then you have. The
freedom fighters. Who were
trying to you know. Free
Yara from this dictatorship
and then. The kind of
leaning into the propaganda
side of it as well a lot of
them are getting into I'm
I'm very intrigued to see.
How things unravel but I
will say and you you for
this of yourself where. It
became you know it just
checklist I know that is
classic Ubisoft's game
design towers. Checklists
and I think. I think I mean
if you go back to far cry
three which I think. EIC
much had the balance just
right and then you go to
something like assassin's
creed hollow which is a
game that. Doesn't end and
obviously it has a ton of
content but it also has a
lot of bloat and I found
that with the last two. Far
cries I'm not including
like primal or new doing
but you know like far cry
just didn't have. The I
don't know I just wasn't as
tight knit as an experience
and it just provided me
with so many options just
to drop off because I
couldn't be bothered to
liberate. Another thing or
climbing up the tower so
I'm interested to see how.
That kind of dealing with
that in terms of the
gameplay itself time
anything on farmer. Yeah I
think I think the- I mean
like both of what you said
there is a on point like
they- off the wildlands-
release which performed.
Incredibly underwhelming
leaves behind a- you know
they had their financial
report and one of the main
things they cited was the
game. And differentiate
itself in any meaningful
way it kind of just got
lost. And that's not only a
problem that Ubisoft has
when it comes to its own
games versus other people's
games other companies came
it's- it's a problem that
Ubisoft has when it comes
to its own games versus its
own games they're all kind
of blending into one thing
right now. And that has
been the case of assassins
that has been the case with
far cry and we're
definitely is the case with
all that- ghost recon games
so. With that in mind yes
everything I've seen so far
all of far cry. Eight eight
it's given me nothing to be
excited about so what I'm
looking for two years as
well Phil says like what is
the narrator is it going to
say something. Because if
it's got nothing to say and
it's the same games with
Moorcroft thing. I'm not
sure I can get hype about.
And like you were saying.
Jean-Luc needs to be
meaning for the different
this time around because we
played multiple far cry
games to this point. And if
I really want that same
experience again I can pick
any number of games that
are out there that. Offer
me something different
instead of the same far cry
flavor. The coffee stuff
seems cold seems
interesting it's not enough
for me I'm at this stage in
on in my Gaming career and
life when. I need something
meaningful to happen in
these games instead of
being like the same thing
over and over and over
again- so I don't know I
hope that the show
something cool something
different- I do. Wonder
whether they're gonna be
like they're gonna try and
do the thing where they-
show off that one mission
that everyone talks about
burning the marijuana field
or whatever it may be but
this one- and kind of trait
some pause. That way but- I
don't know I need I need
something I need something
to kind of shocked me out
the malaise around far cry
right. Now because so far.
There is there's no a lot
get sued excited for me. I
almost thought you were
setting us up for a
definition of insanity
doing the he said same. Run
over again yeah but yeah
but I mean that that is not
in itself says a lot that
the defining far cry stuff
that you think about the
burning them the marijuana
fields the definition of
insanity that kvass as a
character that was a far
cry three. Which you know
we've moved we've
collectively move past but
you know still kind of
trying to reach those
highs- let's move on to
don't have very long before
we're gonna pass over to
the S. A. official. Opening
stream- we know we're gonna
get updates on right as a
public assassin's creed
Valhalla it's going to be a
kind of Ubisoft filmon TV.
Section obviously will
understand more about the
upcoming stuff from mystic
quest which I started
watching recently and I'm
genuinely very much
enjoying this across I
think it's very funny- I
was well aware wills then
which is coming- to vote on
July second based on. The
video game where wolves
within which in itself I
think is not based on the
board game why wolves or is
that just you know like a
spin off but either way
there is a kind of. Game
night ask movie coming out-
so why will so then- so
spend the last few minutes
before we over discussing
potential surprises. So
obviously we've had rabbits
and Rocksmith but there was
still a lot of things that
you Ubisoft has that either
we know what that I working.
On all that we hope that
they're working on. My big
loaded question. Phil today
day do we more beyond good
and evil two. You know I've
it feels like that might be
where. Ubisoft is headed I
feel like they like to hold
these little beyond good
and evil trailer is like in
reserve and then just
bounce among people- and
that's- did not happen two
years ago to three as well.
Nobody expected an awesome
we were just hit with all
this game played stuff.
Seven Joseph Gordon Levitt
you. I want to say. Yeah.
Which was just like I just
remember I remember Eddie
from his team I think it
was Eddie went to- the B.
on the Neva presentation he
was like a difficult enough
it's here I don't
understand why. So I don't
know maybe yeah so like I
would not be surprised it
would be unsurprising if
that was the surprise it
almost seems like a thing.
That has to happen at some
point yeah. I mean honestly
when I was kind of putting
together a run of show are
you went to Ubisoft's
website because you know
yourself news. Usually has
a pretty up to date- kind
of list of stuff and the
feel good evil to stuff
was. Pretty highly placed
I'm in a position on the
website so maybe. I just
don't see how it's beyond
Knievel GamePass my-
michael highgam right. But
I'm intrigued I'm intrigued
I just wanna see more of
it- time it comes you know.
Avatar hello. No well. I
think it's massive- working
on an avatar games you
think it's too soon-
because I don't think we
know when the movie is
coming I think they have
been filming I want to say
but I'm not sure if- if
it's too soon to see
anything from the game. I
think it's probably too
soon to see something
substantial from apple I
think that. Ubisoft well
want to. Remind people that
they are making and- I will
tell Gaming. Based on yeah
Cameron's. Thirty seven
movie series is that people
apparently ready terrible
adult. Book fair enough
but- I reckon we get like a
logo. I may be like a blue
alien looking into the
camera and saying. I am the
avatar I don't know about.
You know seen avatar. No
because I watch the trailer
and I went looks like top
ten. And I will not be. And
I just like have knowledge
that and then they came out
and everyone went yes go
three D. I was like what
was the movie like and
they're like. This call
three D. yeah it merely I
could. The thing ready that
was about I know that me
but I remember. It was a
moment. It was a check or
something like that X. I.
C. you dig through the I
see- was it unobtanium. Was
what they were going for
some yeah yeah without. But
regardless so we know
avatar is in the works of
massive that was how the
Star Wars project- the EA
Star Wars licenses of laps
and while EA does still-
it's a working on Star Wars
games. Are now you post
office kind of how would I
go Phil do you think we're
gonna see like even into
the teens. I hope so we
have almost no information
about that at all so I
would really love to hear
just a little bit about
like what you soft is
attempting to do with that.
Whole idea. We know it's
narrative we know what's
open world. That's about it
and you know- this is the
team that was working on
the division so. I'm I'm
really interested in what
that translates to for Star
Wars- I think we really
need to kind of go off into
some different directions
with star wars in general.
And related with it and I'm
hoping that that's what
we're gonna see from
Ubisoft some new ideas in
this whole galaxy. I was
gonna say I mean the
Mandalorian. Ellie I mean I
know it's kind of the most
recent so I was in memory
but it's like that does set
itself up to be a game
pretty well that game was
essentially like just fetch
quests all of the place-
we're gonna start to wrap
it up now we gonna throw
over. To the official EA
stream eight EA he S. a
Syrian- to. Look this ESA
E3 EA I was gonna mess it
up and of course I have to
mess it up and they were
gonna throw is the official
ESA stream. To kick off E3
twenty twenty one. So we
got Greg Miller. Golden boy
and Jackie Chang. Then
we're gonna go to the U. S.
of pre. Than yourself
forward and then back here
for all our reactions. So
don't go anywhere catches.
What everybody welcome to
E3 live from an undisclosed
location in Los Angeles
California. E3 is back
after a one year hiatus I
am Greg Miller one of your
three hopes this week and
I've worked in joined by
one of my other house
Jackie Chan hello Jackie.
Report here. Exactly last.
Except for when I leave the
set when we leave we have
to wear the mask I love the
Batman mask thank you
roughly will find a new
fashion sense. Yeah indeed
of course as EIC swing
early E3 is back things are
a little different than
usual their forces no in
person convention this year
our presentations will be
virtual but trust me. All
the news and excitement is
very real so while we may
be here in Los Angeles
reacting all of you get the
opportunity see every
announcement. From the
comfort of your own home.
That is right Greg we are
coming to you from here in
LA and sending a shot all
over the world. From coast
to coast in the US. Erica
to the middle East to the
EA you. Handed China and
the more we're spending
over a dozen different
countries several
confidence. That the wifi
connection is working okay
maybe a space station or
two or V. earth. All this
of the helping hand of some
of the most trusted media
companies around the globe.
Very exciting oh my gosh
it's the best right as it
continues to go that was
one of the things that I
think. Was so exciting to
me when they approached me
hosting right that was the
idea that this truly is a
global event they want to
get everybody involved
everybody touches the ball.
Localizations different
people different outlets
covering it and really
making it you know E3 for
all in this giant E3 that
we can all celebrate
together. Even though we're
still part yeah what's so
exciting is the
accessibility and I just
feel like everyone is so
high. Brian. Tano
downtrodden. EIC five
thirty. You know he makes
up early the time. A kidney.
I know but even before he
had a kid now he's- the
riser I thing I don't know
Brian I'll for my junior
party. Was not waking up
with right I didn't doubt
EA. K. but on the it was a
so excited this morning
waking up to all the tweets
and of the X. you know.
Twenty cap is apart from
our friends and family but
twenty twenty one is bring
it all back together again
we have a whole host of
media friends from around
the Gaming community to
react with over the next
few days. And that brings
me to our third host Alex a
golden boy Mendez who was
with our media partners. Hi
hi hi hello everybody and
welcome we're here in our-
Tetris collective set is
actually quite nice here
excited. To be a part of E3
this year and I'm joined by
some of our friends and
media partners we got. The
one and only Damon hi Phil
from IGN coop good to see
here we also have my good
friend and co worker. Right
here Ali may G. four TV
baby we also have Dan Casey
the legend himself. From
the nerd is so nice of you
I did big fan always have
been end. The person who's
become my new best friend
over the last few hours got
michael highgam I'm from
GameSpot michael highgam
what's up man your thanks
for having. I well I pre.
That 1100% of course thank
you guys so much for
joining us here today and
you know. We're gonna be
talking about all the
latest and greatest that's
gonna be coming out of E3
but before we do that I
want to get your **** quick
reactions- you know will
start with you what are you
looking forward to hearing
E3. There's so much to get
excited about I'm really
stoked for the PC gaming
show because there's a lot
of great stuff that comes
out of that every year a
lot of India's but in
particular dying light to.
I can finally live my dream
of perishing a parkour
accident without actually
perishing in a park or
accident from the safety of
my own home it's gonna be
so much fun. We see a lot
of mac games a lot of
surprises to come yeah I
think all of us would
rather not perish from a
parked car accident- they
what about for you but- get
you be sucking up today at
my favorite thing to do
video games it's clear
outposts. So far cry six is
very exciting to me I'm
also a rabid fan of turn
based strategy game so if
you decide that something
along those lines. So it's
I would say yeah- I'll look
at that I. Okay are awfully
what about for you I'm
excited about everything G.
B. this is the first time
that I get to join everyone
here E3 so I've got like
the nervous sweats as well
as the excitement so I
tried the best what's- but
what I'm looking forward to
is. Here in some news from
Capcom because I know a lot
of people have their
fingers crossed for
potentially another VR.
Experience so. I would die.
For that G. B. I die for.
Yeah for a lady. We could
talk about that later on
and- get into that later.
We got we got a very long
long long. Next your days
michael highgam what about
you but- I'm going to be
staying on brand and I
would say Square Enix. But
not because of Marvel or
any of the big names I'm
talking about Babylon's
fall. That is the game that
was revealed in E3 twenty
eighteen and I went radio
silent. But PlatinumGames I
know that they got
something up their sleeve
and I know that. You
there's your big fat off of
your big fan of platinum
games as well. But near our
town is one of the best
games of all time and I
want to see what platinum
has up their sleeve this
time around bold statements
here from michael highgam
that's where you're going
to be here at all we can
focus. Bold statements hot
takes. That's what you want
to hear but- well I think
everyone. For joining us
and we'll have more. In
just a moment but first. We
actually have a special
announcement to share with.
All of our fans. And to
help with the news. Here's
a very special guest. Hey
everyone I mayor Eric
Garcetti. And to all the
video game fans and
supporters. Developers and
publishers out there today.
Welcome to E3. Los Angeles
loves E3. And not just
because we posted this
conference over twenty.
Times we love the E3
because this town is a
Gaming town. Home to some
of the biggest Gaming
companies. And a multitude
of independent studios. LA
is home to a growing
concentration. Of game
developers and publishers.
EA sports teams and
players. Talent agencies
and investors. Cutting edge
technology and innovation.
And that's just the start
of what makes LA. A hub for
the video game industry.
And what makes our city.
Such a good fit for E3. You
have an incredible few days
ahead of you. So enjoy. And
we'll look forward to
seeing you in person. Here
in the city of angels in.
Twenty twenty two. We're
back ladies and gentlemen
next year E3 in person back
in LA. It could possibly go
wrong going super thing and-
it's all happening right.
Fortunes are coming off I
mean the fact that like we
were able to be here you
and I together but Alex I
mean then have GameSpot
Nerdist IGN G. for all
under one roof right like
that was a dream last year
we are all in our houses
watching streams totally
actually during rehearsal
you and I were like. Yeah I
think it's the thing about
it yeah you know there's no
yeah. Over here it's
happening for all in person
we're excited to be in
person with you next year
ladies and gentlemen. What
an amazing start to this
year's E3 there are so many
more announcements on their
way over the course of this
year's expo so stick with
us everyone. There's much
more when we return. We're
not just nerds we have
people. That are like us
and get us it just
solidified Gaming as the
monolith that's not going
anywhere anytime soon. E3
is high if you're not E3
you're not doing it right
it's just excitement the
size of it all the
connection of people from
different walks of life
people that I've met and
games across the- world
I've been fine isn't
enough. To go exactly one
time. It was almost like. A
holiday I was always in
these sounded super top
secret was awesome now the
good day for several days
we all just got caught EA
games the best become
friends that happen to me
multiple times E3 to be
around positive people that
love it I love the people
that make video games
shower us in games it was
something we aspired to
magical every year honestly
it's a celebration I think
of how far we've come as.
As people who just love
nine. Hi everyone. Welcome
to E3 twenty twenty one.
I'm standing here the week
the president and CEO of
the entertainment software
association. The ESA serves
as the voice and advocate
for the U. S. video game
industry. We've also hosted
E3 since it started in
nineteen ninety five. Every
E3 has its own story and
this one is certainly
unique. Given the times in
which we live. While we
couldn't host the event
last year we've been amazed
by the role games have
played in our everyday
lives. During the pandemic
that prevented us from
being with so many family
friends and colleagues
video games connected us
entertained us and brought
us together. I'm not just
saying this because I love
video games or because I
work in the industry. As a
player and as a parent I
experienced this first
hand. And I hear similar
stories every day from
people from all walks of
life. Games kept the same
and kept us connected.
That's what makes coming
together this year for E3
so special. It's an
opportunity to convene and
celebrate as a community.
With that in mind I would
like to thank the
publishers developers
platform sponsors and media
partners joining this
year's festivities to share
their plans about the
future of games. Will also
give voice to the many
conversation we're all
having today about games
and about society. And
throughout this year's
event will be sure to
reflect the broadsheet
today as well as the
positive impact games have
had on society. Now I would
be remiss if in a year of
so much loss I didn't
acknowledge the passing of
an industry giant earlier
this year. Robert Altman
founded center Max a choir
Bethesda Softworks and went
on to build brands and
franchises that are among
the most popular. Under his
leadership his team created
games that continue to
delight fans around the
world. I got to know Robert
in his role as chair of
ESA's board of directors.
What I learned was that he
absolutely loved the
creativity and dedication
of his team he relished the
opportunity to gather as an
industry including eighty
three. And he adored his
family. It's great to know
that his legacy and the
games they produced live on.
Over the next few days will
celebrate games the people
who create them and those
who play them. We'll bring
you big reveals from
companies large and small.
Will also have some great
surprises along the way so
stay tuned. Thanks for all
the love you've shown games
this past year. Now sit
back. Relax and enjoy the
next few days of pure fun
and excitement.
Thank you
so much stand for that
appreciated it let's take a
look at how this week is
going to play out starting
with a look at tomorrow's
huge slate of dead some
publishers we just saw an
exclusive clip 5 away from
Naraka Bladepoint which
will see more tomorrow
twenty four entertainment.
And then we get the Xbox
and Bethesda games showcase
followed by square Enix
presents and WB games back
for blood will follow up
with some heat of their own
then it's the PC gaming
show and future games to
close. Out then let's look
ahead to Monday don't be
thinking don't miss things
Verizon unveiled their
initiatives and
partnerships in the Gaming
space followed by
Intellivision take two will
address diversity and
inclusion in the Gaming
space then it's mythical
games to announce what's
coming soon from their
team. If you like indie
games we put the
independent about first in
the spotlight to freedom
games will follow and you
won't want to miss what
Capcom has to unleash.
Razer will end the day with
a look at some of their new
products and we wrap things
up on Tuesday as Nintendo
leads the way things are
sure to get off to a huge
start that day his Bandai
Namco will follow up with
their newest titles. Your
Rico will take the floor
and then GameSpot chimes in
as we wrap things up with
the E3 awards so you don't
want to miss a single
second. You don't Alex you
really don't why would you
go anywhere else I don't I
don't know why right here
there by the way we have an
area where. We how many
more areas are there. We
gonna have to watch and
find out from. Okay I'll
just tell you right now is
that there's three there's
three Greg we just got to
try and keep lowering the
mental why lie to one
because in the twitch check
it's on the- with so many
heavy hitters and
announcements to come we
want to pose the questions
to ourselves here. But also
to you at home throughout
the coverage of E3 to make
sure your voting in our
poll throughou You're
watching on twitch Twitter
Facebook or YouTube pages
simply. Chat type
simply. Chat type into the
vote into the chat in the
Bruce. All the boats get
tallied up live and shown
on screen so I will pose
the first question. Golden
boy what developer are we
most excited for now except
publishers as well put it
on your little chats yeah I
you know what I'm gonna
keep it real. All right
anyone who knows me. Knows
that I'm a halo tonight we
go so I'm sorry I gotta go
my boys at three four three
I'm so excited to see
anything from halo
infinite. The halo
community is buzzing right
now and we're all very
excited about what could
potentially of course you
see the chat running away
42% sort of talk about
Xbox. The second beyond
that but let's talk about
the real elephant in the
room ladies and gentlemen.
Marvel's Avengers Black
Panther. More how many
times I gotta tell you.
Stop and- me. I want you I
need to get a level of
right I'm I haven't so. For
though it looks for a know
I. We're going to hopefully
see more out of it. How we
are going to be better out
of it- and I'm sure it's
going to be awesome. Greg
Greg's been going nuts
about about the Avengers
this is our time I
appreciate that. You're
like me with halo. Thank
you thank you very much are
so let's go back to a okay
let me see that thing yeah.
39% of people are excited
for Xbox nvidia. For
Nintendo as well sorry
obviously Nintendo how
could you not be excited
for that- but you know
where's the love for- for
you resolve Square Enix I.
Remember going to see some
heaters. Off course and I
think one of the big things
about that right is the
fact that you saw. Is
imminent that is today in
Gearbox during the day I
feel like E3 is all about.
Unwrapping that last big
Christmas gift and when we
want to do that you know I
mean you come down it
beneath the tree of all the
small ones got the one big
one in the back there when
you go for it. Yeah that's
right and Christmas will
come early this year
because tomorrow we got.
The Xbox and but says that
games showcase iready
mentioned- halo I you know
I'm I'm always looking
forward to that. I'm always
looking forward to whatever
comes out of- you know
before to camp of course as
well if we get something
cool there but- you know
what makes this one so
unique Greg is that this
time around. It you know
two of the- with two of my
favorite press conferences.
Have joined together in the
Xbox Bethesda game showcase
which means. Starfield
maybe starfield give us
starfield I he we have to
it's a game that has so
much hype and we know
nothing about it. The time
is now. Phil Spencer Todd
Howard come out. In brace
and then just unleashed on
us if they actually I like
ideally I would like for
them to come out. In like
jet packs. You know sure
descending on perfect world
yeah you know I know you're
watchin surges you descend
into the states with Todd.
And then you guys announced
starfield then and there- I
think everyone will be
rather moist. Do you ever
think about the look at
this is the trailer this is
what we know. About Star.
Well I can be the greatest
Gaming generate. They will
go bat for a- will fight.
The with out in the for it
there are people. Now
fighting. For starfield on.
On some. Hunter percent
yeah. But I mean. For man.
You know anything from but
that. Though to. If a treat-
a great great studio-
incredible histories beard
stand talking about
earlier- and really there's
just- there's a lot. Of
hype there's a lot of a
passion. That I think is
gonna be coming out of that
camp that's reason why
everyone is. So excited. I
mean you're talking about
taking the Xbox fanbase
which is already so
powerful so now that. And
because the fan base and
making them one family like
yeah you totally expect
something from that. And
all I want outside of all
that is smaller Gaming
news. Where is twelve
minutes. Give me a release
date for twelve minutes
yeah. They're not fair
enough fair enough. Jackie
we're pretty high for
microsoft on Sunday why
don't you in the squad let
us know what you think.
About some of the other big
names looking to make a
splash. That E3. All right
thanks so much Gregg yeah-
so much to look forward to
but- first we want to
remind everyone at home if
you want some. Limited
edition E3 merch including
hats T. shirts and jackets.
It is all available at E3
expo dot com slash shop. I
don't see the bomber
jacket. There would also be
oh my gosh it looks good
we're stealing some- yeah.
Okay we're going to do that
for sure but okay. My E3
crew. So excited be with
all of you by the way. But
I'm Greg and golden boy
talked about. Xbox and-
start build all the jazz a
bit. But I 1 here we all
are hyped about so let's
just go down the docket
here- we're service
Square Enix okay they
recently announced that
they'll be dropping a world
premiere from Eidos
Montreal. An update on
Babylon's policy
michael highgam not a lot
here. Details in the Black
Panther expansion and a
first look at life is
strange remastered.
Probably see some true
colors to. My question is.
Any ideas on the item Montr.
Title Dayan's. Thanks I.
Yes I don't know. Why
there's absolutely no. This
excel. Mario I wanted to
bring out my- well
sunglasses that you click
and go. Okay that's not I
don't continue yeah- well
there is the- there's
rumors nothing is confirmed
yet- but- I think. There
are some guardians that are
keeping it very secret
until until the big reveal.
On I'm I'm gonna steal this
from- someone said this
during rehearsals the but-
not. Right now might be a
good time where you want
might want to have a cyber
punk style game so I'm like
hoping for days yeah it's
I'll get her for it. Like
this X. is one of the most
impactful franchises in in
my life. The original one
that came out two thousand
like it's old now but man I
still got so many memories
and like. Human revolution
and mankind divided for
like almost hitting those
notes. But I feel like now
with now would be a good
times like bring that back
and- I know verse of Sims
like. Might not sell well
whatever but bills are my
styles of games and- you'll
bring back the six please I
know I'm please we'll see
who's right Damon-
michael highgam and I. I'd
be happy if. I'll be happy
to tell you. I'm not going
to be wrong. Well as I know.
We'll see you could be a
stretch there- I feel like
took the good gas.
Meanwhile I just like why
beasts. Okay let's hear.
Them how. Said where all a
sudden. Turns into making
for some reason. But those
those seem like they're
actually might happen here
so I like enough space that
already. Your kingdom
hearts gamer Donald
actually heals you like I'd
found for that. But let's
not talk about something
that's physically
impossible. Any ideas for
you I think I'm very
curious as much as I would
love to commit minor crimes
to make day aspects of
reality I I'm I'm I'm used
to being. I'm used to
waiting for dissect it'll
come in due time so I'm
sure it's gonna be
something I totally
surprising- but yeah I just
I don't know I understood
for more- life is strange
as well so I can get my
hopes too high when I've
somehow something's coming
my way and I think with the
life in strange the
remaster actually packed in
like the- first one and
then the prequel together
so if you missed one of
them you can get all of
them again. Okay yeah- life
is strange I'm so
absolutely high port
animation is just off the
wall and then- just so
heartfelt and lake hits me
in the feels so much but-
are you damaging hot seat
here because Greg Miller
was telling he's to kick
your **** actually given a
really good. Team lead for
dad yeah yes. For the-
because you could play each
other to. Is mode yeah will.
Went out. Okay so I was co
op RA. I would your- yeah
okay I was just that you
know were ready for about
for blood. Hey Greg down
but okay I guess you all
were doing coop so mad we
we're queer cooperative
gamer is super excited for
back for but yes it kind of
feels like a lifetime ago
there were plans for dad
with a bunch of other ideas
yeah. It's nice to have
basically left for dead
three come back back for
blood coming okay awesome I
mean zombies like. We can
always use more zombies.
The girl is gonna get you
in lady di okay let's talk.
What's going. On as a
totally I'm obviously a big
fan of the vampire tall
lady- so obviously resident
evil. Drops here I'm just
no more creepy baby is
everybody with me I'm not
for sure thank you I never
want to see that. Again
Capcom thank you okay yeah
that's- what we wanted to
see we were leading we
have. Like Razer. Seven
with the whole VR
experience where you know
it's basically put the pant
simulator because
everything coming at you
when you were. 5 absolutely
terrified yes but dear god
what I would give if we got
resident evil eight. VR
edition because then all
not only will I run
straight into lady deep.
Nails I'm going to be I
think I'm like cool she's
coming towards me. And then
I'm sitting so I'm. Step on
me and that's all I mean
out of the VR experience
tracking that's all I need
I would say relax but also
I feel you on that one that.
Thank you let me clear all
and I can't. The real
aggressive people seven of
your component was such a
big deal if you actually
play through the whole game
and VR it was wild is like
one of the best VR
experiences. Legitimately
and resume village is a
great game already so if
you can put that in VR no
that would be wild
specially if you want to
bring it to PC VR as well.
Maybe line up for the PS VR
to whatever whatever that's
gonna come have that as
like a big hitter that
would be a big deal. And
also a sausage almost to
seal boys out there if you
want to go. Just be careful
if you buy a haptic suit as
well because my pal Kyle
hill did the Mona eight.
I'll explode. Well it's you
get stepped upon our but
it's just it's literally
science yeah well I'm
willing to take that chance
all right Godspeed for the
I'm Dan o'neill sure we can
see in a lot. I hope. You
got us down that. I would
up mortgage and everything
I have for morning Michelle
so you're telling me we're
gonna see Dino crisis. Well
I must he'll be
relentlessly taunted all
these title I hope they
come I hope they happen if
they do it'll be a great
day but I'm sure there's
some awesome stuff lined up
because even if it's
resident evil eight VR even
we get some rumors of a
popular fighting game maybe
a sequel to that who knows
it's gonna be an exciting-
prison Tatian okay and then
we gotta talk about Gearbox
everybody. Tying it. I
can't even talk. About it.
She is one of my favorites.
Video game characters of
all time Jesus those little
wild thing right and- it's
going to be a fantasy epic
I just I'm- super amped
about it so. How revealing
in and might be only one is
like that except I love-
initiative just get in
there. And tiny Tina
doesn't even look so tiny
anymore the regular size.
Home I'm very excited I
know I'm so excited I mean
honestly there are so many
great items to discuss- if
we want to go round robin
really quickly like what
are you most excited for
Damon perfect dark. He's
even had a perfect target
on his back show me what
this game looks like
michael highgam. Already
said in the beginning
Babylon's fall from. Show
me what that is can you
remember time. Oh my
goodness I can't believe
that that although Jackie
get me on the floor that's
all I need that and
Heisenberg thrown like
little metal nuts and bolts
of me just. Heisenberg oh
my goodness I think we're
on the leading the team but
okay Dan. There that sweet
sweet star field I want to
see what they have in our
system. Yelled all right
well it's some great
answers there but we're
going to wrap things up
here for a moment but that
doesn't mean the party is
stopping. We are just
getting started live from
E3 next up we're talking.
About solid state to. Hurry
back. Hey what's up guys
what's the pain- just want
to stop by and say thank
you guys for. Watching the
show thank you guys for-
enjoyed E3 I can't wait
till we get. To be back in
each other's faces and-
walk around these. Huge
conventional loans and
stuff like that and I. And
okay what is the stress me.
Somebody get me out of the
house please just come pick
me up anybody. Turning
Gerald. Please come get me
until then. Keep saying
Gaming. He's in Canada it's
really helping seven thank
you. In Georgia. I can't
believe Jackie just try to
turn Gaming Hatfield
against Greg Miller all
right that's possible all
right everyone knows we are
left for dead Dynamo you
and me could be back for
blood Dynamo it's gonna be
all about it but let's talk
about Ubisoft is up next
we're finally there what
are you most excited to see
you you know what we did-
get some news the other day
about this whole. Splinter
cell animated yeah- if I'm
a bad man I'm out here
thinking like well. You're
gonna do an animated series
Bob's burgers so what's a
great way to accompany said
animated series I've been
trying to pull this
narrative the entire time.
I just want splinter cell
you are a betting man in
the wrong way I will gladly
take the spent twenty
dollars. No sooner. Versus
5 greatest multiplayer mode
ever made I stand by that
statement stand by as a
Superman fan let me tell
you splinter cell fans it's
time to give it up. You're
never going to get another
game it's not going to
happen they don't bring the
V. R. went into this I saw
them try to do this
community and- don't worry
about it. For me far cry
six yeah I know we've seen
so much about it but- I get
more excited the more I see
in the fact you know they
lean a little bit said we
are political this is a
political game. I you know
Jon Karl had a great
interview Jeff QB this week
where he was talking about
like I'm not the villain
and I love the fact that he
saw in his characters that
way yeah. I really hope
they get the water stain
shows again to reserve the
winner Dr yeah yeah but it
the truth is. Jeff Bakalar
Esposito could do anything
and I'll be glued to my
seat so- seeing him in far
cry it's really gonna be
fantastic- and I think
honestly man you be soft
like I would like to see
some. Little nuggets out
there for division fans say
although it might my
brother's a massive
division fans do plays all
the time he always talks to
me about it. Maybe we get a
little something like that
some some but you that was
it saying right they did
they went another way to
say no division to update
noted on our land and I'm
like but division early as
was to be so. I'm. Please
just lied to me tell me. If
you. Want to live. In the
Ubisoft okay. The other one
I think that's got. Yeah I.
A call and I'll- for
blessing. Junior over. Of
funny as riders Republic.
Yeah I'll look at such a
cool debut. Then I double
A. like. Is that where we
heading with that where we-
yeah. The more the sports
writers I feel like that is
a genre that could really
use something that would be
like reinvigorated. Right
you know we all remember
the axis axis of the world
and stuff like that how
much we loved it- ten
eighty those games are.
Great or fantastic. I would
really really like to see.
Some more updates on that
game- what we'll get maybe
some you're more downhill
biking as well mom biking
BAndai I love that kind of
stuff. Injected right my
mates. Well that's- what's
exciting about right is
that it's going to be the
twenty twenty one version
of that. Where you got off.
All of the riders coming
together doing that having
XP AB. Regression
understanding what that's
going to look like. In an
online world I can't wait.
Let alone the fact right
there to talk about.
Assassin's creed volatile
you'll be getting an update
of some kind. How big that
is what does that mean we
don't know. Obviously talk
about their TV shows are so
much stuff going. And
that's- the main show
remember of course we're
gonna be going over to a
pre show. That's gonna be
talking about watch dogs
gonna be talking about so
many other things. And I
don't want to just string
you along. A longer. Ladies
and gentlemen the time has
come for our first
presentation. Let's send
things over to you be soft.
As they prepare. For you
before work. Winds
humanities price. Would
lead us to our town. For
when the stems would
foresee. She alone would
look. To see what was
hidden I. He was silenced.
What was the.
The new power.
The weekend.
The disability
community we have a saying
nothing about us without us
it's the same all rights
access inclusion in the
world combi met improper
awful ways without direct
involvement it is true for
Gaming as is access to a
building it's really
important to us that we
work with the community to
improve accessibility
finish them full thing how
you doing plans and develop
is with first hand
experience of disability
much less likely to make
mistakes now approaches.
Even if or if it's a well
intentioned they might not
really reduce the Barria.
Contribute to stigma.
Really thankful and proud
of the community for the
contributions. When I was
working with you Ubisoft on
watch dogs legion. We got
to sit down at a table
going through ideas on how
the feature can be used.
Click the directional
captioning. Or what kind of
information could be on the
screen at the same time.
Whatever can be removed.
There was a lot of going
back and forth to make sure
there was no confusion. It
was great how they were
double checking to make
sure they got it right. I
grew up waiting for
accessibility to be
something companies can
talk about. One such
legions please anyone
innovation brought with it
a promise of diversity and
inclusion that inspired our
team to make accessibility
a core pillar of our design
the very beginning. The
game offers and visualize
sound effects system the
captains of hundreds of
Andean world and gameplay
sounds from birds singing
to footsteps the cars
exhilarating or crashing
each prioritized by context
can specialize with it
directional indicator the
100 Thieves team is
extremely proud to have
achieved this new level of
accessibility. But it's
only the beginning games
that are truly accessible
to everyone require
continuous innovation in
Africa and I look forward
to seeing today's
innovations become
tomorrow's standard. On
assassin's creed ben howard
we started working on
accessibility features very
early in the process we
have options for players to
choose their text size but
also the text size of the
subtitles. You can add a
background to your hide
elements to make sure the
contrast is good for you.
V. ten and just the icon
size also- depending on
your Gaming set up we want
to make sure that you get
the most out of it. Ubisoft
goal is to make games that
enrich our players lights.
And keep that is making
games that are intrusive
and accessible to all what
we've seen is that by
talking to the community
and learning from each
other our teams are really
inspired to innovate and
find solutions. Striving to
challenge themselves and
always improve. Or.
Uhhuh.
Little's.
So you might
often say on social media-
Agame announcing that it's
gone gold but the question
is what does that actually
mean you may not notice
already so I'm going to
tell you. So when we say
the game is going gold it
means that the game is
being approved for
manufacture. Side that can
be Sony Microsoft Google
Amazon Nintendo which other
platforms were talked into
that specific game. The
game is fully playable-
it's stable it's got.
Decent level of
performance- and
everything's basically
working- and also that we
passed all of the
compliance requirements
from those first parties
and they have basically
said. Yep if you go to
manufacture. And then we
start making the disks from.
The term going gold comes
from- when this is all done
on physical disks it's
digital now but when this
was physical disk is the
ones that were sent to the
manufacture companies
without version of the game
on that is. Has been given
the thumbs up they were
gold colored. And so we
still use that template. So
when we go call that
doesn't mean the all the
work is done for the team.
And we usually go to
manufacture about six to
eight weeks before launch
service in time that we can
use to. Properly punish the
Gaming fix things like
stability in little
niggling issues that might
impact the game play. When
we go live. One of my best
memories from from shipping
a game is when we were
working on the division to.
And we decided quite last
minute that we wanted to
make some improvements to
the onboarding into Charles
right at the beginning of
the game. So I want that
involved was me running
around the office you're
speaking to people. Trying
to see what was possible.
The safety what changes we
could make. Already gonna
improve everything. And
that it was great to be
able to work out kind of
imagine. Right at the end.
That was going to improve
the experience for everyone.
I want to GamePass gold.
That's quite a big
milestone for the team- it
means that something that
they've been working on for
quite a few years. Is
almost ready to go.
Remember to give them a
shoutout when hurricanes on
gold. That means that we're
all really excited to see
you get your hands on the
final part of.
When I
started this project the
homework I got from him
from the universe of team
was go home and play. My
name is Sam I know somebody
can musician and composer
from Norway my name is June
5. And I'm a musician and a
singer. Oakland I
predominantly sing in
Scottish Gaelic. Music that
I perform is deeply rooted
to the music of the
highlands and islands. I
understood quickly that
myself and people in the
music team up for a few
minutes of we had a lot of
the same. Idea so full of
fun and vision of what my
party needs could be. When
I decided I wanted to have
Julie on board and she's
except that I could already
hear the music in a way.
I've known Julie for a- for
a long time in the- and-
yeah always hopes at at
some point the come on an
opportunity to do something
together I do connect to-
to her way of approaching
the older- song traditions
it feels great to have her
part this. It was certainly
an amazing opportunity to
work with in our I love his
work hello this music and
his approach to making
music. To work within our
own these songs and which
is something to me it felt
quite natural and really
enjoyable actually.
Implemented instruments
such as the- the liar which
would be the most common
string instrument that to
time of course use the
bronze horns that we- also
have an in Scandinavia and-
was present in Ireland at
this time and- for a long
period before this as well.
One instrument that I
introduced that I didn't
use in the main game is to
cruise. It's a former
flyer. Was present in both
Ireland and Wales and
Scotland. The two songs
that we work on one of them
was an old Irish and flown
put Eden that is actually
an excerpt of a poem dating
from the early eighteen
hundreds that was the
intention of the song
creating of a praise poem
for offline. There are many
strange myths about that it
is sort of the coronation
stone that. Kind of power
off choosing the king when
a truthful Kingswood
touching the ground with
the sound beneath the- it
is sort of the hearthstone.
Great experience working on
these two songs they were
very very different I
stylistically and
linguistically also. We
wanted the Gaelic language
old Irish and Gaelic which
is a mysterious language
this is a language that we
have evidence so the rating
but we don't know how to
have it send it we don't
actually know for sure how
it sounded to so. It's a
little bit of educated
guessing. The legend is
that the storm will bring.
But the song cleans if
Ireland came to peddle the
storm would remain a storm
of wonders the kid is a
very important Hey
character in this story
ketamine says dark here
going on it was challenging
for me to I had to adult.
The voice of this amazing
character who's very very
strong character but it was
really incredible and
recording the voice parts
and being directed in real
time. From Canada I put a
lot of heart into my work
it's important that it.
Extend the game but also
reflects the culture. The
music in the language they
really shape our identity
as appeals. It was hugely
satisfying to work with the
music and actually for me.
It was a great way to
channel some creativity
during the pandemic.
A
little's.
Nineteen eighty
six Britney friends the
gamer brothers catch a
glimpse of the future and
launch Ubisoft no internet
no emails just a bunch of
people and a passion for
technology and games today
Ubisoft still has an eye on
a future where 85% of the
jobs that will exist in
twenty thirty I haven't
even been invented yet
since Ubisoft can't predict
the future we need people
ready to forge talented
people who aren't afraid to
create the unknown and I'm
on the lower is one of
those people this is I'm on
the cool cool she hates
interviews for about that.
But we'll find a way
because it's worth it I
could tell you she's a
junior developer a graduate
of a video game school but
I won't because she's not
instead I'll tell you the
story of an unexpected
career path well I'm
narrated by the way I don't
really exist but I know I'm
on dean and I know you PC
correct me if I get
anything wrong I can do
that Amerindian loves arts
and crafts she draws
illustrations and character
art he can crochet tiny
cute animals she studied
languages at the university
of Chambery France she
lived in New Mexico and
Japan in each new place she
started off from scratch
totally lost. Barely
understanding. A word and
she loved. Michael highgam
said was always easy for. I
the developer skills to get
out of six. This is pale he
hates turning his camera
on. Calls but I'll make an
exception for. That he'll
make an exception for us. I
always am on dean's first
real bus he recruited here
in twenty sixteen for an
internship in
communications even if he
didn't have a degree in
communications. She seemed
daring and resourceful he
trusted her immediately.
And yes amounting plays
video games but lots of
people Ubisoft play games
many don't and that's just
how you be self like that.
Amadi manage Ubisoft's
internal weekly newsletter
she felt his job was a
perfect match for her
independent spirit and your
taste for new challenges.
But she'll never forget
the- saying push the button
Amonte it will only be sent
to eleven thousand people.
It's twenty thousand now
for up to marine she's now
the one in charge of
sending. The email. Easy
peasy. This is Cody she's a
content communications
manager she help them on
the in built on what she
learned with pale. When she
hired her next. She wasn't
afraid to break with
convention and I really
encourage that. Because it
provides a new way of doing
things. Almandin started
organizing conferences in
writing speeches for
Ubisoft's speakers. She was
learning something new
again and she loved it. I
know it sounds weird but-
he's telling the truth I
love the challenge. But in
Amerindians head a little
seated behind an idea was
for me. She was so close to
the people making the game
she left. Two years later
it became clear she wanted
to be aligned design
Amerindian reached out to
Elizabeth she was leading
teams of line designers at
the time. So we should talk
about the game she liked
was question made and
proficient she was even
able to connect with ninety
two appeals only and took a
bus. I need to test it can
sometimes make a huge
difference on the policy of
the game. Amerindian
started helping production
teams design the content of
their games. She's one of
the bridges between the top
management H. Q. and the
production teams. In
Ubisoft studios around the
world. She isn't
interpreter as is always
been. Yes being a line
designer is. All about
communication you can
always re interpret your
skills in a brand new way
looking back without
feeling Colleen she
would've missed a key step.
That's it thank seventeen
for your inspiring story
nothing before I go did you
like this story. Head over
to you be soft dot com to
hear more just like this
one and maybe even take
your first step towards.
Creating the unknown with
Ubisoft's. So. Or.
Razer.
Or.
Hello everyone as you
may already know Ubisoft
has been supporting
industry just for many
years now weathering some
prediction innovation
creative or even financial
support well since I've
been supporting individuals
from all over the world
today we wanted to use for
what's right let the
sedation if can you give us
about the pleasure of
supporting recently.
Enjoyed hi I'm son rode the
co founder of two kind
interactive the young
independent game
development studio based in
Berlin Germany. Currently
working on dar from.
Dorfman take is a relaxing
strategy and public gamer.
Ever growing ideally
landscape by placing tiles
you can immerse yourself in
the beautiful peaceful and
quiet world if you need a
break from every day life.
Documenting also offers a
challenge for those who are
looking for what because to
be a high score you do not
only need to plan ahead but
also place your tiles brace
strategically we are the
lucky winners for Ubisoft's
enterpreneurs in the camp
in the German speaking area
and we are excited for the
upcoming exploration
program. Where we
participate in mentoring
sessions and are able to
receive marketing support
such as the new gamer in
two games come. From anti
is already available right
now in early access and
will. Go into full release
later this year. We also
have for. And the need
switch so there's lot still
to be discovered. Thank you
for your time and to do so
for this great opportunity.
So I'm in Taylor I'm one of
the containers of. Online I
came michael highgam one
which is our studio print
online is a turn based
strategy game you've got a
team of five players
playing in. Comments
firefighters. And they are
gonna. Okay but you know
okay that's too I think
it's a- fun world and I
that the- play it it is
solid we've been working.
Now yeah are the winner.
Socks twenty nine eighty
series. A couple cents much
of the year they best
person for. Access to those
with different folks
internal help prevent and
their company we have
pretty 5 discourse. A lot
of interesting the game and
we're really pretty that.
Online is in early access
now so feel free. You can
send it to some friends I
would really appreciate
that very personal thank
you bye. Hello everyone I'm
Dave principles generator
on you sick of parking use
a parking is world's most
extreme parking game I'm
probably the only reason
gamer to goes to actually
stop your car it's a funny
physics based Razer. Which
doesn't take itself too
seriously but still
requires an issue for you
to master the hardest
tracks we crashed into the
Ubisoft design team awhile
ago and we had some great
discussions on the second
parking he gave us an
actual 5 great feedback on
the roads. And they've been
champions and became ever
since so we're super
grateful for the music of
parking presents you with a
ton of very surprising
levels the goal is to fill
every parking spot before
the timer runs out. And
don't get too attached to a
car's though because.
You'll have to respond all.
For competitive player out
there need to. You every
levels you can. Which
friends and the way. Sort
of stops. And for everyone
that's feeling creative
also included a level
editor that features
everything that's in the
main game. You can go all
out to be creative and make
your own trucks 1 know how
much use parking. Can
already do so download
today could also talk to us
show us your best moves
will talk to all departures
that's hard discords. Have
a party.
Hi everyone. I
money and all police are
here Ubisoft ivory tower.
The crew to. Launch twenty
eighteen reaches its third
anniversary. It's been a
very intense here plays
multiple count on the
plane. Every four months a
new season and every two
months anyway. We deliver
all the content announcer
when you're ago. And for
this I would like to warmly
thank our teams here
addition you all that work
and commitment despite the
copy nineteen context. But
it's also time to warm
anything Q. our community.
Since we are ready proud to
announce that you're on now
more than thirty million
players 5 joined a crew
franchise. Since twenty
fourteen. And for those I'm
not joining yet whatever
it's a time to jump in to
protect first playing this
amazing vehicle form the 1
procrit eight in game
starting today. Also next
week enjoy one event for
each major update ready so
far in a special
anniversary live some but
it's far from being over.
And I'm super happy to
announce more seasoned
waffle through. Your
content of course be
available from other flicks
new season any business.
But enough talk Andrea
glimpse of him next not
awfully show. Thank you all.
But my. One of the ways to
Ortiz around New York City.
Here in Miami. Already
today.
For or.
Hey everyone
I'm a teacher they now than
life producer on watchdogs
legion back in October
twenty twenty you included
a resistance build that
sack and state our near
future London since then
you have jumped in online
mode friends dared our
tactical ops. And 5 for
London's Meena. Now on
behalf of the team I'm
proud to give you a taste
of what's coming up in
watchdogs legion deadline.
Got a simple job for you.
Huge payday what's it's in
London. That's where your
nephew Jackson lives right.
Anyway the job pretty
straightforward break
inside broken steel device
giving control arm
weaponized robot. That
thing must not fall into
the wrong hands. Easy easy.
This I need for a okay I
guess we're doing. All I
need is that little device
stolen by your partner the
one in the stupid mask I
can find. I just don't
think I can trust you
without some insure. I am
tired criminal con man
running towards. I need you
to pay attention.
Or.
At a
time to do how does nvidia.
No longer. The firm. My bad.
Now I feel.
For a limited
all from.
Hi everyone and
welcome to you be
thoughtful words I'm Neal
and I mean is that we're so
thrilled to be back hosting
Ubisoft's board over the
next hour will be your
guide all the latest news
and exciting announcements
coming from Ubisoft we've
got so much in store for
you today including deeper
look that far cry stakes
writers are public and
rainbow six plus a few
other surprises you'll find
out about soon enough.
Neelam I'm excited we're
filming this thing together
we got this gorgeous set E3
is mac. But I know why you
all are here you want to
see games so let's get
right into it. The rainbow
six operators are facing
off against an evolving and
deadly threats. You're no
doubt have noticed that the
alien parasite has spread
to new areas. It's time to
suit up and step into the
containment zone. Here's a
deeper look at rainbow six
extraction. He's so much PC
daring to the heavens until
a piece of info. And in.
Nineteen it could be
contained. So to one of our-
I need an extraction team
now. There's a way to. You
will find. But I know. Sign
me. Thanks. Think of the.
I.
Throwing me a party. Yeah 5.
Not. No I know you must
have a ton of questions
after seeing that trailer
and we have answers as well
as a full gameplay
walkthrough coming up so
hang tight. My name is
Richard a new resident
community developer coming
to you from North Carolina.
We're thrilled to be back
to give you an introduction
to rainbow six extraction.
With me today in Montreal I
Bruno malign our lead
technical director. In at
least see a forty eight
game designer to help walk
us through. Policia what we
tell our players about
extraction. Extraction is a
one to three player co op
experience you might think
you know what you're
getting into since it's
gonna be some of your
favorite rainbow six
operators. But it's going
to be completely different
this time you're not
fighting against each other
you're coming together to
face an unprecedented
evolving alien. Some of the
operators abilities gadgets
intact should feel familiar
to siege players. At this
time as you progress
through the game you'll
unlock new ability upgrades
and a whole new arsenal
specifically designed to
take on this new threat. So
the operators we just saw
in the trailer very
familiar. What will happen
to you Bandai. She got
captured an extraction
you're always putting it
all on the line if you were
to me falls are encouraging
here gonna go missing in
action. You can't play and
my operars until they're
safely recovered U. S.
wate have to come backtogetn
there and get them out.
Every time you gin the
containment zone you risk
losing all your progress
and grades so stay on your
toes and wt every move
you make. Balancing theriskg
to be tough. Bruno Q. tell
us a little bit more about
the alien that. What is
it who are they and whe
did they come from what we
know is that our teams are
involved formf the
parasite thawas first
dected in few years ago
during the. Regev a you
ma school. But the change
since the parasite that
spread to treating you
region emerging as overall
conttment sold witn New
rk softball school a
ask. This is what we know
soar within thecontainment y
anyalls them is in a
continl elution.
formation thatnd
there's tissue Spon
procedurly takg over
dierent on tt have that
map and reactio to ey
are free. Our site is
always ready all evolving.
He didt look too happy
about the operatoro serve
eir new. What we ce off
againstell the black gold
spray isrobably first you
will on. It to e mac
one your brie is the ten
still iting for a- and
then the are. some of the
other ips your have en
on the tra.  do lg
range . Excluse
rearchers thi shiing
fromAnd that. There's a
lot more speci a argi and
we do tt been ups or-moreo k
you both so much for
ining me I'm reall
excited to dig to more of
the dails we still have
croslayo talk about.
Yes that' right extractio
will bng everyone
gether regardless of the
platform f rainbow s
siege communi we have
exclusiv unlocks for y
in both gas. Okay youe
been wtingong enough.
t's ke an excluse
first look atome meplay
foote here Israel six
traction. Wcomeorainbow sixe
netactal co op shooter
gameor rnbow six
opators a droed into
ien rritory.n today's
walk toughe're on a
ssio to investige
anomalie identified at eOrpe
addionalnstructions.
ur Dtona five hured
ground netrk thehole
thing e Janese. ant
au tckers on dorma
Dot deroy them th t
with theracksAs
squad ohree Allah alibiin sr
erator abilities to
compte objectives aist
each oer and theitere
are Keans andheiray.
Of seding up. Eyor
stin a bring tlife
's not so easy to
elimaten lae numbers
Location t enemy reas
to irusis in thei
ecosystem including
opator elinate
mikeowar. The ealt
tactics e thway to go.Okay.e
sprawl substem. A learnerkes
up taccu y faster andstngern
use tir rctighto
see b luminescent
propties iour ques
and rm in. Theontrthes to by
targs.hankaming. Good
jobdentying are k
invariants hps t tea
determin the btapproa to ken
frt of it. Fgs wl
swing oundack. G out
the for the forme. If
you're luc.
Tt was
cle here the team canregrouy
airlock ors ll open on
to the next. Which will b
tougher than t first.
Apple slo Archie's anwe
need to goYou react The.
Right ere react blad.
One wn we're not done ye.
That youe targeting.
Don' forget the denture
yet g that sample we'
located a spiker you can
fire armor piercing
ojectiles alibieploys a
prison holograms it's
going The squad canse
react tech to go further
encoagement. e more
Intelhey collect tackle
haven't their dposal to
fight o the threat it's
all about teamwork to
oumart the ene back in
that spot. Chokepoint it's
a good idea to increase the
k mines efficiency. The
wayeep fighting. Yeah
smasher incoming Wow that
a good leader no lead for
the argued to foow
another objective complete.
The squad neither
accessibility extraction
point to bring home the
latest Intel or move to the
next airlock. The third
subzone would be the most
challenging yet a true test
of both tactical team
strategy and operator
reflexes. The markings are
responding to a leadership
for communicating. No Way
would lead to mobilize
against us. Ontem down into
the lead comes out of
hiding.
Second.
We have an
operator in. In operators
now M. I. A. I don't know.
Hi. You heard it a rescue
mission is underway reacts
still needs you. Operators
it's time to unite and
stand together against
emerging threats squad up
with friends and co op or
step into the containment
alone. Stay tuned for more
rainbow six extraction
Intel coming very soon. If
you think fighting aliens
is tough trailer link it's
art. Well that was a Segway.
Ten years ago rockstar
redefined music learning by
introducing the first
console game that taught
millions how to play
guitar. Whether you're
already an expert or just
starting out Rocksmith has
an approach that's for
everyone. A fine in
interactive way to learn
guitar playing your
favorite songs and in the
decade since its release
our community and its
impact only apple 5. This
year let's turn it up to
eleven and see what thanks
for Oxman.
She. I'm Martha
Nagel producer at Ubisoft's
San Francisco Rocksmith has
truly been a dream project
for me as a lifelong gamer
and a touring musician
Rocksmith is what I wish I
had when I started learning
music and that's why I'm
thrilled to share the next
evolution of music learning.
Rocksmith plus a new
interactive music learning
subscription service
available this year learn
how to play guitar and bass
by playing along to master
recordings of your favorite
songs connect your
instrument your PC console
or mobile devices. And get
real time feedback as you
play. Connecting with
rockstar plus will be
easier than ever now that
you can use your phone as a
microphone. Download the
app log in sync to rockstar
plus set it down and play
along. Now acoustic players
and electric players with
camps can use rockstar plus
with no extra gear needed.
It's a game changer. And
we're excited to reveal
rockstar plus we'll have a
huge amount of songs at
launch all songs the
library will have chord
charts they'll be perfect
for rhythm players who want
to learn the foundation of
a song the home and
struggling to. We'll still
have the note for note
authentic arrangements for
players that want to play
songs exactly how the
artists originally played
them and each week released
a steady stream of new
authentic arrangements to
keep growing that partial
library. We're also
introducing the Rocksmith
workshop a new tool that
lets users create and add
their own arrangements for
songs we've licensed. Your
subscription will give you
access to all those songs
more content than ever
before including joiners
beyond rock what pop hip
hop country Latin R&B all
sorts of metal subgenres
we'll have music from all
over the world from big
stars to indie darlings.
It's the most diverse song
library ever seen in music
learning software Ross plus
we'll still have our proven
practice features like
adaptive difficulty and
refer Future will you
practice and learn at your
own pace or slow down and
repeat. Tricky parts until
you master them. We didn't
prove those V. and rockstar
plus and are introducing
new ones beginner and
intermediate players will
benefit from more
personalized learning.
Things to enhance
recommendation system and
more robust progress
tracking players want to
see their growth on a
single song. They can now
monitor their progress
technique by technique
across the board and
overall offer a better
sense of how your improving
overtime. Advanced players
will be happy to know
introducing a new Rocksmith
tablets review. That way
you could take advantage of
rockstar plus the song
library and practice tools
in a format that's familiar
and one that will hone your
tab reading skills. We're
excited to announce that
you can register for a
chance to participate in
our closed beta right after
the show. Visit our website
at rockstar dot com to get
an early look at rockstar
plus and help us test and
create the future of music
learning. Thank you so much
for the amazing fans who
have enjoyed and supported
Rocksmith over the past ten
years. What's the jam
together with rockstar plus
for another. Ten register
now for a chance to play
the rockstar plus beta.
Summer's coming and nothing
gets thrill seekers blood
flowing like bright sun and
fresh trails and writers
Republic will give them
just that. Last year you
got a first look at our
massive multiplayer outdoor
sports extravaganza. Since
then the products grown by
Johnson Dr.
Greetings
thrill seekers this is the
riders. Populous stomping
ground. Here you can be
like minded right. Manage
your career. Learn to mail
those wild. Stay style.
Share your creations with
Republic. They on top of
the latest news. Take up
some ferocious multiplayer
action like free for all.
Six sixteen competition.
His old work performing
features on the module to
turn from red to blue every.
Two team's overall score
still with me okay. When
your team is turned all the
margins who you capture
that despite. Which will
help propel you forward
into the big stuff.
Progress to unlock. Most.
So if you want to be the
boss of career. World
famous competition we.
Some
might say the best. The in
the city. We've got more.
Maybe you're all about. The
way to progress you know
start having the right
break it's important to.
We've all got our
preference.
All right I get
it sometimes you just want
to explore in even nature.
That's right everything you
do counts getting those
stars. Activision in the
Republic we'll look 5 all
these awesome to do if you
reach new milestones and
unlock more channels. Red
Bull joyride. If it's the
biggest. And guess what you
can play it first is your
friend. There is so much
more. Your son. More BAndai.
Okay the natural outdoor
playground for you and your
friends to enjoy anyway did
you want. Would you sleep
with everyone we need.
Writers. Is this. Razer.
We.
Don't keep the mountains
waiting riders Republic is
coming September second and
you can pre order now and
claim your right to rip.
Okay so you seen some of
our favorite rainbow six
operators battling alien
parasites how's your day
job going yeah ever since
crimson highest we're still
trying to clear all those
pesky Flores drones off mac.
Your six is off to a
blazing start with each
passing two hundred
thousand concurrent players
a few weeks ago. If you
haven't joined yet twenty
twenty one is the perfect
time to drop it.
Securing
twelve journey we've siege
we are humbled and grateful
for the and to just to
community that that's super
the district. So today is
all about sharing credit
your flight developments
that tweet dramatically
improve. Your experience.
With the community growing
everything we've been hard
at work finding ways to
improve your ability to
play with your friends and
you. Clans on June
thirtieth we are unifying
over PC and cloud based
platforms cross play and
cross progression. This
means that any player on
Amazon Luna yeah or PC
we'll be able to queue in
two games together. Well
having a unified account
progression. And suspension
players you know the twenty
twenty two because they
will be available between
PlayStation and Xbox
platform and the
classification would be
available between organisms.
All these updates we needed
to be all time you know
that you prepare and make
sure they have a most of
which- is clear bases
together benefits everyone.
It will finally allow you
to play with your friends
across different platforms.
It also means that your
progression will not follow
you. Anytime and anywhere
you play. We know cost plex
he's a future- lots of you
has been anticipating any
real thrilled to see the
enthusiasm it's an instant
as in spite. I mean I
mazing found out. The- some
cost place their indices
community is there
lifeblood that keeps this
game moving forward. We
cannot thank you enough for
your support it is because
of you that speech gives
you all the Nintendo
growing. To wrap up here's
a brand you're limited
trailer starring Sunday
about then you would defend
the outstanding team right.
Check this out. Ready six
years ago I met the fighter.
The same night. That's what
this team. The stock was my
father's. Doguwa call we
check the creators star has
many many. Love wisdom and
bravery since you listen I
need to get this burden
there you try to get some
rest your device.
What's
happening she.
We that's it.
What happened next. Why
don't. New projects are the
only things to be excited
about this year take a look
at the incredible updates
coming to our live games in.
Twenty twenty one. The.
From the release of the
ghost experience to the
latest teammate update. On
break point keeps evolving
thanks to your. But that's
not all as twenty twenty
one marks the twentieth
anniversary of three
conference giants we are
happy to announce that
there are still many more
surprises to come. Stay
tuned. Just always been
about connecting with
friends and family you're
in good company there are
no bad dancers to move the
coffee table alert the
local homeowners
association. And let's go
out.
Hello my name is Todd
recall and I'm a singer
dancer actor director and
choreographer I'm super
excited to announce that my
song military of sales is
going to be a part of just
dance twenty twenty two. Hi
Dan. Do you do. But that's
not all nope for the first
time ever the just dance
team and I are
collaborating to give you
an exclusive version of my
song for justice twenty
twenty two. I don't dance.
And they- to me just dance
allows people to express
themselves through dance
and just celebrate who they
are and their individuality
and such a fun way just
dance has transformed
millions of lives and I
hope that this song brings
you all so much joy whether
you're dancing alone or
with the group to work out
or just to have fun it's
going to be a great time
and I can assure you you
will not display you will
absolutely slay the new
lyrics were hand crafted
specifically for just
dance. Let me tell you
something they're full of
sass but if they were
written by yours truly but
I guarantee they're going
to give people so much
confidence that's the
reason why I wrote military
at sales and now it's been
just dance. I think they're
ready for this jelly I hope
you all have just as much
fun dancing to this track
is I had making it. Oh and
one last thing you will
have the opportunity to be
a part of the making of my
new video which will be
released alongside the new
jazz dance track for more
information on how to
participate Dolly. Just
check the link below. We
got to go I cannot wait to
see you all living your
best life and being the
most fabulous you have ever
been. I will see you often
just dance twenty twenty
two. Dance. For three you.
Can call me. Okay you don't
know what time it is come
on everybody on the floor I
want to see you work.
That's cool. It's time to
get our Viking on it was a
big year for the new chief
of the raven clans but your
journey with a four is far
from over.
In November
twenty twenty we released
assassin's creed holler. To
our delight it was the
biggest launch for any
assassin's creed game
today. And we have you to
thank for that. Becoming a
for a Viking leader going
on a quest to fight for a
new home is an adventure
that resonated closely with
many of you. I certainly
had fun exploring England
with a four and stumbling
across unique world events
but left me with a
memorable side stories.
Please more amazed to see
how you dedicated yourself
to the biking lifestyle.
More than three hundred
million raids in total and
build more than a hundred
million buildings in your
settlements congrats. Eight
four still has a long
journey ahead and we've
been continuing to offer
free updates for all
players to enjoy post
launch these updates
include time limited
festivals new quotes. And
even a whole new gamer such
as the river rates update.
And the mastery challenges.
We had an community
requested tweaks and
features to for instance
will be adding one handed
swords in the coming weeks.
The team is also working
hard at tackling issues and
improving the game
experience for everyone.
We've been tracking various
known issues on our forms
and also shared our complex
bug fixing process in a
recent job log. We love
seeing your continual
feedback and we thank you
for your patience and
support for the game. On
top of regular free updates
we're also building on a
four story in the world of
assassin's creed full hola
through Gaming suspensions.
Rest of the Jews released a
few weeks ago. Allowing
players to explore Arlen
and battle a mysterious
cult. The children of Dan
you. In our second upcoming
expansion you'll get to
relive the siege of Paris.
The most ambitious battle
in Viking history taking
place in war torn Frank kia
you have to do everything
in your power to uncover
any secrets. And form
strategic alliances in
order to safeguard your
clans future. There's maybe
excited to learn that black
box infiltration missions
are returning this means
you're given a goal for
mission how you achieve it
is up to you. Expect new
abilities. Weapons and gear
and of course new and-
watch out for the siege of
Paris coming this summer.
Assassin's creed has long
focused on the exploration
of history we are happy to
announce that the new
discovery tour will be
released this fall. Will be
free to all who own
assassin's creed via holler.
Explore the world and take
a deeper dive into the
history of the Viking age.
The team has crafted a new
experience where you'll get
to play as people during
the time of Vikings. And
follow them in their
endeavors big and small.
Collecting exclusive
rewards. Whether you're in
assassin's creed fan with
the heart for history or a
student looking to
supplement your knowledge
the discovery tour Viking
age will have you covered.
Assassin's creed Mulholland
doesn't stop here for the
first time on an assassin's
creed title will be
supporting the game well
into its second year. Well
this year will be a very
active your for the game
we're already working on
more expansions for next
year. Something tells me
that even more is not done
with.
So you see some great
games from us we'll 5 news
about the movies and TV
series we've been working
on. Are you B. saw film
Intellivision team has some
exclusive content to share
up first is met the quest
the workplace comedy set in
a game development studio
the streaming on apple TV
plus. If you haven't
watched the second season
yet here's a look at what
you've been missing before
the upcoming season finale.
This is an involuntary
reaction to being inspired.
That's it that's it that's
it except make it about me
and not the world. We feel
really seen and heard I
don't want to see you or
hear. To get what she
wanted she expired she the
motion we manipulated us.
UP next is an exclusive
look at a new trailer for a
feature length movie
wearables with it it's a
whodunit with T. thirty
coming to theaters June
twenty fifth. And on demand
July second. Hello everyone
I am Josh Rubin the
director of wearables
within. And I'm Sam
Richardson the star where
was within. Where was it
was based off Ubisoft
Gaming we're so excited to
bring you an exclusive look
just for you. Check it out.
Dr Ellis. Until this is
probably thanks. We need
answers it didn't disappear.
To dispatch. What it's not
Emerson flint. It's one of
the U. okay what what. We
don't understand where
hello my friend I can't do
that ranger Wheeler you
could be one of them. One
of what. What where will.
The roads are yeah. Coming
from with the generator.
Also there's a dead body in
your porch. Because. Is
packing. Sleepover with
guns with guns yes.
Everybody's going how the
heck. Littering and just
excited managing just
watching. Follow me the
question apple TV plus and
be sure to catch wearables
within this summer in
theaters are on your on
demand platforms. No hero
story is complete without a
great rival to match them
after all even the most
vile tyrant is the star of
their own narrative. When
it comes to memorable
villains no one does it
better than far cry. Please
we have to get on that.
What the hell I'm going to
do with baseball cards have
any idea what these are
worth less to. Yeah monocle.
Always making new friends.
Your late. With a little.
He gave up his ticket.
First family all set hello
the non fund hello I was
not going anywhere anymore.
Come on. Let them on. But
could not. Addresses don't
worry about it to
michael highgam. It sort of
got. This is a great ninety
we should be fighting up
running to the young keys
hello gave you a **** gift
Lida we survive same as the
orphanage same as the
economy. No no. No no no.
Before he was added but I
see that me pop pop love to
fish. We would go out on a
boat just like this and we
would catch fish and then.
Release them. It was say
it's not always a ball your
storm in the whole. V.
sobotu. Challenge except
when he called. Juicy
Bartlett. To let that go.
I've got a very big fish
today I. Have a nine Diego.
No Way. Welcome me home.
Now it's time to bring your
own. I don't want this
anymore but by we have no
choice. Let them go. They
can work make me feel. True
they could be good workers.
They could help rebuild but
I use. You want to leave.
You said okay. Thirteen
years old. And Diego has
such. Sure for his people.
These fish. We will catch
every place.
You've just
seen another disturbing
lesson from Anton guests
you. Passed down to his son
Diego I see grooms him to
become the future ruler of
Yara. The most important
part of crafting a far cry
villain isn't the fact that
they're evil or shocking is
that there's someone that
could sit across from you
at the dinner table and
charm you into thinking
that everything they
believe no matter how
twisted or horrifying could
be absolutely true. That's
the secret joins us by our
and we couldn't be prouder
to have him join the fight
cry family. Now when
creating ants on we had
quite a lot to live up to.
Because when you think far
cry you think about the
streets legacy of violence.
Which makes today F. very
special day for far cry
fans. Not only did we get
to see into the minds of
Fenton Casteel we finally
get certain face some of
our post launch plans. Our
dream was to wonder defy
cry finance tradition and
introduce a brand new
experience. It is time to
see the other side. Go
further down the rabbit
hole and it's up to you.
Find a way out. Tell your
mother insisted. You. That
is. Full. M. to a machine
who isn't afraid to slot to
get what he wants. Is this
a tax. Three which- and I
will not waste.
Definition.
We're so excited for you
all to check out this next
game Neil I can't wait to
get my hands on this one.
They hold the month is
super proud of these new
gate and I can't wait for
you to experience. It's
fair to say that we did
something quite surprising
but the concept of Mario
plus rabbits kingdom battle
and for this project we
didn't want to stop there.
Hi everyone. And I'm so
excited to be back as well
today 1 veal our new
project Mario
blessing Adeoye Spock's of
we are diving back into
these unique crossover with
even began bichon expanding
our universe when a major
scale this time it's not
just the mushroom kingdom
there's an entire galaxy.
To do so you will lead a
brain Jeff Bakalar steam
off unique here. Including
some fresh faces like
Alberta's Lena and other
surprises on their quest to
apple evil across the
galaxy. This species we
bring them from planet to
planet they will be facing
a powerful villain.
Curbside and then to me
unlike any fee a lot. He
also encountered before.
What do you want to be a
little by deskside they
will have to have new
allies this box. The
surprising trade shows bond
from the manager of 5 beats
and Lumos we land their
wives powerhouse well well
he- the NHL's and origin I
had to call off I once
thought. Fox let's keep
some surprises for later.
After the tremendous
success of Mario plus
rabbits kingdom battle the
entire team was moved by
the amazing reception from
players across the world we
were stunned by the love we
fell for this unexpected
team up. We know it's been
off the radar for a while
now as we wanted to take
the time needed to bring
this cross over to the next
level. It's not just a new
story with new enemies new
heroes Mario plus rabbit
sparks of hope has big
ambitions it introduces new
action elements into the
mix that will push the
boundaries of tactical
games. Even further. That
being said we also wish to
offer an easy to play
experience for all players.
Yet hard to master for
those of you that are
willing to take the
challenge and you'll be
able to experience this
cosmic adventure
exclusively on the Nintendo
switch. We can't wait to
tell you more about the
game soon. Does the entire
galaxy and we cannot wait
for you to experience.
So
we're not done yet let's
check in with our CEO even
email. Hi everyone as you
have seen the we have a
fantastic and diverse line
up of games coming soon.
And this is just the
beginning. Thanks to all
the teams are to be soft
for what they achieved and
for always striving to
deliver the best possible
game experiences. I'm
ambled by their resilience
energy and collaboration.
Really during what has been
a challenging year. I'm
also proud of I would
industry's ability to bring
together millions of
players from around the
world to share memorable
experiences. And moments of
joy PC is one of the real
hours of video games. Any
keys what motivates
everyone to be soft to do
our best. Finally my
sincere thanks to you the
players. We appreciate the
trust you place in us. Your
involvement in our games
communities keep them
growing and vibrant. We
want to create original
enriching the only lasting
gamer. And your
contributions back on
support make it possible.
We also approach that's
some of the biggest names
in entertainment. Trust our
creative teams to develop
games within day university.
For example you're just so
Mario press rabbits fox
hello developed in
collaboration with Nintendo
where everyone's favorites
Mario and Rabbids
characters return for an
all new adventure. And
speaking of great also
ships there is one more
exciting seeing we would
like to show you today. It
is a glimpse of the amazing
journey. That awaits you in
one of the most beautiful.
Good dentures places of.
Brought to life by delayed
his version of it with no
drop in June I'm excited to
share the first look we do
not. Enjoy.
And.
Thanks to
even all the dads that
joined us to share what's
new with you stocks. Today
fourteenth in rainbow six
extraction. Learn some new
songs and rockstar. On the
drenalin Russian writers
are public little the dance
floor and just finance one
twenty two. Is it a new
shorts and assassin's creed
Bala. When is the chilling
confrontation for cry six
intime double their
favorite man in overalls in
Mario plus rabbits. Don't
go anywhere there's still
more to come in the persia.
File.
Hi everyone welcome
back and this is the game's
wat po show for you so
forward as a part of E3
twenty twenty one all
right- I guess let's first
things first possibly the
most bizarre pre show I
think I've ever seen for me
press conference of all
time. Just a lot of slow
walking animations- times
you expect. Now and I can
only assume it was like I
didn't bye bye think they
were traveling to Sam
Fisher's funeral so. Meant
to symbolize everyone
journeying from across the
Ubisoft universes. Later
arrested one of the all
time greats who is suddenly
dad and will not be coming
back. Yeah I mean I know
that we can. We were
bracing ourselves with some
announcements and I think
we all kind of clinging on
to the hope that maybe see
something from Sam Fisher.
A new splinter cell or even
a remake of an old plan to
sell- but alas it was not
to be however they did kick
off the show with rainbow
six extraction the big
title that we knew. That
they would be talking
about- liberal thoughts on
that presentation time will
come too quickly for us and
then- Phil I know you've
got some muscles on
extraction. Yeah I thought
it was a surprisingly good
like I expected S. every.
No major surprises even the
thing right at the end of
it all was kind of.
Expected to it to a large
degree. By everything that
you showed was solid and
looked interesting like I
was up for rainbow six
siege I think the rocks my
stuff which we'll talk
about it's got some. Really
cool stuff in there-
batters Republic looks
really interesting- Steve
is probably the only thing
where I was like. Okay yeah
I can this seems cool. And
same goes for just on send
an assassin's creed. But
everything else was pretty
pretty good Rehmat.
Reminded Mario Rabbids
being. C. the kind of like.
Highlight of the bunch-
that all those all those
people and vehicles driving
while also going to
Raymond's funeral. As well
as some faceless you-
restoration in peace. First
name Razer name- messed.
Man I should imagine if I
was like his son in law his
name is Mr. Anyway it's not
ten plus hours of Phil I
could come to you rainbow
six extraction what do you
make of what they showed up
today they actually kind of
went into quite a lot more
detail and I think we will
anticipating good to see
some gameplay as well but-
you played it. Yeah I've
been sitting on this
operation for like a half
now. Deliberately didn't
throw to you in the pre
show because. Yes so- a
little bit of what they
showed during the
presentation is about what
we play we're in that
Alaska map- it's
interesting I'm not much of
a siege player anymore I
played a bit- when it first
came out. And this does
have that same sort of
siege feeling but it's much
more of like a stealth
experience and you know
it's coop and it's about
sneaking in there and
getting. Things from the
aliens information whatever
and then sticking back out
and- I enjoyed it I'm
looking for a sort of PVDF
thing that I can jump into
and not necessarily be like
locked into a live game
experience forever. You
know it's too easy to fall
out of things like siege
another other. A live game
saying I think because you
sort of a few black the
time lapse you're sort of
like. Fall away and-
everybody's out handy right
so this feels like it
experience for you might be
able to get back in- and
stick with it and not
necessarily. Just stopped
by everybody else because
it's a cooperative so I'm
excited about that aspect
of it I'm also just into
the idea of working these
sort of. C. H. swot
mechanics- the rainbow six
you know squad. I thank
them. But with. Previously
enemies you guys around and
they've got nest. Kicking
out of the walls and stuff
and- there it created a lot
of interesting
possibilities it felt like
for the use of those sort
of siege. Abilities and
those characters- to just
be like challenged in new
ways and to get the
developers thinking about
new ways to utilize all
that stuff so- we had a
good time I think with it
it was a little too easy
for us. I think it's the
actual game is gonna be a
little harder we got a
priest through. So I'm
hoping it'll like. Wall of
your little harder when we
actually play it it seems
like it definitely will
because so much of the game
is about. You know risk and
reward should be go further
into the map that we have
banned- are we gonna lose
our people if we get killed
along the way that sort of
thing so I expected to be
pretty tough- can take a
lot. For your team to like
be good at it and- I'm
interested for sure we had
a good time for about two
hours. Of our- place
yourself. Wow yeah I mean
so mean even to watching.
Game play back here. I
really appreciate the kind
of starts off really really
slow which is kind of more
in pace with what you
expect from a rainbow six-
sort of game but then. It
just feels like the anti
just goes. Off and
everything kind of becomes
pretty chaotic is that true.
It definitely seems like.
If you mess up especially
or under certain
circumstances when you are
kicking off an objective.
Trying to rescue a downed
operate or something like
that. Things get hectic
and- what I what I like
about it is that it really
seems like. It's so high.
It can go to chaos when you
mess up. Mostly right like
you're sneaking around.
You're trying to- Scott the
area and take out all the
enemies and stuff but if
you. Trigger if S. if
somebody spots you like
they start screaming and
also the leads are coming
through the walls. Of
really is dependent on. You
playing well any working
well with your team- but it
also seems like it has
that. That possibility
where. When you mess up or
when something goes wrong
it can go very wrong in it
and I'm really interesting
and kind of hilarious and-
an intense way so- yeah I
think it'll be. If we
could- to kind of mix both
those experiences. Time you
played final rainbow six
siege than I have do you
have any questions like
bending questions you wanna
ask Phil about his time
with extraction. Me I hear.
The main thing I was kind
of thinking about was how
much of a kind of. Do your
skills or your
understanding I'm from
rainbow six siege proper-
carry over to the
extraction and do you think
that you can do why.
Suggested which I've played
a lot of extraction and
perhaps take some of those.
This is a mess those skills
back over his speech do you
feel like this is a good
bridge between the two
games. I hope so because I
would like to be able to
take those skills from. The
previous experience and
actually be good at
multiplayer I don't know if
that's gonna be the case-
what it seems like it is
but definitely your C.
skills are gonna transfer.
Into extraction right a lot
of the same. It's a lot of
the same. DNA that's at
work there are a lot of the
same- characters and-
abilities and- gadgets are.
Tweet for alien you know-
infiltration but mostly
it's a lot of the same
stuff so if you're
interested you're gonna
have. A pretty good time
jumping into this- whether
it transfers back in like
makes you good at playing
against other players I'm
not really sure if that'll
be the case. I do think it
will be handy to spend time
in there and like learn all
of the different stuff.
That siege has to offer
because so much of it is
very similar. But is gonna
between trillions in they
are definitely like. You
know very. Stationary a lot
of the time you have to
sneak around. Bill for a-
it's bill Frist Milt
experience so- I don't know
you michael highgam
packages sieging get kind
of stumped on. But I do
think at least you'll know
your character and your
your guns and stuff. So
we'll have that advantage.
Your final training modes-
Rocksmith plus now we
talked about this in a pre
show because this did leak
a few hours ago what I'm
gonna do wanted to much-
the one thing I just really
wanted to call out so I
used to use. Rocksmith
quite a lot and you all
kind you always kind of
weird tethered by the fact
that you had to have a very
specific cable that you
plug into a brutal and then
into your console. And now
the fact that they got rid
of that and it's just all
through your phone is
genuinely game changer it's
like a lower the barrier of
entry to so many people so
I just think that's really
really cool register for
the PC I close beats and
now I believe. I'm. January
this call to just go of.
Grab my guitar from among.
And trying to. One but if
you've- if you never try.
Rocks before because of. K.
thing. I generally think it
isn't to teach you talk and
I'm excited about the
future works with because-
it's one of those. This
will I enjoy yourself. Big
commitment to it like there
wasAnd god broadband you
know obviously they
don't teach you how to
put into real life but
you also struggling
with the fact that. The
licenses for those
games will eventually
get pulled because they
would only be support
for so long so Ubisoft
having this commitment
to Rocksmith plus is
generally very very
cool and I hope that it
continues because it's
a chemical gamer also
Tom view. That's how I
learned my guitar was
just by reading times
ultimate guitar. Like I
think it's really that
in. Zero plus I just
want have a little. I
know how to play with
song and it will way
too. From a number that
Starsailor because it's
a you know go on a
three and then I'd-
pick up my guitar again.
I was like yeah. Like
are you- I lay a lot of
on- shocker three-
through learning from
all guitar so I just
think it's cool. I'm
huge news is that this
is the first time
Tristan's has been
coming to the wish.
It's a long time
Nintendo officially Ted.
Yes that was not the
knees I expected to
hear today I always I
guess you just always
and I dissipate that-
just tons of becoming
to the we but I think.
I have a time is done.
I'm a contact inside
yourself and they tell
me that- this was
retaliation for leaking
then you Mario and
Rabbids game. To
abandon the we in
retaliation right now.
Oh my god- I think
you're gonna say was
your uncle who worked
Nintendo but you're
seeing as you have
brought Mario. Cervids
sparks of hope let's
let's go works or it
ari. It just like we
saw some screen shots
this morning when the
game links in but
obviously you get that
charm across in in
that- cinematic trailer
I'm not quickly good
gameplay. Phil what
were your initial. It
looks great I'm into it
I have no idea what's
going on it was a long.
Trailer to have zero
understanding of what
the team is going to be
about. But it looks
like it's a nicer- more
interesting version of
kingdom battle to me. I
don't remember that
game too well as far as
like running around the
world maps and stuff
like that so I'm- I'm
wondering I kind of
want to fire back up
and see how. Different
it's going to be. But
it didn't seem like
there is a lot more of
it in an interesting
way. With all these
other characters
running around- and you
know it if that's the
case then that sounds
great to me I really
enjoyed- kingdom battle
and- anything that's
gonna. Like I said. In
preshow add more
weirdness today's
already weird concept
is I'm totally into it.
I mean yeah I think we
had this is right but
it is very very
charming looking game
already I mean. I'm I'm
just watching and
watching that story
trailer and then yeah
when you got this. I
don't know who this is.
CameAm I don't even
know what that is
they were just
hitting everywhere
but- only the kind
of mushy. Frame of
reference. I can't
wait 5 dot that
personally yeah yes.
EIC yeah.
Organization
thirteen like the
one they will let
you know your too
much like we've got
actual hair being
an absolute weapon
but you are too
much eight Hey
nothing is my boy
actually use his
you know he's a
he's a very but
yeah I mean it just
looks super super
lucky and I think
the one big thing
that I took from-
would it would it
sparks of hope is
robin Rosaline is.
Energy when you
know Mario is like
come on come back
and she's just like.
Just like. So I I'm
I'm really
intrigued by it I'm
also intrigued by
Jason tries
cryptic- post about
Hey they're not
resetting what the
platform is so
perhaps this one is
going to be on the
room and switch pro
which sure doesLaw n
show the look like
there's a lot of
freedom of movement
happening in the same
place. For well it does
seem well you would
need a more. Consoles
run andThe switchboard d
been flying for a long
time so it wouldn't I
mean it was genuine
surprise me if this
game was going to be
used to kind of
showcase- the- I was of
the alleged. Switch pro
covering myself there
in case. You know it
was ola all along. I'm
assessing creed vile.
Then so if I mean this
isn't about how. I
really am my time with
it I spent about fifty
it is. And I wasn't
anywhere near done. So
it's- like I'm I'm of
got to because the day
looks great like they
always had one that we
to Iowa another see of
power- and it they can
amend reading stuff the
black box infiltration
missions but- central
these. Hit mine as-
missions assess mission
week it's of- she your
approach. More
carefully think they
were from. Definitely
need may reveling.
Number that was
telephone of deaf need-
I think it's really
cool that being rich
because it was a cool
idea. Because I think.
Assassination the I
systemDo it where is the
black box missions were
definitely more
considered a measured
so I think it's really
cool-Had in last year'sy
and origins we can sort of
like just wander around no
combat just learned about
the place where the game is
set that's coming later
this full. And then as I
was saying. Some finished
the main game not only that
to DLC is but there's more
expansions coming into the
second yeah which I think
marks is marked the first
time that an assassin's
creed game has been
supported. This long yeah
he said the presentation Mr
1 guys like in years tests
creaking. Yeah I thank I
couldn't swing that it
dealt with 1 previously
origins all to see one of
them because I remember
interviewing them there on
EIC yeah we're we're doing
this we're going to keep
this one going for two
years so maybe maybe
they've all forgotten well
maybe I'm wrong. Things
like long term that seems
it makes sense given how
much these games investment
of resources are required
for them to keep them going
for that long they need
more time to make the next
one so. Makes perfect sense
yeah. Yeah you're gonna
spend all those years
making just one game and
with all the kind of
resources that you would
need to potentially add DLC
it makes sense a supporter
for been longer. And also
the fact that it's two
years now maybe give me
give me a chance to.
Actually finish the game.
But it is very long. Maybe
too long some would say. I
me. Yeah for lack Ubisoft
take it down a notch you
don't need a lot 5. I
speaking- use of games okay
speaking 5 but I would and
I have no idea how let's
agree would work- wheels
well actually. Bloated
gameplay perhaps far cry-
we go look at far cry six
so we're going to kind of-
a look at John Paul
Esposito and like I said in
the previous year the stuff
that interests me the most
is the relationship with
the son who seems to be
kind of really in the
middle of I'm the kind of
obviously the dictators his
father but also kind of
sees that the people are
pressed and wants to be a
part of the struggle and
you know he's very much in.
So I think that's really
cool but the big showing
obviously was the post
launch plans so not only is
the best far cry far cry
blood dragon I'm going to
be. Released with. And
unedited integra. I love
blood during- and also the
making an animated series
out of it so it makes sense
to move again to kind of
bring it back and put it in
park for six. Hours is part
of a downloadable content
pack. Well it you can play
is all of the villains. So
everyone's head it's the
smash brothers universe for
far cry. You can be false.
You give me the other guy
and- the one as well Joseph
seed. No they're very. Yeah
it's just like if you look
at the veil over estimation
of the value of those other
villains like. Right now
both men having someone in
I and I and I guess it kind
of reminds me a little bit
of- occam's safety that let
you do the predator maps as
joker- requestYou calling yd
these these lads and tell
me that no in some way
inspired by the joker but
like yeah yeah we need
you're- not pristine.
Christina Dzhokhar would
you like to play as a pagan
min. Like joke. Exactly
because you go I know who
the joker is and then thank
you man you go thank you
from breakpoint all the
other. One it's I'm sure
it'll be fun and it will be
cool but- I think that the
far cry showing itself was
pretty interesting I'm glad
that they they had that it
was the definition of
insanity moment again like
we- said it was going to
happen and that was. Like
it was it was like I don't
know cat it the trailer I
can already see it is going
up on the Ubisoft channel
asphalt crisis six trailer
catch and release. Because
that's the entire like you
know point of that whole
speech so. It makes sense
that they would want to
give- the character. The
oncology physical character
a moment to try and- wow
everyone but- the more
interesting part of it was
his son was like football
is. Life- I don't want to
be yeah. So that was a cool
kind of I'm what the
implications of that all
now has me interested
because it feels like your
actions or it feels like if
hopefully your presence on
in this in this whole
Future is going to be over
like the soul of that kid
or like them. The moral of
that kid. Yeah I'm quickly
just before we go back to
the ESA stream we got a
look at the avatar
frontiers of Pandora coming
in twenty twenty two it's
going to be. I guess it's
now current Gen it's- PS
five Xbox series PC I
believe stadia. So quickly
what did you think of it.
What's great- I don't
really remember after all
that well long time ago so
it leads I had a feeling
when I was watching this
trailer. Yeah I mean I'm
into it that's it seems
like there's a lot of cool.
Angel there but at the same
time yeah it's been a lot
of years since avatar
happened- so it's going to
have to I think. Well me
and everybody else to kind
of get us to buy in a
little bit it was pretty
cool looking for sure I
want to fly along around on
the- wing to. Animals yeah.
Yeah I think it's a like
kind of saying- is
showcasing the snowdrop
engine. Gives one of
Ubisoft's. Own engines and
kind of like showing the
power behind that is a good
move. It's also difficult
to kind of get. A real
sense of what a game is-
based on a pre rendered
trailer. All right to we
get a throwback to the SA
stream now don't forget to
join us after Gearbox which
is a two PM will be here at
two thirty with 1 reactions
and. Far cry phil hornshaw.
What does analysts who are
people from. Bring the six
inch and also people who
worked. On the very first
rainbow six games over gas.
Yes to. And I think a lot
of people going into three
you're going to be curious-
just what an average-
mission with an average
hour. Of the six extraction
looks like- so can you walk
us through the basic
gameplay loop. First of all
it's- three three bear-
call up. Your squadmates.
It's a tactical game
because it's a Ramos game-
it's first person. And- so
you're doing- what we could
intrusions so as-
courageous rainbow six
operators you enter
containment zones- which
are mysterious and which
regenerates. Every time and
you have to extract which
is why the game is called
extraction- you reschedule
every time. You go in this
zone so. You must get out
but- with the information
that you're looking for. A
designer in a recent- also
that you'll be able to
choose when to attract- mid
mission if it's if you're
not doing so well- actually
you can extract at three
different places in an
encryption map. The it's
map is divided into three
seven OPS and it's really
up to the players to
decide. They want to go
further here's what it was
like transitioning yeah I
just never- that- interim
succeeds into attraction to
PVN barman. And how the
team decided you know which
operators can oversee jazz
roster of over fifty
characters now and I saw-
nine the machine so far so
here's- hi does decide what
what makes the cut. There
were different layers in
order to select them the
first one is. Obviously we
selected the ones that were
the most fit- I think that
the. Base for a PC EA. But
also able to play. As I
said you need to your read
his along a friend of to
try. Though- so- that there
must fit this job. And then
we obviously rework them to
make sure that- we push
them their full potential.
Within our again John rock
and within our war. Fantasy
why keeping them hiding
tactical. A good example I
noticed was- visual. See
each can become visible on
cameras- in the traction he
becomes invisible to
enemies essentially yeah
time. That's a very good
example of the adaptation
that. We made in this this.
Is the case fall fall fall.
I don't can say much about
it but I did also to ask
about extractions
narrative- how much how
much of a campaign is there
the players will recognize
or- what type of stories
being told. Extraction
starts three years after
the events of a New Mexico-
where the price I was-
seemingly contained by
different besieged by then-
but immediately after the
events steak creek should-
the react organization-
and- out of nowhere. No
reason- the process emails
again all in saw different
sites. In the U. S. so
react to- become
radioactive. And
Intellivision in a in those
four different. Zones also
for the front area as a in
the U. S. we're on the same
day. Six react. It
extraction alive server
game as my as as you choose
one. Evening you know since
uptick Mormon like kind of
thing on the- Tuesday's. So
I got three to much of now
what I say yes there is a
there's poster of.
Absolutely Bandai I know he
was on his recently to I
haven't crossplane and as
my as came as far- shares
of it's been confirmed
whether check have
crossplay within- on top of
that process princedom I
can attend for now but I'll
be very happy to answer
later. And that was a bit
more information on rainbow
six extraction Damon
Hatfield I remember
fourteen years ago moving
to San Francisco and bring
home an Xbox three sixty
and you in me playing
rainbow six Vegas did. So
many good memories both
endings to yeah of course-
and- this a little bit
different three with six
different today yeah but I
am excited for extraction
for a couple reasons I know
sees a great game super
popular. I'm not really PVP
guy though so for reworking
that rainbow six game play
into PC EA much like back
for blood that seems really
cool and also just given
the choice if I never given
a choice between a
realistic setting and- so I
5 or I'm always gonna go
with the latter so. This
extract is really speaking
to me I like it yep yeah
I'm right there with you
right of like a ice and I
played C. job enjoyed siege
but the P. V. M. P. things
never been my scenes so to
take like they sent me to
weeks ago. Take all that
information that they've
learned all those mechanics
bring him in here it gets
me going to and I want to
give their now
michael highgam you gonna
play. Yeah hello hello yeah
I got Blankos bring will
succeed is my favorite
multiplayer shooter like on
the block route really I
got it was a big counter
strike player and remove
succeeds as the game that
kind of. Elevated that
style multiplayer
experience of course
extraction being a way to
kind of take this the
fascinating mechanics the
operators yeah all the
different things that you
could do in rainbow six
siege but- it makes you
think about those things a
little bit differently I
know that- Jackie and I
were watching and seeing
how the operators are being
used. Because the threat is
very different than other
like live players so I
think that that they have
such a strong foundation
with the operators in with
siege so this is EIC I got
my eyes on extraction big
time. I'll be what about
you I'm thinking about the
entire experience of the
game because it's been how
long since we've had like
some really good
multiplayer let's go shoot
up some zombies and aliens
some whatever is running
towards us screaming slimy
tar monster man yeah
exactly right and same
thing with C. just like you
know. Your friends can get
mad at the people playing
against older smaller
surfing over this and that
now it's like Hey man is a
I either get good yeah you
know we're gonna replace it
with someone else and.
That's what I'm super
excited to team up with.
Turning on your- it is on
them to get a feel that's
and if they die then you
will work them you want to
sometime did you. Did you
we Gaming with. Are you
playing we need to if
there's for in the yes.
Okay kick him out yes don't
worry about that she's got
all these new G. four
friend I mean yeah. Don't
worry about it. So those
were the- only things you
saw. Into often we an X.
new clip for their up. Call
horror movie. We within.
Base off the game of the
same name. It stars Malani
vine troop and- Sam
Richards and let's take an
exclusive look. Hey
everyone I'm Margaret Blake
and director phone
development I keep this
awful Intellivision and
producer wearables so that.
I'm so excited to show you
the trailer for this movie
it's our first
independently produced
feature and I'm even more
excited to have the genius
writer behind it missional.
You're with me. I was lucky
enough to work with me
she's not to develop the
story for this film during
Ubisoft's inaugural women's
film Intellivision
fellowship. We are both so
proud of the finished
product. Everyone mission
wealth and I'm the
screenwriter of the
upcoming wearables with
themselves. I read in the
Ubisoft women's fellowship
and you could say the
projects sort of chose me
since wolf is. Kind of my
last name. The movie is a
modern day horror comedy
whodunit starring Sam
Ricketts and as a forest
ranger who comes to a small
town and a lot of my job is
the postal worker. Together
they have to keep the peace
while trying to uncover the
truth behind the mysterious
creature. Who's been
terrorizing the community.
Please enjoy the world
class from was within we
can't wait to check out the-
on June. Twenty seven they
were travelling in August
so you know for A. M.
sprints and I heard
screaming well let's be
honest the whole
neighborhood heard
screaming. To get a
response. I'm so sorry I'm
confused. Because if that's
the case but it's not. Show
a little respect what do
you mean M. I don't mean to
be rude but your dog only
barks at Jews and brown
people no cars. Some for
other just to get. Four
possum hunt. And that it's
somewhere wolves within Dan
I'm being told we have to
go to you first I'm glad
they told you that because
I do love a good horror
comedy and this cast is
lowkey stacked with a bunch
of people you may not know
their name but they're
genuinely hilarious yes Sam
Richardson from Detroiters
I think you should leave a
lot of fine tribe was
amazing improviser be
probably our best in the
AT&T commercials but she's
so much more than just
advertising cellphones and
they also party and from
what we do in the shadows
that isn't impressive
pedigree right there. Just
really talented people I
think it's a rich promise
for it because the game
it's all about deception
it's kind of like you know
it before others among us
are maybe simultaneously
you have a game like
wearables within where it's
all about tricking people
into thinking you're not
aware well but you secretly
are and that's exactly
we're gonna get here yeah
that's the thing about a
unity talk with cast how
stacked it is when we watch
for the first time I was
like I'll another person
another person in but
they're all the ones from
like the funny people in
the other shows like I
noticed the 1 guard from
orange is the new black
michael highgam you're in
the state. Yeah yeah yeah
so yeah give them off their
ego. My what do you. For in
a horror comedy. All my god.
Is it yeah. I think this
could possibly top American
world in Paris well now no
I've got a classic room is
not allowed money I'm sorry
all the shared universe
everywhere wolf movie ever.
Same universe I know what I
want yeah I'm I 1 people
with my kind of skin tones
to survive throughout the
whole. Movie that I think
that I can. Yeah that- I do
want that isn't only move
or show off to we've got in
X. clip from the upcoming
movie free guy followed by
a one on one interview with
director Shawn levy
entertainment weekly's
Rybnik Romano but first
we've got a special guest
to giving us a look at his
upcoming video game action
comedy. I think his name is
Ryan something well I can't.
Hello E3 I'm
internationally tolerated
film star in nexus six
basic pleasure model Ryan
Reynolds. At its core free
guys the story of the first
self aware artificial
intelligence Hannity coded
into the background of a
popular video game. Known
as an and PC. Front right.
But remember while A. I.
holds great promise for the
future it may also pose a
dire existential threat and
we should want to help
before destroys the soft.
Anyway enjoy free guy. My
name is guy. 1 sorry just a
scattering of drive bys in
highland. Paradises I got a
best friend the greatest
couple called. Monday's
right I. Work at the. I
thought I had everything I
needed. Then I met her.
Everybody except you he.
Please hold. Something is
expected you. You are so
much more than these are
okay fine. This will it's-
not really. It's going to
destroy it. You've met god
yes he's an absolute jewel
trust exist. We're not real
doesn't that mean that
nothing you do matters. You
can hear. My best friend
trying to help them get to
attempt to does not renew I
don't know what he- the-
this is the- perfect place
these people all I have. So
I'm not going to be the
good guy. Great guy. Enjoy
your supply of virginity go.
Good guy ruining the- in
the first. For we can save
our world.
Never mind of an
entertainment weekly
magazine thank you so much
for joining today's E3
panel conversation with
filmmaker Shawn levy John
is diving into the world of
video games as the director
of the movie free guy. Ryan
Reynolds stars as an NBC or
non playable character in
the open world game free
city but then become self
aware of the fact that he's
not actually a real person.
Unlike you body. Comedy and
a lot of action in scale so
can you give me like a
little bit- you know. The
description for him about
your and a genesis of this
project like when did it
sort of this material first
come across your way. So
Ryan called me we have.
Almost made several movies.
And I won't name titles
because some of them were
about to come out- but- we
had we were introduced
years ago through a mutual
friend Hugh Jackman who I
got to know one real steel
and he would always said.
If you guys ever work
together it's going to be
really it's going to be
gangbusters because we're
both Canadians with lots of
daughters in- we really
work hard and we want to go
home. So we're just we have
a similar approach to like
we knew each other a little
bit we almost found the
right thing. And in the
summer of eighteen. Ryan
texted me saying. Do you
have a movie for next
spring summer I think I
finally found her. Can I we
talked about it like a day
later he said. Here's the
script called free guide I
knew descriptors I'd read
it two and a half three
years earlier- but at that
point. All I saw was- it's
a gamer film it's a film
about Gaming culture video
game promise. Probably
there's hard more hard core
players. And gamers who
would be better suited said
that. But Ryan kind of he
said let's just talk talk
about it because I'm a
casual gamer myself. I
think this is an incredibly
juicy premise but let's
take the premise and making
a movie that isn't just for
the Gaming community let's
get that right let's get
that aspect movie right we
work. Really got. To sell.
But let's also make kind of.
Postmodern Truman show. A
movie about. Background
character. Gains awareness
of their identity or their
specific games that.
Inspired the look and the
feel of freestanding one of
the more- birth 1 is Grand
Theft Auto first sure-
Fortnite was another big
what was fun about yes. I
remember early on. Was fine
is the random little
tidbits of inspiration so
for instance I don't. Okay-
okay. Kind of sharing this
EIC early on I was
obviously I make stranger
things that's kind of my on
going. Okay and so EIC
shows descriptive free
guide to the brothers to
the duffer brothers Matt
and Ross you were close
friends at this point. And
I would because they play a
lot- mac in particular
plays a lot of you need
music you know it always
drives us crazy and I think
it was I think you
mentioned was in spider man
like there's this one old
lady. Who's like she's like
an NBC which is like a side
mission she just always
**** about her lost tax you
know we should do. There
should be like a character
like that. And so in free
guy we created this and PC
who is wandering around the
city looking for her cats-
and it was just kind of a-
I really there's a perfect
example of like I'll take a
good idea from anywhere all
take inspiration. From
anywhere and- I know
remember like- there's lot
I don't know. There's a lot
of movies I haven't seen
the games I'm playing so.
That's another example. I
also want to stay neck
like. We were supposed to
come to E3 and we had this
whole plan. Last year
actually Ryan and I to come
with a free guide I want to
show the old movie you guys
and- you know this is
obviously. The heart of the
world. That we work every
day cognizance of making
movie. Making movie that is
different from the other
video game movies because
as we said this is an
adaptation it's not literal
to anything. But hopefully
it's authentic to
everything. And hopefully
it's authentic to not only
J. but more importantly
maybe to the culture of
Gaming- and that community.
And how passionate. Right
like people really care.
They care about what
they're playing they care
about the way that that
world in those games are
represented and talked
about. And you know for me.
I don't want to do anything
half past I want to.
Connect with the community
they can't. In a passionate
way and- hopefully we've
done we set out to do which
is to make a movie where
that community feels like.
Okay that's one for us and
we got it right. Also
thanks so much John for
joining us today for E3
panel and for everyone
watching at home. Three guy
will be released in
theaters this August.
Thirty enjoyed. And that
was your deep dive on free
guy- movie we've heard
about forever you know I
mean this whole pesky
pandemic on the way. But
it's finally coming out in
August abi I need to ask
you. Am I allowed to be
excited for it we've been
burned as gamers buy movie
so many times like this
looks interesting and funny
and it's got shown and it's
got run and like why would
we like that I feel like
because it's a comedy and
because like we've- we
heard from the director
like he's- done his
research into the culture
and- also the fact that
Ryan Reynolds is involved
with it and we saw those
work on Deadpool like. He
really went through
Deadpool and became that
character yeah I think that
we can get excited okay I
I'm feeling optimistic
about it okay I heard that
there was a bunch of
streamers with cameos like.
Booking a- job except the
guys I mean that god. Will
do but I mean like I feel
like there is so. Gaming
culture has gotten so much
younger now that finally
legal will Coley was paying
attention and they're gonna
try to jump in on it but-
even if this one is like.
Okay that opens the doors
to find thank someone
something that's like even
better yeah right exactly
that makes perfect sense
now Damon Hatfield from IGN
dot com you host a show
called gamer skew. Yeah I
hear you. PC for you. This
a this is a- you can all.
Find a cameo for former I
Future. Shorts in a- and in
an alternate universe it
with me- because they 1
have some Gaming media in
the film it resets IGN and
the idea was floated for me
to do it by I couldn't make
it for some reason that a
conflict they're shooting
on location couldn't fit in
my schedule so Terry went
instead and so it's not
there is gonna be in the
movie. Wow and then she
quit IGN. Because the big
movie star. We're gonna do
this. Michael highgam is
this going to be when you
blessing Adeoye Future C.
yes. Okay okay. Will bless
I were talking about how.
It's been a while going
into a Future nowadays it's
only right and I like going
into Future with there's
nobody there to solve
highway a little while and
then say okay now the fears
of cleared up shares and I
can get receipts together
we can track how corn yeah
let me know so what you
doing when this game was
game. With this movie comes
out so yeah. Yeah I wanna
hang out with my bro. Okay.
Good I'll take a styrofoam
out get the starter. And
yeah. See this one. A nice.
I can't wait to see this in
a Future because that
trailer looks like so much
spectacle the kind of which
I don't really want to see
on the big screen because-
I've been missing that so
many movies that have come
out. I'm very grateful to
be able to watch them at
home but- it can't
replicate the sheer thrill
of seeing it with. Other
people on a screen. The
size of several times my
apartment. So I'm like very
thrilled to see that. And
also I I'm putting my trust
in Ryan Reynolds here
because- this is not his
first video game movie
rodeo he did Pokemon
detective Pikachu is far
greater. It's a very active
role in this project so.
I'm hopeful that they can.
Have a good time to really
lampoons and the stuff that
we like to make fun of it
video games in those trips
and things like that. But
on this sort of blank slate
bunch of other people like
Jerry Comerica EIC white
TV. Really stacked cast as
well. Good point. I'm
hopeful. I'm hopeful all
right let's see we can do
everything. I get out there
watching the fears they
were talking about for
right now keep watching
your- small devices you
watch E3 with us. Hot
friends. What a great start
to think. About golden boy
Jackie what do you guys
think of these movie
trailers we just saw.
Absolutely loved it. So
much comedy. Involves video
games we're- absolutely
here for it- let's. Dive
right- yeah. I think we
make fun of them PC is a
lot. Let's be honest all
the- time. The end.
Enlisting they never do the
things you want them to do.
You know. An escort
missions. Whites make an
escort mission people.
Blackheart I know but-
what's fun about this is
not. Okay the MPC. Is
sentence. And he's just
absolutely adorable
hysterical he's played by
Ryan Reynolds and I just
feel like Ryan Reynolds can
do no wrong- Deadpool
Deadpool two. We are doing
Casey talking about
detective Pikachu- I really
just. Anything well I mean
I needed to Fantastic Four.
But. I would not support
Greenlee- leader by leave
okay does my joke yeah does
my joking I messed up Greg
Greg don't come at me.
Green lantern. Talking
about green he's not. Okay
we're good all right around
back on the rails okay-
that happens so- where
wolves within. I do we were
going to be Jackie I told
you we were gonna be crazy
that's why we have you in
people like Dan. Yeah and
I'm awfully somehow tricked
away in here yeah about it
is quite the group I mean
you guys are literally two
wrestlers that are talking
about video games and I'm
here for it- so yes
wearables within also very
comedic- I told you I
absolutely love the
trailer. And it's actually
a VR game and I think it
was sent a mediaeval
village setting but
obviously they're branching
out here the yeah. Yeah but
absolutely hysterical I was
in stitches about it so I'm
here for more movies about
video games and yeah the
last. Thing we look for a
lot we learned rice was
reflected to active P.
could shoot like I hate
ready player one even I was
more plus a pop culture
yeah there was still that
that flair that charm that
was present in the movie-
and it really spoke to a
lot of us I mean I'm a huge
fan of the book- so I kind
of got a little bit of that
here almost with free guy-
which which made me excited
and then obviously were.
Where rose within I'm not a
horror person but I'm
always into the idea of
comedy. Yeah so you know
you put sand ridge than
anything and I'm in there-
from the gecko yeah yeah
and I'm gonna go and- you
know- fight great a long.
It I'm gonna get you guys
are gonna go find
unfortunately- but before
you'll do that really
quickly do not forget to
check out our exclusive E3
shop for T. shirts hats and
jackets at E3 expo dot com
slash shop now I'll go
fight yeah we're we're
gonna go 5 don't worry.
Coming up we've got Gearbox
software and what we might
see from them later on
today you don't new games
new trailers photos that
and more still to come here
to be fighting on camera
that to make sure. Here at
E3 twenty twenty one. World
of Warcraft because I was
so addicted to it and I had
so much fun it's still one
of my favorite games. Ever
though I don't play anymore
because- you know. Got a
work. My playtime on that
game was literally measured
in years on one character.
One of the biggest things
about were the work of that
kind of kept me going back
it's just the grind. The
lower of it is just amazing
and it's just. An amazing
game I don't think anything
could ever beat it
honestly. RuneScape of all
games I. Again completely
took over my life clearance
gave before school playing.
You know get a couple more
hours sleep and wake up and
act like I totally wasn't
hired. Psycho not. A game
that builds on my love of
platformers. But also
added. A comedic
sensibility that I had
never seen a video games
before. And just a general
creativity that I thought
was like. Mind blowing for
anything not just video-
stature is my favorite
game. Day he- teased us all
with the- graphics sixteen
many where they included it
in there but it was the
Japanese version of it. At
I wasn't mad I was like I
need to find a solution to
play this game- jet set
radio because I saw a
commercial for it once. And
it was bananas and I was
like I have to have this
game so I want to punch
shop and got a dream cast.
With my own money and I
went to target right
afterwards in the only game
they had. Different radio
which the game I wanted. It
was fate jet set radio if
you haven't played it
please go back in the day
it was on Dreamcast since
just because that was my
first PC game ever. Used it
was because you could make
I could make my own life
and in the stands and that
was something I'd never
really experienced in a
game before- definitely the
last of us the last of us.
Just how I. Being able to
play a game that's so John
droppingly beautiful and
immersive and getting so
wrapped up in that story.
My gosh took all my
emotions Ford all of them
into a glass and smashed
the glass in front of my
face. While I cried about.
It- if you smelled good it
was.
Welcome back to E3
twenty twenty one we are
mere minutes away from the
latest from Gearbox
software. Guys what are you
hoping to see from Gearbox
today we don't talk about.
All right. To hold them.
What you want to see from
Gearbox okay so it's two
things- number one I mean
it's E3 we're all here for
video game the right side
okay we gotta talk about
the movie I'm super aims
for border Ubisoft. Hi more
money. To so really quickly
I do wanna see cap or keep
1 shot wide out and just be
like absolutely stunning
and amazing. And then eight
no rest for the wicked.
Come on. Song and I just
think they'll be perfect
it's only need just like a
little walk out. And then
twenty eighteen is
Wonderland yeah okay- I
want absolutely love tiny
Tina she is just absolutely
not in the perfect way. And
this is gonna be fantasy
epics show. I just want to
see more and I want to see
what they're planning so
that's that's me those are
my two things yeah it's
just the echo on it. Tiny
Tina Wonderland I want to
see. What they do with the
mechanic supporter
borderlands immuno adds new
flares and their you know
of course I mean that's why
you know it's- you know
based or inspired by right
that DLC that everybody
love for borderlands two
which was. I need you to
tell you a story yeah I
have aeration right in the-
she is the you know the
bunker master here right
it's- going to be telling
you this. The nvidia
Gaming. That sounds awesome
I wanna be a part of that
I'm excited of course yes
for the movie because
they've shown all the
silhouettes for the team
now let's see. Here just
look like. But it also I
think we know we will pass
off and the Gearbox
publishes a lot of games
very true to what they
could possibly have up
their sleeve what surprises
they could have for us
today. That's a big part of
this equation even though
we be we jump to
borderlands borderlands
borderlands yeah when you
talk about you got to talk
about borderlands I get it
but I'm excited for this
one great. All right ladies
and gentlemen we don't have
to wait any longer without
further ado let's turn
things over to our friends
and. Gearbox software. For
welcome to Gearbox
university. Where
inquisitive minds and
culture compelling
opportunity. At Gearbox
university our aim is to
broaden your intellectual
horizons and enrich your
global perspective. Gearbox
university was founded in
nineteen ninety nine just
fifteen years after this
eighties orientation video
was made. We offer numerous
degrees across a multitude
of fields including socio
path ology supply chain
management and storytelling
with the European sounding
accent. Gearbox university
comprises three unique
colleges that will place
you on whichever path to
success is right for you.
At the college of Gearbox
software we can shape you
into the looting shooting
ball hunter you've always
believed you could be at
the college of Gearbox
publishing we offer
advanced degrees in Norse
mythology projectile
meteorology. For regular
meteorology you can even
write your thesis on the
day of vacation of gravity
finally there's the college
of whatever the hell else
we're doing with
specialties in that S.
bunker nomex history of
magic enlarged vehicle
maneuvering. And yes even
the Hollywood filmmaking
did you hear we're making a
borderlands movie it's true
let's learn more about all
the innovative
opportunities you can find
it Gearbox university
dynamic pioneering
groundbreaking.
Everybody
if you don't know me I'm
ready fits for. The founder
of the Gearbox
entertainment company and
executive producer of the
borderlands franchise in
all of the great games that
we do it Gearbox I am right
now on the set of the
borderlands motion picture
individual Namco
introduction we're
shooting. This is a live
sound stage and I thought
since I'm here it would be
cool if I walk around a
little bit and show you
some of the cool stuff that
we're doing. Let me this is
a live set I was working on
the move right now in real
time. Everywhere we've
been. In the caves of the
caustic caverns. We've
been- in the in the desert-
in the sand quarries we've
been in the stone quarries
doing all kinds of amazing
stuff. We look- this is let
me think. You are Jean-Luc
percent yes this is you are
author director. Hey
everybody this is a E3.
Members and you got you got
it right now we have he
doesn't dispute GamePass.
Well Zurcher this
hypothetically again we've
never met him before in in
the game or real life
changing outlets for the
first time it has been
restored our system you're
doing this thank you. Yeah
thanks you know look I feel
like we're just getting
started one is the energy.
This movie. Yes I mean it's
on the I mean we have. I
don't want to say we're
filming but it's lots of
blood lots of guts. Also
very borderlands I have
learned how to. How to
twirl of land off you know
what I think we should we
should yeah we can show
that this is. This is this
isn't this is. Video game
fans will recognize this is
the infinity. Of lead off
infinity. And you got
pretty good. Well they have
ones that actually you know
this one is light. Could
really learn. Yeah because
I don't want to. I wanna
smash religion Kate's
amazing. She can sites.
Where else can double
that's right. Jennifer
world isn't it unbelievable
she's. I is a god I. You
know that came from Jack
Carol thank you done in
house well as I saw believe
the funny she was and I
don't that she up the
grades acting in Jack black
and Jack brought up a great
comedy K. she was so into
it he wants to really you
know I understand from the
inside out like what. Are
the powers were difficult.
We want to make a real
great. Fiction we don't
make just make a great.
Video game. The rockstar be.
That's the key great site
you have to make a great
sci fi movies. And it's
really complex of from
Orleans fans. Who play the
video game if you have
people in your lives. The
do you want to use a
borderlands but are going
to play the game with his.
This movie is how you doing
you can bring your family.
Loved ones bring them to
the movies we want this
introduces a mortal and
gently left. We want this
to be like a gateway drug
going on. Fortnite fans I
mean the thing is the great
thing about the game is
there so much. That you
know you're you're telling
eighty hours. Every time I
mean people people can live
in the world. So we have to
create a different
experience and experience.
Has to be throwing in a
different way and exciting.
Things the fans love. Easy
best guys ever worked with.
But like just a world class
sample units of actors
that. Came in just to come
in and play and- everyone
is so into their cash. With
the with the way. During
spring creek Florian's
killing Arianna's. Times
seniors. Kevin is. A man on
a mission can't move. EIC
watching the cabin. And
going full actions. I he's
really gonna surprise
people think Kevin's over
the actual. And I. These is
a trend we saw. You go.
Going you go to our and-
come with me as from. I can
for already and- when the
producer. And all.
Legendary. You guys the
this this a I mean sorry
from our our production-
ari ari is made whole bunch
of all movies- you your-
from. With the R. I. from
Marvel right because I'll
be all right was the
founder and CEO of Marvel
studios. And they created a
movie called spider man and
then- Iron Man and. Review
the executive producer.
Your time and then- then
men and then the Avenger.
And you know. I think it's
gone from the use of the
most successful movies of
all time- for comic books
and yet the pitch you gave
me was. That was cool we
figured out with comic
books- we think that video
games are the next frontier
this. Anything for the last
perfect. And you and in
your flight. And how hello
idea was kind of a it's
kind of a jerk wasn't made
us work for. You work for
you were right. Right yeah
understand like. People all
the time it's a world what
we have to do to make video
games with different skill
set than what you care
about making use of. Ians I
didn't want I wanted to
make sure that if we were
going to partner with
somebody on the phone side.
That it was. It was you
people that cared about our
universe shared about our
fans. Are injured about the
character. The world. And
is going to actually
develop I just no one is
gonna collect options just
thrown studios to see where
the- business that. And I
mean I've- I've probably be
off for like two years
plus- yeah. Dating for two
years. But we do a deal.
It's been a long. Yeah
we're here and we're so.
And it's been worth it you
know why. Use that time
pretty well I can't I can't
believe. I'm really proud
of. It's it's pretty
amazing so we're we're more
than halfway done with the
shooting. We're about two
thirds of the a look at
this. Really funny shot-
yeah the trash we shoot it
behind the scenes I was
told that we can give it
away but I think for him
anyway from behind the
scenes we should get- so-
I'll tell you what you
guys- this is in line this
is our- deliberately. You.
Can't not know this we look
this. We can't show yeah I
don't okay some guys- this
could be an amazing E3-
borderlands the film is
going to be absolutely
credible- we've got some
cool stuff to show you. I
know some if you're
interested in seeing more
about. The the new game
that we the we have
announced. And and many
more from Gearbox
publishing seeking to get
all that- I wish I could be
there in person but- since
our digital. We're going to
do it this way. I think you
guys in. That you later
cheers. Among the many
innovative courses offered
by Gearbox university. Make
sure you check out
borderlands science by
solving the puzzles you can
contribute to real world
research studying the human
gut microbiome. Are you
freshman in the audience
here's our leading
scientist. By playing
borderlands three you can
contribute to real world
scientific research that
helps real people you'll be
directly helping our
scientists organize and
compare this is do do. Dr
no with borderline science
you too can be the
conductor of the food and
while you'll read in game
rewards when you play the
real reward is knowing that
you are making the world a
better place. Gearbox
university where not even
charging tuition. The whole
world game started in the
mid nineties it would be
the fast have a truly three
D. R. T. S. so that was a
big deal and you know the
late nineties.
The. Source
of. Rise from the grave.
Which stocks the. Hi thank.
Which K. your role.
FPS a
quick question we're not
talking about. Yeah right
that is correct my favorite
hi I'm Caleb Elmore and I'm
senior producer and tiny
Tina's Wonderland. So it's
really unique about
Wonderland is it's- looter
shooter which is pretty
classic for Gearbox
software but for the first
time ever we're sending it
any brand new fantasy
environments even though
it's inspired by some of.
The content we've made
before with the sultan
dragons keep the fan
favorite. It's a completely
standalone plot new set of
characters with some nods
to the past but if you've
never played a borderlands
game before you can
absolutely jump right in
and enjoy it just as much.
Absolutely excited to talk
about all of our new enemy
types- so that is one of
our wyvern enemies you will
absolutely be fighting
them. They're not your
average wyvern so course
we've got goblins.
Definitely can't have a
fantasy game without
goblins but again. Willing
to make the Morrow. Thank
you so much everybody I
hope that you are still we
are about tiny Tina's.
Follow us on our social
channels to find out the
latest and greatest news
enjoy the rest of the show.
This franchise been around
for so long. Here we are
years later and we keep
looking at like twelve
homeworld three. This has
to happen. The giants. You
have been chosen by the
call for the protection.
But your first task is to
find close that are. Drafty
your tried journey starts
in the wilderness hunt Pat
yeah the Razer resources
and explore the untamed
world. Once you log in turn
to your village and use
those resources. You must
protect the seed of.
Because everything would be
destroyed so take I had
things rise when the sun
sets. Destroy these docks
before they destroy the C.
each victorious night makes
way for a new day the
venture is the new layout.
To greater heights based
the creatures. And with
great restaurants great.
But be careful the Phillies
to Midgard washed by a
troll. The defense. This
because the giants are on
their way. And it's- in the
fall of destruction. That's
EIC is greater than their
high. As the saying goes.
Wait. Hello everyone my
name is Ron Marotta I'm the
creative director at
Northville we're just under
two months away from
finally launching our
upcoming ten player co op
action RPG tribes of
Midgard and deliver it to
you on July twenty seventh
on PS 5 PS four. And steam.
In terms of Midgard you
play as an online we are
the glories Viking hero
that's been returned to
Midgard in order to protect
the CWC the world tree.
Every time you start and
you run you would want to
go out and explore this New
World gather some resources
fight enemies and returned
to the village in order to
craft better equipment and
tools to help you survive.
You can also agreed in
fortify your village
because each night
creatures from hell will
emerge from the depths. To
attack your trees. Make it
through the night to go
back out to rate enemy
camps well in caves. Take
part in events go on quests
build anywhere and of
course Luke compass items
to gain experience and
level up your Viking. We
now have eight classes in
the game is with their own
abilities specificities and
playstyle. As you gain
experience you level up to
unlock even more skills.
Which you can then combine
with dozens of ruins for
over the top results. But
those ninety creatures
aren't even your biggest
threat. You must get ready
and prepare for your
biggest challenge and I
mean biggest challenge to
date. Every couple of days
it John will emerge and
walk towards your village
with the intent of
destroying the CWC. You
must stop it and take it
down whatever the cost
otherwise it's game over.
You can of course play
tribes of Midgard
completely on your own. But
we highly recommend that
you bring along nine France
to thrive together. We
cannot wait to share more
information about this ever
growing FPS I got in the
weeks to come. In the
meantime you can already
pre order the game right
now to earn exclusive items
and be among the first to
defend me to guard against
Ragnarok. Because as they
say. Well hello again
weights. Thanks for
watching that sale. At
Gearbox university it's not
old textbooks and calculate
sometimes we like to kick
back and have a little fun
a good sense of humor is of
vital importance if you
want to succeed in these
home here's a list of
sensible wise cracks you
might hear when you're
exploring on campus why did
the tribe of Midgard cross
the road to get to the for
some. Not not who is there
the commander the commander
who I don't know what you
asked me for. Welcome to
the home world diner a
special today is the desert.
Hello my god fallen and I
can't get up claptrap tiny
Tina and mad monks walk
into a bar. I think moxie
owns the bar so why would
she be walking it should
already be there it is
telling me to not old
enough to drink maybe it
doesn't matter. Also what's
the punchline and how is
claptrap walking. I want to
say he counts as a
unicycle. Okay we'll work
on this before we submit
E3. Gearbox University.
Park comedy school is a two
year degree.
This but-
tennis just be. You can use
to carry the burden of.
Five day. 5. Your **** is
breached reality. Chance.
The.
Mr. Just. You'll call.
Greetings everyone my name
is Dick Cain and I'm the
senior technical producer
encounter play games first
and foremost on behalf of
everyone at CVG and Gearbox
alike I want to thank you
for being part of god falls
journey up until this point
it's crazy to think that
god's law just launched in
November of last year our
developers have been hard
at work ever since in fact
this past February we
launched the massive primal
update which included new
content such as additional
rooms in tower of trials
primal gear sensible and
much much more but I'm
excited to announce today
that on August tenth we
will be launching got fall
on the PlayStation. Four
not only that but only got
on the PS four entitles you
to E3 PS five upgrade and
we will support question
place so PS four and PS
five users can seamlessly
co op together and if
you've been struggling in
the ascendant our trials
don't worry we're adding
matchmaking but really
match making in the PS four
edition are just the tip of
the iceberg because we are
so excited to launch our
first ever expansion which
we've entitled Byron
darkness. IRA darkness will
take players into the fire
room for the first time
ever will be that with new
challenges enemies bosses
trophies cosmetics and so
much more but along side of
fire and darkness we're
also releasing a free
content update which we're
calling the light bringer
update the main component
of the light bringer update
is a new end game loop
which recalling light
bringer in light bringer
players will fight off the
darkness that threatens
appearing on and be
rewarded with a new. Loot
type. Firstly firstly we'll
chat the player to come
pretty. Of in order to lift
the curse and awaken.
Basically if you thought
primal gear was tough you
ain't seen nothing yet. And
then of course we want to
make fashion before front
of god fall so we have
added a huge library of
cosmetics to both the light
bringer update and the
expansion of light all of
which can be unlocked by
simply completing
objectives in the game.
Thank you so much for your
time today it is an honor
to be speaking here and I
hope you enjoy the rest of
your E3. There's a really
unique tone and vibe and
feel to homeworld hasn't
been emulates. 5 prequel
start a remaster some of
three what is the next one.
We're glad you've chosen
Gearbox university for your
higher education endeavors
as you engage your academic
pursuits don't forget to
try out our extracurricular
activities show off your
shutterbug talents in the
photography club make
lasting connections in our
chapter houses. Or if
you're a boring person you
can always try out for the
debate T. we also have
sporting events but try not
to party too hard at the
homecoming game or you'll
end up looking like this.
Be sure to follow us on
social media where you
location we find free ship.
As well as news and
announcements about our
latest scholastic offering.
Gearbox university we can
shape your future. Because
thinking for yourself is
home. Now go by hello games.
Back I hope you guys have
an awesome presentation
from all the Gearbox games
in development Gearbox
publishing products coming
listen- I'm standing
outside. Kevin Hart trailer
door I'm just going to just
one minute I think I think
I think he wants me yes. If
you. Clans fans meet Kevin
Hart hi guys Norman. Pretty
pumped up right now you
guys- rainy she telematics
Albion first. Great six
three yeah and I can get a
good grasp of how much how
little. Your freaking
awesome like I don't okay
you'll you'll understand
click here for connection
thank you Mrs this is
amazing 1. You know. I'm
going to say- how 1 of you
I'll say it's amazing to me
that yep it's two or three
cats the role of course
you're very familiar with
this is your creation- I
think the big the best.
Thing is surprised that you
guys. Yeah I know why. What
I'm doing how I'm doing a
while doing it you have no
idea the level that can.
You got no idea how much
preparation outside into
this particular character
in his role you've got no
idea. You got no idea you
don't even know was under
his jacket. I don't. No I
did my job is to come in
not only be prepared to
shock nothing remains with
the door you're doing it
I've seen some I've seen
some pretty like it's no
one's ever seen you like
this for now I can have the
same man he lives it's
phenomenal jobs. It's also
fun to work with he's
working his **** off for
everyone's working
sensitivity and Mazen cast-
king Jamie. Arianna myself
slow I Direct de la Jack
black even the maze of
people together so sense of
the you you've seen the
Gearbox outlines gave no
for seeing that this is
something that could be
phenomenal shots out to the
world of Pandora. Pandora
no hours. No no this
commerce you you're going
to be incomplete all these
how naomi kyle- please
visual you know you're
going to believe that
you're in the place with so.
Have you taken a minute.
Introduce yourself to our
no problem going in here in
Lisle I'll see you in a way
room in here. Let's wait in
between takes. Awhile later.
After using thanks for.
Holy crap you guys this is
I can't refuse this movie
will be but- we got a lot
of to do look at more than
how down production and-
but you know what back at
home Gearbox all the great
people that created this
universe that I'm here
representing on behalf of
all the talent to Gearbox I
work hard at work making
new stuff so- check this
out and I'll see you guys
soon. Cheers everybody.
Just.
Will post show for
Gearbox software is E3
presentation whatever laws
premeditation with no
presentation. Look I knew
this a news publisher would
go off the rails that. We
start watching. It is okay
to not have a showcase
sometimes you just take the
L. and you're like you know
what we don't know if it's
show we're just gonna PCI
this one we have our
dignity intact this gonna
hang out over here we're
going to enjoy the fun
stuff happening over we go
cool stuff overhead we
showed off we should turn
it into trailer we don't
really have much to say
about this movie but we got
it so it is going to
childcare. It's okay.
That's kind of the theme.
Although because lights if
you're a soft also had like
a pre show that was like
wasting time like showing
characters as walking like.
There's been a few shows
today with like you know
you can just have like a
single trailer in someone
else's conference if you
have like. If you don't
have like five really cool
trailers but together for.
The conference are showing
that's okay it's totally
fine. Will be okay with
that just throw like a tiny
Tina's trailer at the end
of. Microsoft but that's
the conference or something
like that for everyone's
been there when they go to
a meeting and they they're-
often now- and then they
come out and they turn to
their friend who they trust
in the office and they go.
I couldn't email. That was
the very definition of.
That could have been an
email. In a showcase. And
it was an email I'm. Going
to email call. Well the-
it's like it's very weird
because I was we know
Gearbox is big thing that
they announced
unfortunately like the
already announced it and
they didn't show more of it
today in fact like looking
at my notes for the tiny
Tina's 1 the lines. The
stuff they announces that
there is. Does wyverns in
it and goblins let's. The
news where the thing like
we knew it was standalone
we knew is sort of based on
the tiny Tina DLC from
borderlands two we knew the
cast already when you is
any twenty twenty two. It
just seems like. You should
help you should have heard
this and like. It's my mind
boggles you should. Have
been held and it's very
definition of like what is
wrong with the internet
where everyone is like I
have a take everyone needs
to know my take someone
throughout my take and I
feel like that's what E3 is
now is just. Everyone was.
It was in. And showcase
that was designed and
executed to show Randy
Pench spread on the sound
stage for the borderlands
movie. And keep his Chabot
says Randy Pitchford and
frame center. For a frame
for as long as possible
like. Even the Kevin Hart
was like given off don't
give a **** about talking
to anyone on the internet
right now you don't care
like he's not. I was taking
a dump and you came and
disturb me and now I have
to do the funny man
routine. The rest of it was
like the whole world thing.
That homework trailer came
up or they said the word
home what about four times
and somehow getting
stitches together into a-
reveal or anything it was
just. How homeworld
homeworld homeworld
homeworld three is in
development and we're like
yeah we know. Everyone's.
Mom this for ages what
you're doing. Shows the-
shows anything. This was
really read strong con
because on paper you have
like a lot of other you
have stuff that right you
have the movie stuff you
have borderline stuff you
have- tribes of Midgard and
you have got full on
homeworld and then the
stuff they do at home also
like splitting up and
having like a weed- homo to
came on two thousand three
moment here and then a very
very brief seventy hits
like why wouldn't you just
structure this. To be like.
In about homeworld section
about- tiny Tina's section
of our colorful like. Let's
go through what they did I
should talk about likely on
his team was kind of there
and keeping track of
everything so we'll start
with the movie star. So
obviously the borderlands
movie star borderlines the
movie. Is in production I
think they said during a V.
T. that they're about
halfway done it they have
an absolutely. Ridiculous
cast that is so surprising
relocate Blanchett they've
gone- Jack black and Kevin
Hart that we stole. And yet
and I don't know Z. which
is pretty cool in Eli Roth
is involved and- the people
who worked on the Marvel
movies. That was a ride
home. That was definitely
coming home but it's like.
I I'm not sure why we saw
this behind the scenes
stuff where they literally
shows like yasss queen give
us nothing. The whole time
it's like I don't
understand why we couldn't
just help this and have
like a big a beat later on
down the line because we
didn't we didn't see any
costume. We didn't see. We
just saw sound stage this
is very very confusing and
I. It's a weird to drip
feeding of information that
like. The worst part of it
is. No one no one got the
benefit of anything back
the movie didn't benefit
the game tiny Tina's 1
demands did not benefit I
told like they talked about
a couple things and they
showed the same trailer
that we saw earlier in the
week twice I'm not just
left like me were thinking
what you have got. I
doesn't make a good
impression that you've got
your own like platform
right now you got your own
stage to say anything you
want about this spin off to
a video game that's beloved
by so many people you're
taking an interesting new
direction and you've got
literally nothing to say
about other than its goal
wyverns and goblins and
they're like wait I could.
I could have told you that
it was going to have
weapons and goblins in it
if you didn't tell me that
I obviously unlike yeah
the- but the other. Games
like- the- follow hello 1
what's it called again I
can't remember what his
name. 5 so medical. Like
that the didn't benefit
from it anything I told
they showed off a trailer
and then how to do say like
yep yeah you can say you.
The world but like
intelligente any sort of
gameplay mechanics like.
Give give five minutes to
that game to try and sell
people on it. And then dot
had nothing and then it was
just it genuinely felt like
we wanna have. The movie
showcased in some regard
how can we have enough
content to string it all
together I know it's not.
You've you've wasted. Your
you've played yourself and
you play the developers.
That was going on it even
even gone gamer nothing. I
mean- gone full gospel
admittedly did have like
quite a big news being that
the sorts of. Quietly sort
of revealed that even they
did reveal the god full is
going to be coming to PS-
so that's very very
interesting like. Because
god full was you know one
of the few like proper PS 5
exclusives- for timing is
also PC right but in terms
of console. It was PS five
and so. Not coming to PS
four is great- receipt
there are way more PS four
was in the world and
they're all PS five. That's
cool that's a new story
that's worthy of it- it was
not no the news story
though. God fall god falls.
Every everyone's going
gospel of god Paul coming
to PS four that should not
be like that- at least they
announce the gospels coming
to PS four that's
interesting that should not
be. Your interesting. Thing
to come from your
conference. This should be
founded are you just like I
mean. Even a shows the
other day. When twenties 1
clans was officially
unveiled like you had
actually birch that. It's
very strange I don't
understand why you wouldn't
you know bring her back
which is key talent- it's
great that they were
talking to the senior
producer in the game but-
if you're not letting her
reveal anything about the
game then it's- that's a
strange. Someone we've had
these Gearbox press
conferences that are kind
of strange and meandering
visit what they've always
been entertaining to a
degree though. The thing
about this one is it was
stranger meandering and
kinda pointless. And it
didn't have any Randy
Pitchford doing magic. Like
if you're gonna I was. I
have nothing in your
trailer in your showcase at
least I'm gonna have Randy
Pitchford and it. I least
have him do a magic routine
that everyone can mean.
Nothing absolutely nothing
your dried the surface of
Mars. This no water. Unless
I mean unless this was you
know we we've been dealing
with like Covic delaying
stuff a lot like he's
employed all of twenty
twenty and obviously the
Saucony ramifications for
people working from home
Whelan's twenty twenty one
and I think beyond two so
maybe this was just a case
of they over committed to a
presentation and then at
the end it was like the Dev
teams just kind of maybe
said we're not gonna have
this in time maybe
production on the movie
move back because of new-
should doing stuff to do
with the movie or whatever-
production schedules shift
all the time. Maybe they
just like we took some
getting those done we're
not gonna have anything big
to show the showcase. Which
is why it feels that way to
me I mean this is just me
reading between the lines
because you know I wanted
Gearbox to have a better
cooler more noteworthy
showing and so it felt like
those interstitials where
you know you you had the
dad jokes were relating
into sort of Gearbox humor
you had the stuff about- it
was a bold lines university
blends the science project
that they were doing which
is super super cool. It
just feels like maybe you
should have enough time-
but overall we can it-
throw into the ESA stream
this is a very very brief
posts removal Gearbox act
quickly Jordan overall.
Thoughts on the street. I
earlier this week I said I
wanted to see how
Wonderland is different
from borderlands and they
didn't give it to me I'm
disappointed I wanted more.
Sam yeah I mean like I am
more excited about 1
demands and I have been are
probably Gearbox Gaming in
a long time and I'm a fan
of borderlands and I hope
that the team behind it
gets the opportunity to
show off what's cool about
that game and ready so let
at in a way that doesn't
have been thunder stolen by
literally nothing else
which is there was a big
light shot yourself in the
mac moment I'm I'm sure
there's amazing things and
I'm excited to see your
game if you're listening
I'm- yeah. Good luck. All
right we'll be back again
tomorrow morning at nine AM
don't forget I thought Xbox
pre show we're gonna go
over to the ESA show right
now and then it could join
and Phil will be back after
that to wrap up. E3 day 1.
At you soon.
What
Intellivision making twenty
three RD body. Sitting way
Chester dave jewitt. You
want to ask you. Going to
the gym for what's up with.
Solution a local branch
your ability think. We
should get package. That's
on the new. She. I tend to
he was on top. What if I
was how many GamePass. As a
part of life for all games
but we'll be bringing you
the latest Gaming news and
announcements interviews
with developers the biggest
press conferences and lots
more playful is ideally
online event that combines
the excitement and
announcements of E3 with
charity live streams the
following week with lots of
special guests who gonna
help us raise money for
able GamePass so join us in
June for E3 and playful on
GameSpot .com. YouTube
.com/ GameSpot twitch dot
TV slash GameSpot and as a
part of E3 official
broadcast the event.
Welcome back to E3 live
from LA hi it's been quite
a show it's not over yet-
we're gonna look back
ladies and gentlemen. At
some of the most historic
and iconic moments in E3
history but I have to
apologize for the people
who are going to do this
all right I don't know if
you understand what.
GamesBeat is it's a great
site for great people like
dean and Mike. There's also
a person there named Jeff
Grubb. And Jeff Grubb is
not a man you want to know
ladies and gentlemen but
he's in this video and I'm
very very sorry for so
without further ado my
apologies but here's Jeff
and Mike from GamesBeat.
It's the internet you're
busy because it's E3 I'm
Jeff grabber for games B.
.com joining me is
michael highgam not who's
gonna say hide all the good
people right now. Hi good
people. Mike it's time to
learn to love E3 again
because we're J. two games
journalist I understand you
put together a bunch of
stuff to fall my cold dead
games journalist heart- it
memories of E3. You ready
just take the threat right
now I'm happy to do so. You
know my heart only has
worked for E3 so you know
yeah you have you can call
yourself jaded all you 1 I
am just a ball of. E3 love
yeah and I'm going yeah
your windows yeah Chris. E3
okay Chris is past future
impressed yes- not featured
those are. Okay right yes.
Right illiterates. Be great
all right michael highgam
what is this you we set it
up just playing no they is
one once a the seven re it
E3 is from somebody one of
rows we're gonna here how
and happy all those people
are Jeff what I've listed
just to come hugs it can be-
degree done ray. Yep
everyone's like- so that's
like a game there right now
it's not. So everyone was
appointed but then we got
this. See you see that. You
can hear people you see
that the big sort of people
are starting to realize
what it is that's a right
that's fine. Even that
playground there like if
you no fantasy setting you
have to recognize that so
yeah it's kind of very
slowly. Dawning throughout
the audience I think most
of them who really like
Papa seven know what isn't.
Recognizing the yeah. Yeah
that's a great reveal right
they don't start with
clouds serve nearly. This
is when everybody really
knows. Even if you weren't
aware yet right yes even if
you're like a very casual
fans some who never played
final fantasy for. Yeah
okay I got a slight chills.
Mike feels. I know you're
not a- like. Am come on
what is this Mike. What
it's super smash brothers
mega man trailer- this is
the most excited I have
ever been. E3 I love smash
brothers but mega man is my
favorite video game
character. This is back
when there were very few
third party carriers like
this point right here like
I knew it was from that yes
I. I lost it Jeff I was. So
it's the gas my brother's
eyes watching with them. I
absolutely without like I
played tennis match
brothers make man is
literally the character I
would 1 in that game the
most at this point there
was no indication it was
gonna happen. We've only
gotten snake and sonic as
third party characters at
this point ever in the
series. You and always
great moves it's incredible
remix version making me
into music up the beautiful
CG art this is still the
best making as ever look by
the way. Is this like smash
Bros version of them the
kind of like. It like
captures the proportions of
the eight it's right. Like
it's kind of. She Mike I
I'm secure about things
that you love- it you agree
that I I'll okay what's
this okay. All right
alright mate okay maybe
this might do it for me.
This might be my- yeah.
Favorite moment from any E3
ever- I you know I've been
a long time long time which
is all the fan and- it's
always been like one of my
most important franchises
but I also agreed with the
assessment that they needed
to change things up and
they said they were gonna
change things up in the
delayed breath of the wild.
This EIC we found a new way
of doing things are gonna
try ginger I like didn't
really believe it- and then
they released this trailer.
And I was just all and it
might be the best trailer
for anything ever period. I
know that honestly this
it's almost just like good
filmmaking this trailer
like they did. That they
they know like you're gonna.
He's got his last
appearance in the last 11%
reason. It's really good
because I think about that
all the time I don't know
just the way they think
that if that's what you get
because yeah. Here it comes
the deed. That's great and
I had a good. This boy is a
Big Boy Mike this is a
pretty short clip you. I
think everyone's going to
know what is referred E3 to
us for PC it's not just
about video games the
Japanese trailers and demos
sometimes it's just about.
Personalities and this was
like the emergence of the
resonator from two thousand
and four I'm an employee
I'm I'm very excited. My
name is Reggie I'm about
Kickin **** I'm about
taking names and we're
about making games. Even
those who don't know Reggie
invented the big foot pizza
I think so- course it just.
That's what you brought.
You don't know about you to
talk about how like you
know import Reggie was for
V. you give the tent up he-
a big. I don't even I think
it was the big foot and I
don't think he invented it
but whatever yeah his
name's on the- he was it is
based. Staying up all
night. Yeah like I got it I
corrected it all right
before people get mad we
better do something for
microsoft now if ever there
was a sequel that was
anticipated. It was halo
two after halo one came out
now is a very big deal. Hi
this is the game that maybe
get Xbox I got an Xbox for
halo two- and once. I don't
think people didn't like
about able to see ending
right. Right now yeah
Clippinger stuff yeah.
Weather warnings S. as in
your twenty one. And I
think you know especially
this point this kind of
long uninterrupted gameplay
demo with maybe a little
bit more unusual right I
think this is what
popularized that while even
up till like two thousand
fifteen with with Sony they
have a very long I'm sorry
for download it basically
the same kind of format
right just play along level
from the game. Thank you E3
two thousand and seven and
it's kind of hard to
believe now but this was
the E3 were called city for
modern warfare was the
Belle of the ball yeah you
know what thanks for the
call of duty is the biggest
thing in the world right
now and still is and
people. Are excited about
it but- eight it. May be is
it like a showpiece for the
show anymore because a lot
of people are again they're
hoping for more something
more surprising than your
next call duty. At this
point. This was really call
of duty hitting its stride
like that number right
there people freaked out
about the what about that
also. We did not see that
guy in the call Grassley
got up. Net absolutely
destroyed people's brains
in two thousand and seven.
But you know it's not just
about gameplay demos. In
executives sometimes
celebrities can't even make
their way into your heart.
I met this really was a
moment wasn't it. It wasn't
me everyone loves Keanu
Reeves. When they got done
your celebrities. This is
for a new member crowds he
seems to be very interested
in the game that he was
making so it thank that's
an all you can ask for from
celebrity right just. Dumb
don't talk down seem like
you're enjoying yourself
maybe even actually enjoy
yourself and people will
respond to that and also
you know kind of be Kiana
Reeves that helps a lot.
Bring him out that's your
problem. That's pretty
great when we go back again
now. Our back to E3 two
thousand to see what was
gosh I was pretty young at
this point but I remember
thinking this is the most
excited I think I've ever
seen people be for a video
game like this seems like
it was by far the biggest
deal in the world at the
time and it's metal gear
solid two. Melgen also it
was so such a big deal it
was the- I mean. Probably
the best PlayStation game.
Getting the sequel on
PlayStation two- seeing all
this stuff and just. Yeah
it just looks so good. So
cinematic yeah. I look at
this point the fact that
we're seeing rain drops
like bouncing off of
objects. Like like the fact
that that's what all pretty
at it's time this with yeah
games just didn't look like
this before this point and-
and it was it was this you
know. Perfect storm of the
best artist in the world
working working with the
best technologists in the
world to make a video game-
yeah. All right Jeff do not
you want to close it out
let me be the first E3
moments. I do. Back in
nineteen ninety five again
the First E3 and this was
some these big moment those
following Saturn's little-
Sega's little show about
the Saturn and they're
surprised it's out now
would just confuse
everybody and this is how
Sony responded as they're
getting ready to launch the
original Playstation. Last
name. Maria still is going
for the three this guy
right here had just given a
long boring presentation
and he did that on purpose
but to make to really
emphasize with about to
happen right here first the
race is going to come out.
And say one thing. Nine
because you it is that's it
right there this is this is
them understanding
immediately this is
Playstation not out yet
Sony not really nvidia
games yet not especially as
a hardware company but they
already understand how to
do this E3 show come up and
make a huge impact. It's
kind of unbelievable and
that it was the rest is
history right like they
they- Saturn had to balance
the center was too
expensive so he knew that
they would undercut the
price by a hundred dollars.
And then every time
processing it would respond
Playstation would lower the
price and tells the sick it
just couldn't keep in the
business anymore they tried
a little bit a few other
systems after that but- it
was it was the young the
writings on the wall at
that point. And it all
happened right there with
with. Playstation
understanding how to play
the C. three game it's-
yeah see there's all
there's all sorts of fun I
don't even talk about John
enemy grads and- you know.
Weird out of school six
announcements years before
Weber CA but there's all
sorts of fun stuff
defamation. All the fun
stuff that's happening
right now it'll happen in
the future. Just a- minute
Jeff admit that you love
E3. All right affair not a
minute. I'm not just a
games journalist I like
games to don't tell anybody.
We know what we're telling
everyone okay your mom. All
right that's gonna do it
for us everybody thank you
so much for watching I hope
you enjoy the rest of the
show- I hope we can keep
you too long and- if you
tune back in you're just
getting here right now
you're confused. Good yeah
you we don't. Survive I
hope you're your favorite
game gets announced next
I'm sorry all right
everybody have a good one
enjoy the rest the show. I.
I am Monica and I currently
work for a Japanese video
game company called our
place- as the current art
director and previously I
worked on bloodstained
ritual of the night as B.
communications manager and
I also used to the box art
so that's just kind of a
summarized version of
myself. I always thought I
was going to be an
illustrator like- just a
freelance illustrator from
you know start to end the
end- art was my passion and
it is still is but I always
wanted to try something
new- all the time- anything
that would I was interested
in like comics. And video
games- just anything in
general. Me are directing
is something that improves
the overall gameplay. And
you know and also the game
designer will know like-
there is these kinds of
ideas because when I
started to do this job like
they didn't really have an
idea of what they really
want to do visually. So
it's basically like I want
to make this kind of game
but I don't know what it
looks like and for me
that's where I come in and
kind of help them kind of
feel that it. I started as
a fair and- I really wanted
to well I was. My artwork
was very inspired by the
games that he created in
the past. So at that point
I eat I knew what. I wanted
as a fan- and- with
bloodstained ritual of the
night- it was a game that's
based on gothic horror and-
the past- and- the people
that were working on the
past Castlevania games. For
working on. And for me I
was a huge fan of
Castlevania and the gothic
feeling of that entire-
series. And I haven't seen
a lot of games that were
like that and- it was very
unique. And since my
artwork was inspired by
that kind of game- I do a
lot of. And those kind of
dark Carnegie kind of-
styles. I was someone who
knew from a very young age
that I wanted to be an
artist and do this specific
type of at work and- even
even though I didn't
really- no or- I had a one
specific goal I still
struggle to do so and I'm
sure a lot of people can
relate to that because they
wanted to be something.
Like a specific job they
wanted and they can't
achieve it- even though
they try really hard and
for me I think that's
that's totally fine and
they should try something
else that's new because-
you know if I didn't take
this chance of becoming a
Amy communications manager
and also the translator for
the company I wouldn't have
been in this art director
position at all- I would
have been like you know I
we like no I want to do art
as a career I'm not going
to take the translation job
and- I still. To this day
be a freelance artist
taking on these 1 being
work that- you know that I
had no art direction
whatsoever in and so I feel
like for those who are
struggling and- you know
thinking of creating their
their passion job because
it's you know like if
you're working on something
that you're very passionate
about your you get very
emotional about it and I'm
sure a lot of people feel
very down when things don't
go- right or things that
they're- worried about- you
know. Doesn't get resolved
doing the same kind of work
over and over again so I
feel like for those people
like in a very similar
situation as when I was
struggling as a as an
artist. I feel like I
should try something else
as news so for me video
game was like my second
passion and I really wanted
to be involved in some way-
so I decided to take on
that job and be a
translator but you know in
the end- people when you're
very passionate about
something people recognize
that and I was both passion
about video games and art.
So in the end I became an
art director that I never
thought I would be able to
do. So I feel like- for
those people- take the
chance even if it might not
be something that you
really want to do as an end
goal- you should take the
chance if it does. Change
your- yeah. Great stuff
there of course remember
video games are so much
more than just making them
and having that kind of
thing you could do anything
to be involved in video
games and so if you have
the passion to drive- the
determination you can make
your dreams come true and
have some kind of job in
the video game. Industry
also- I've course before
that there was Jeff Grubb
games beat thing I was told
behind the scenes that it
didn't play that it was a
joke Jeff Grubb is not a
terrible person he's just
extremely old and shouldn't
be listened to. Always
German I want to remind you
don't forget to check out
E3 expo dot com slash shop
for limited edition E3
apparel like this because
you might be saying I'm
having a great time
watching you do this Greg.
Man if only I could
commemorate it in a way
that I can wear all the
time when I go to the old
baseball games the sock
hops because you're gonna
walk in there an old Toby's
gonna be behind the bar.
Cleaning the glass on paint
a picture and he's gonna
say man what it what is
that sure you're the one I
guess what's the hat you
were in there sure you're
if I I. two. You know I
know there's a big
spectacle take my shirt off
doing E3 but they might be
up to well I can't do we
maybe get a bomber jacket
you know. But it doesn't
matter Tom Cruise is
another movie coming hours
flying around we wanna look
like him but a guy.
Virginia gov Tom Cruise
went to. E3 noisy ago
technically. Go ahead and
everything else always
gentleman. There's so much
more happening here don't
worry about that one. And
there's no way I can get
the script back on track is
there because I'm talking
about the three shop you
should go. Do to rectify.
What we just go for Direct.
With more of our key. In
theme today. Let's talk
about the lines which-
Gaming. Cinema continue to
blur- Jordan Voght Robert
Jones. Jordan Voght Roberts
the man behind the lens
directing upcoming
projects. Metal gear and
Gandham. Sat down with the
folks at Entertainment
Weekly. Doc what the
future. Of these film. I am
these IP's. In the shirts
that you can get and where
the sock hops. Hello E3
never mind I with
entertainment weekly
magazine thank you so much
for joining us today for a
panel discussion with
filmmaker Jordan Voght
Roberts Jordan thank you so
much for being here. I
thank you for having me I'm
excited. To talk about all
things video games and E3.
Yeah I mean there's
definitely a lot to talk
about I mean people I think
it's safe to say people
mostly know you're making
found by constable island
in the- summer. We are also
a major gamer can you talk
a little bit about just
your history in the gaming
industry what was sort of
your big introduction. I
mean I was just one of
those kids who at a very
young age. Video games
rewired my brain you know
I'm a tough guy with I walk
into a room and there's a
box that my first instinct
is. In what combination do
I need to move this box to
unlock the door- god forbid
if I ever walked into a
room. And it was like a
triangular hi I'm a wall I
would think. I definitely
to blow right now to shoot
that I Namco clock
something. And- you're
working on a movie
adaptation of math metal
gear solid you're working
on a live action Gundam I
mean is it safe to say.
That your bill making
moving forward it's sort
of. You more inspired by
okay. You know ironically
used metal gear. Is
something I've been trying
to. You know Sisyphus push
up the hill for seven plus
years I that that game and
could you miss on the world
means the world to me. And
that something that I'm
very proud of what we're
doing and I think that it
is very. Sort of Kojima
punk rock- twisty. And then
Gandham likewise is you
know the godfather of.
Culture in a lot of ways
without exaggeration you
know like it is the
grandfather to modern anime
and thus you most Japanese.
Things that we love- you
know it really is Wildwood
Ghanem was doing on
television and animated
format in the seventies and
need the complexity and the
way to the stories they
were telling and so. You
know I have a lot of things
that I want to do in my
career but- that you know
those are only the kind of
nerd properties I'm
attached to that are even
announced there's other
games things and other.
Other IP's that I'm working
on but but yeah big a big
part of my driving forces
to be a part of these
things and to help rewrite
the narrative. Of how
people perceive these
franchises and how they
properly get translated how
you. Are you take a
filmmaker. Who understands
the core of what these
were. As you go through the
process of. Translating the
activist Marian so planning
game in which you can tell
a story in a way because
you are the protagonist
verses the- passive
experience of watching a
film. And so those are 1 to
1 translations and so I
think you really need to
understand when planning
game what are the lessons
from you why it makes you
feel certain ways what the
tone that it evokes is you
know what those real
idiosyncrasies that kind of
make up each game is- and
how you then translate
those things to. A passive
experience of watching a
film and so it's you know
it's just something I've
been obsessed with for a
long time and I feel very
fortunate to be able to be
a part of these projects.
All forms of- metal gear
solid you know I've
documented all of your
tweets about the long
process. I'm a thing this
movie I mean what do you
think it was about. In fact
had such an impact on right
you motivated to keep this
product a lot that game
came out same here same
month basically as ocarina.
And so on a on a
PlayStation and Nintendo
level you have I think two
of the most seminal works
in all of Gaming. That are
going to set the groundwork
moving forward for the
template of. At how we
transition into not just
two to three but then how
we- of all the Jews these
things so yes not all it's
very easy to look at metal
here in August cinematic
this is. But your your
dinner these characters
that are walking talking
ideologies and they all
represent different.
Slivers and ideas of I
think there's like basic
question of how do we make
the world whole again- and
they're all trapped in the
cycle of pain and- you know
to me the most. Memorable
and- touching thing that
still sticks with me yes
you're transported so
you're playing this movie
and- people are talking and
in acronyms and coding you
just thrust into it. And
you have this incredible
rogues gallery of kind of
over the top like iconic
you know Marvel iconic
level characters. But the
feeling when you kill
sniper wolf or when you
kill a lot of bosses mac
but up until that point in
Gaming killing a boss was
always viewed as a victory.
And that was like hell yeah
I'm past it and instead.
You're met with this moment
of somber not. And regret
and incredibly meaningful
and hit me at that exact
moment of my life for like
that they're just there
there can never be another
release of a game or
something that hit me at
that that those teenage
years when I was just fully
ready to just be consumed
by and transport. Solved
within the timeline for
year- are you moving
towards live action BAndai
movie now are you doing
metal gear solid first our
you know I'm waiting for
the next thing to be the
grim and you know whichever
one that is. Like I don't
control when the studios
choose which movie they're
making. And so. I love both
these things to death you
know I have other movies
and other things that
aren't EIC PC based that- I
also can't wait to go and
make sort of a smaller.
Thirty million dollars
saying were it I'm just
going Buckwild- by. Yeah
and we called the studio
Naspers group which green
lights gonna happens first.
Sounds like a plan. And I
know a lot of the details
like you know for both of
your project and I'm from
boxing yeah I was curious
if there is anything in
order to. Route your
approach and- I'm
especially because of the
quality and so far it feels
like you kind of propaganda
anywhere and start. I mean
Ghanem is. So a fascinating
thing. It's similar and
dissimilar from the
challenge of metal gear
because Gandham also is a
story that they've been
talent for forty two years
in the universal century
timeline in addition to
that they have several
other alternate timelines
with other series some
michael highgam on multiple
series movies some they're
just one offs and so my
goal. Is to. For all the
people who might say I
don't know where to start.
I want to be able to.
Create this film and give
them an access point or you
can say this is where you
start. This is your entry
point we're gonna ban say
hell yeah that is that is
my gun yeah it might be an
amalgamation of like
several of these different
things- our different
timelines and whatnot. But
this is truly what gonna
mess and this captured
everything I love about
condom and then outsiders
have this feeling of. And
it was what about metal
gear too but this having
the sentiment of- this is
something that I just
didn't know I wanted to be
obsessed with. All along
with our final few minutes
I'm I wanted to ask you
know. Obviously it's been a
crazy year for a lot of
people what does it mean
for you to be back E3 even
virtual late talking about
Gaming again talking about
all the products that
you're working on. You
know. E3 beyond me loving
games E3 when I was. In
college. Me and my buddies.
He had one of mexicana tech
company. But we basically
are not fabricated not
forged but like we didn't
really have any right being
there but we were able to
like finesse the system and
get badges and from
Chicago- we all flew out to
experience adverse E3 as a
kid growing up it's just
sort of this mac you know
it's just like fantastical
place it was like my first
leap of like I'm gonna make
a documentary and I was
like really fascinated. By
several aspects and sort of
like cultural tears within
E3 in how it's presented I
never completed the
documentary but that's
actually where I met a lot
of- these people- I still
consider friends today and
it was the year the PS
three was announced as just
this giant banner with the
slogan that was just
welcome change in the E. in
the chain's backwards so
it's a three. E3 actually
wasn't really pivotal
changing moment in my life
for us in Chicago making
shorts and I came out to LA
and I remember being at LAX
and I remember being at at
the convention center and
just thank you I'm moving
to LA. I feel I feel
opportunity here this is
where I'm supposed to be
you know you walk because
any of the massive wall of
sound that is eight the you
know Westall where you just
imparted left to right. It
really is can cough and-
it's a it's a- it's like.
Some what was amazing. And
so it really E3 changed
it's the reason that I that
I ended up moving to LA
like something about that
trip. May I never thought
of. Something about that
trip changed something in
me where I said this is
where I'm supposed to be
right. And it wasn't even
about video games it just
was about. Here I am taking
some of my first steps as a
as a filmmaker in college
trying to make this
documentary. And something
just felt right and so I've
gone to so many E3 since
then. My friendships and
relationships- as a seven
portion of them have only
grown in the game world and
to. Be collaborating not
only with developers on.
Marshall campaigns. But
also with their I. P.'s and
so to be able to be able to
be back in in in this this
the small way I think we're
all struggling with. How we
re integrate into the world
right now- and what that
means we've all gone
something like this is
great work home. We're all
home buddies a recluse is
to be like oh my god how do
we interact with people-
and so. Yeah being able to
be there in just the
slightest- and just for to
be a thing- it means a lot
to me because E3. Really
did. Changed my life.
Although I have been
honored that you recognized
today Thurman thank you so
much this is going to
create thank you so much
yeah absolutely.
As a part
of life for all games but
we'll be bringing you the
latest Gaming news and
announcements interviews
with developers the biggest
press conferences and lots
more playful is ideally
online event that combines
the excitement and
announcements of E3. With
charity live streams the
following week with lots of
special guests who gonna
help us raise money for
able GamePass so join us in
June for E3 and playful on
GameSpot dot com Future dot
com slash GameSpot twitch
dot TV slash GameSpot. And
as a part of E3 official
broadcast the event. Twenty
three RD body. Sitting way
Chester dave jewitt one
document trying it changes.
Going E3 gimbal what's up
with. Solution the divisive
yeah but I don't think. We
should get package. Well we
need to chill on the name
yeah. For she was. So wishy
washy. Degree that change
okay D. was topics. It was
a homicide in GamePass
Farrakhan.
Hi everyone my
name is Christian hollow
but I'm a writer at
Entertainment Weekly and I
am here to host a panel for
this year's E3 about real
world the game worlds- the
differences and the and the
ways they intersect. With
me here are our panelists-
Gary Whitta screenwriters
Daniel Erickson former
creative director at
bioware Juan Vaca narrative
designer at Netflix and
Rhianna Pratchett writer
and narrative designer
thank you guys so much for
joining. Interesting fuel
for this combo and I just
wanted to start out with a
big basic question which is
like how important would
you say is it for video
games to reflect real world
events and movements a lot
has happened in the real
world over the for the past
year I think we can all
agree with my sense is that
you know was all about
escapism you know yeah how
would you guys. Kind of
generally talk about the
importance of making games
that reflect aspects of the
real world special is our
real world is- is changing
so much I think that's a
very difficult question to
answer in kind of a
holistic way really it
depends largely on what
kind of game- you're
setting out to make your
right games- have always
been and remain in large
part escapism there an
escape from the real world
one of the reasons why.
Animal crossing was such a
hugely popular game during
this year pandemic yeah was
it you know it was like Hey
the world sucks right now
but forget about all that
here is a very you know
bucolic Adeleke place you
can go to where everyone is
your friend and the worst
thing that can happen to
you is maybe get stung by a
wasp people really
responded. To that you know
offer of escapism the wild
really did suck at the same
time in the last you know
couple of decades we've
seen- video games really
emerged as a legitimate
awful middle aged about
platform for political and
social. Commentary you
generally tend to see that
stuff in small a budget
indie movies and for the
same reason in small budget
indie games if we what if
we were to do next. Right
now think about like one of
the games that- that
deliver you know really
really kind of make you
think it a political and
social- thematics that
they're going to be at the
lower end of the- the
budget scale whether or not
video games will have a-
really data kind of tackle
political and social. A
real world kinda issues a
high budget levels is you
know that maybe that's a
question. For us to talk
about but I think most of
most of the interesting
work in terms of. Games as
an art form right now is
being done at the at the
end the level and again for
Canada. Your monetary
capital as reasons not
really all that difficult
to figure out. On that note
I think it's interesting
that it's- when I think
about the diversity front.
I don't think that
everything has to have.
Diverse city as sort of a
core piece for it but I do.
What exciting to me as- it
always feels like the
diversity that is inherent.
In the artists. Is
something that needs to
come forward. And we're
getting a lot more space to
do that. So the grand
exception. To some of the
concepts that. Was talking
about. Was working for
bioware. So bioware had
LGBTQ content. All the way
from the beginning. Because
I merrily gave Gator whose
lead writer footballers
gate. Was where. And he-
right from the beginning
posted S. as Hey I'm going
to have representation
gamer gonna have space here
we're gonna have FPS and
this was. Interestingly not
controversial and then
super controversial. And
then came to the point
where I just saw today the
by word changed its logo
for gay pride. Right for
pride month and is there a
bunch of comments like oh
wait a pander big corporate
soaps and all the old
school folks jumped at him
like you do not know you're
talking about. Right this
is a historical place and-
to Gary's point wise comes
up through the indie
movement mostly is because
it's easier for smaller
voices come up there. Is
the more diverse the
artists in our industry
gas. The more naturally
we're going to get diverse
representation or gonna get
diverse stories from a more
pure perspectives. Then Hey
let's put in. A bunch of
diverse storylines no in
where I can work now which
is largely multiplayer. We
talk a lot about
representation and
inclusion which I think is
subtly different aspect.
Which is if I'm playing a
multiplayer game I want to
be able to come and be me.
Whoever I am. But I think
that's a different space
then. Artistically
representing the experience.
Of a diverse group of
people. I looking for a for
right to suspect you a
great missed. No Way. One
to two to you Augustine old
because we yeah we want to
explore the process travel
we don't want to tell the
same story serving again we
want to find a new
experiences we want to take
audiences on a new and
different genocide. I
think- your rights as a not
and of the- narrative
people are. Often push for
that because it's just more.
Interesting to get your
teeth into. I thank you
once the stories reflect
what's actually happening
in the real world people
see themselves like through
their meat favorite medium
and I think that's what
really builds a connection
and we'll get people like
really involved and
interested in. You know how
you know doesn't have to be
in their stories. And
diverse stories I can be in
like you know like I said
like you things to them-
but I think it's actually I
personally think it's
important to. You know-
advocate for who tells the
story you know and you know
when you have diversity a
diverse pool of candidates
telling stories you're
gonna have diverse stories-
you know that have a lot of
coverage and it doesn't
feel like it's being shoe
horned at- do you think
that kind of stuff is.
Changing for the better in
terms of people of diverse
backgrounds and stuff kind
of. Able to- get to the
point where they're making
games you know not just
kind of the types of small
indie games that Gary was
talking about but- you know
getting. Getting positions
at and bigger companies and
hopefully not feeling- you
know alienated or or pushed
out. I think we definitely
see a movement I think you
know there's a definitely a
lot of talent- that's
allowing people to- tell
their own stories right
make their own twine games
or make their own indie
games or demos or vertical
slices that gives them that
visibility. So then you
know jumpstart and- you
know onto an their next
platform and the next thing
and- the then. We also
connect and we try to
uplift each other I know
that there are things like
what next in Gaming which
is a nonprofit that I
helped co found
specifically for that
reason. As well as
partnering with other
places like- game does of
color- and looking into
other initiatives to really
support- you know everyone
else is trying to. Break
into this field and tell
their stories. Yes when I
add something to that I
think this whole conversely
we can talk about different
aspects about the really
pot the same conversation.
We're talking about do
games. Well can games
accurate. Reflect the world
a world that. About do-
video game developers and
publishers have diverse.
And inclusive stops
actually making those games
you can't have one without
the other. Let's say that
the next assassin's creed
game. Took place during the
American Civil War and you
played a slave on up on a
plantation in the in India
in the deep American south.
That that might be a
fascinating area to- to
explore exams of all the
political and social you
know it seems that we're
talking about here. But
Ubisoft can never make that
game until they have a team
capable of making it and
speaking to those issues.
In a way that is authentic
like I couldn't I there's
no way that I could. Tell a
story like that because I'm
I'd I haven't lived. That
experience involves you
talking about the
historically 5 never
experienced racism. The
only way that I could write
a character like that would
be me being mimicking what
I've seen. Done before
another media which
inherently means I have
anything new to bring. To
the conversation it's gonna
feel kind of warmed over
because that's what it
would be absolutely I mean
I think it's all about that
instruction ality of like
where we as humans like to
Max and how. We evolve and
work together and where the
strength comes from the
drama that's in here and we
us being ourselves and
dealing with our emotions-
I think. You know it's
super important that you
know we do have people. In
the room that are you know.
She and read to tell the
know those stories from a
personal place of
authenticity- and even
having them in the room
doesn't necessarily always
translate to. That and that
will get hit or or or or or
or or what you see will get
done you know like I've
gotten shut down. Forgiven
you know land next feedback
on something okay that
doesn't sound like
something Latino person
would say and you know I've
been told I gotta worry
about is just a small
enough- so. Yeah just
because I'm there like
doesn't necessarily mean
that you know I'm like I'm
always like. How might your
open and I'm trying to do
the best I can for myself.
For the community for the
people that aren't in the-
I think it for me it's-
it's really about. You know
like. Using that new
critique professionally
trained hi end gear and
other not forms of it was I
was here I'm doing it again
tears- like to really test
ourselves and like growing
like make sure that. You
know we tell stories that
resonate with and for-
everybody. If that's what
you're trying to do. And I
think that's the real hard
part right now is there is.
There is still a place for
everybody story I think
that's fine I think we
would. Much rather see
myself at least love to see
a lot of authentic stories
across the board then a lot
of the in authentic stories
that becomes very samey.
Right to be honest labor of
the week whatever the
diversity movement that
stand on the news right now
you know this to be a
character represents stat
there's gonna be. Right now
everything sort of becomes
this sameness as opposed
to. Oh no we've been
telling a certain story for
a long time. Now let's go
get all the rest of the
stories but that doesn't
exclude. The other stories.
That we've been selling for
a long time either. I think
we had. A bit of a problem
in the industry in droll
drawing from the same well
sources- you know when I
started out in the
industry. You know I had
interviews where I could
just talk about aliens or
terminate to and everyone
would be you know that
they'd be the favorite
movies and things like
that. Tarantino is always
reference you know told
Kane. And that there
definitely is a need full
full credit is to broaden
that content is. To reduce
the content out inside. You
know that. There are so
many great- you have time
to see and Future writers
also you know on. On like
guys like and Kay Jamison
Ole and they DO colorful or
you know you can't walk and
the team behind into the
motherland's is doing which
is not which is not eight
AM. Video Gaming so you
type will talk RPG but it's
put together by divestiture
creatas- and your Octavia
Butler we need we need to
kind of judge rasa folly.
The sources that we drawing
from because we're still.
Growing up with the same
kind of movies you know
most of us grew up in the
eighties with that the same
kind of sci fi and fantasy
influences. And I think- I
see younger creators come
up through the indie games
they're gonna start drawing
on on more diverse sources
as well- which hi. People
could create more rituals.
You know how we you say
that- these. To reflect the
real world affect how you
approach- narratives and
narrative design seems like
the kids are already kind
of thinking about that
stuff. I think you get it-
in there in in sort of
small ways and subtle ways
as the right to- as a free
lunch right you don't quite
have that. I met with
Palestinian you're very
beholden to the people
you're working with- and
you tend to kind of EA
round the edges to a degree
and it's a it's a balancing
act between. Yeah I'm-
getting what you want to
study into the game or even
like a little personal.
Anecdotes and experiences
which I like to kind of
folding to my games kind of
personal narrative Easter
eggs and discipline that
kind of thing like- might
my father. But post away
from outside miss- he was
interviewed about the
memory he didn't want to
lose which is about the
noise I was born- well I
think he went home from the
hospital drank coffee
bottle of whiskey. Built
some snow shoes out of
tennis rackets belly ring
is not alone went to bed
with a cactus- and I think
that. I thought that was
some lovely that I touch.
In one of Lauer's. My in-
can rise to write and I
haven't been a big fan of
the follow that story line
and I've been quite open
about this- but and you
know unless you also
heading up the team it can
be difficult. To your push
for those ideas so you tend
to do it. Little little by
little when your ammo and
my kind of position and so
to. You know it's always a
it's always a balancing act.
And this becomes part of
the irony elves for that
exact thing. The people
most in the power to do
this. Are also the people
least qualified to do this.
So it becomes and when I
put something together I
was very aware of status so
it becomes beholden to us
to say okay I've got the
power I mean the place. I
do care passionately about
these issues so I'm gonna
go for Christmas but I'm
gonna go for a test knowing
I don't actually know this.
So I'm going to have to
bring in a broad support
group and I'm going to have
to listen to them. Because
without this it becomes
it's failed message right
it's the- it is the
Diversey version of the
hello fellow teenagers
beam. As the old person
comes down right. Awesome
well I think that is a-
fantastic note to end on
so- thank you Riana and
Gary 1 and Daniel for-
joining this discussion
about. The real world and
the game worlds and- thank
you all for watching.
Mental health I know it's
an uncomfortable topic it's
hard to talk about taking a
hard look at yourself can
be really difficult looking
in the mirror and knowing
something's wrong but do
not be afraid to identify
your weaknesses a dresser
trauma and do self work. It
can be a painful journey to
take on but you are not
alone we all have our
struggles and there's help
out there. We got together
some experts for an
informational and candid
discussion about mental
health and the work that
still needs to be done.
Hi
there my name is Rebecca
Valentine I am a reporter
with IGN and I'm here with
an amazing candle of hope
here to talk about mental
health I had. And it is our
keys Ian Gordon Bellamy and
Mike Wilson here to talk. I
need it can you please
introduce yourself and tell
us a little bit about what
you do and what you're
about. Sure yeah I mean you
guys are using I'm the
executive director of
feminist frequency I'm most
known for. A series of
videos I made cultural
sources women in video
games that you know ruffled
a few feathers back in the
day- and currently- we as
my nonprofit we are running
the games and online
harassment hotline which is
a emotional support. At
text based resource for
folks who make him play
games awesome thanks Anita
Gordon how bout you same
question hello. You are
what you're about. Gordon
Bellamy- I'm treasury USC
games I also need to be gay
gamer professionals the
world. Of animal. Life for
I'm all epic games one.
Also in my cabinet you I've
been in the- for a very
long time since.
Jordan Voght and I work
mostly on the publishing
side of things working with
independent of Albers act
most recently with Devolver
digital. And Good Shepherd
a couple of all indie.
Labels and the past few
years I've gotten involved
with take this dot org and
just. Anytime somebody
wants to talk about mental
health in games. I
volunteer because I think
it's a pretty important
issue and I think- games
can be really useful- for
it for improving mental
health so I guess just to
get things started you know
the last year has been
really hard on all of us
and I think you know maybe
it's given people and
especially in Gaming
communities. At you know
different or new
perspectives on mental
health so I guess just how
was the last year meant for
you and how has it changed
or not how you think about
mental health I thank god.
Coming into this year- I
thought a lot about how do
we distinguish highest.
Discussion about mental
health I think. Everyone
has had the opportunity to.
Take a closer look at their
own mental health journey.
I guess my hope. Is that
we're gonna move in with a
new baseline right in the
same way that we think
about physical health. At
I'll jump in and just.
Subway Jordan said I I'm
somebody that. Suffered
with on and off with
depression for most of my
adult life for an awful lot
of people- Gaming online
gaming especially was like
really medicinal for a lot
of us really kind of a
lifeline so that really
caught my attention and I'm
personally leaning into
that- pretty strongly like
the idea of- Gaming for.
For good medicine for
people to copy Mike I've
dealt with depression for
as long as I can remember
and I think that this
moment has been really
interesting because all of
the tools that we have to
distract ourselves- or
actually speaking for me is
like travel I travel a lot
I used to travel twice a
month I'd be gone for weeks
and weeks at a time and so
it's really easy to not see
the depressive patterns in
myself and being like it's
stuck alone in my house for
a year. I really had to
like spend time with that-
in a way that you know was
eliminating an interesting-
and challenging so my gonna
need a you both very
specifically mentioned the
ways in which for you what
mental health and Gaming
intersect and you know all
of us here are people who
are very involved in games
of people who care very
deeply about you know
promoting good mental
health so I guess can we go
in a little bit deeper
about what. What it means
for Gaming and mental
health to intersect what
how one of those two things
have in common where the I
think one important thing
to remember is that a lot
of people use Gaming as a
coping mechanism when
they're not feeling well
whether they've defined
themselves as having
depression or not-
identified that way I would
love to be able to direct
people to content. That
will nourish them and the
way like. We had this huge
fan. Hit the boulder called
fall guys. That wasn't.
Treated necessarily to be
medicine for people but I
wasn't a lot of the
feedback we got from all
over the world because it
came out right at the
height of lockdown. Right
when people are starting to
break in the summer. And I.
Would just reinforcement
that like there are. For me
media is like- just another
kind of nutrition. And
there's junk food. And
there's good food. Right I
think sometimes. I struggle
to talk about that like.
Games in mental health in
the connections in the like
there there are a 100% but-
I am so much more
interested in how we bring
existing mental health
infrastructure into the
Gaming space- and how you
know so we can. So I'm
gonna just keep plugging my
hot lead because- you but
one of the things we do at
the hotline is. We train
our agents who are
answering your text
messages to have a cultural
competency in games. So we
make sure that they can
speak your language when
they speak the language
that it will be understood
by you or that you know
they will understand when
you reach out to you don't
you don't need to explain.
What twitches or discord is
you don't need to explain
the infrastructure of your
own needs in order to get
the support and I think
that that is so important
because so many of us are
like. Extremely online and
we engage with games and
online spaces in a very
particular way that the
folks who are not. Just
don't. Speak the same
language even though they
want to support us it's so
important that there are
hotlines. And there are
known resources that are
just there for nourishment.
Right because it is a whole
New World. That that people
are having to navigate
concentrators are now
making their own grave
during. And they're
navigating up public basic
1 where the world is acting
on that okay right and then
possibly negative ways okay
like where when the outcome
is there like- you
accomplish this work of art
and we love it. It's
actually a highly monetised
outcome it's much more
interesting to have them be
under scrutiny and ridicule
all and M. back yes course
right no one of note in the
back of the really
monetized. By really kind
of let them developers. In
the public sphere alongside
there are- yeah. The lease
or the toll right yeah I
was telling you like if
anybody asks what Devolver
secret sauce is that's the
first word I say is
kindness. Everybody we work
with with such unexpected
levels of kindness but it
freaks them out. And we
don't have to lock anybody
down in a contractor on the
right he- forced them to
work with us they can't
wait to work with us. And
it's yes we have a good
team that's good at what we
do but first and foremost
and both Devolver and Good
Shepherd culture is. Like
anything last then over
kindness is you're not
doing your job. Right and
that's that's company
culture and we're a very
small company but we work
with an awful lot of
developers and stuff a lot
of games. And so yeah we've
normalized that we and I
try to be as loud about
that as they can so that
when people are. Trying to.
Emulate what the bombers
accomplished as a team that
they understand that that's
point number one it's not
just that. We've got people
that love games no games
really well everybody has
that. But that kind of
keeps people coming to you
and it makes you the first
choice right so that's-
that's a big part of
reversing that culture to
music. Making kind. Cool is
the only cat I'm sorry kind
this is the only cool that
matters. In warning was
thinking about I'm earlier
I think when you asked a
question about like getting
more specific about what we
do with some things and I
think about how I work with
a lot of developers- and
we're actually- as an
insurgency working on Hey-
trainings for- managers and
leaders in the games
industry to understand
gender based harm better in
the workplace and I think a
lot about like what it
%-Ra
leader in the spaces and it
like it it really does come
from us in a lot of ways-
so like Mike what you're
talking about of like okay
well the leadership of
Devolver has to. Allow
space for and teach and
bring that kindness in to
make sure that everyone is
doing that right- and I was
thinking about how like
part of you know we again
we talk about crunch a lot
games right it's an issue.
Like toxicity happens in
and- in game communities
here's the thing is the
issues around mental health
in games I'm our not like
limited to individual
issues right there no there
are many of them are rooted
in systemic structures and
systemic issues so like
like the fact that we have
these really toxic
workplaces that encourage
ands and support and
actually forced crunch
culture is a huge piece of
mental health concern right
I'm trying to say is we
can't ask our employees to
like be mindful of their
mental health and to rest
when they need it if we're
not also willing to. Allow
a lower output right a
reduced output and that's
just the reality of like
you gotta make a choice
here you can't be spouting
like Reston and mental
health and I'll expect the
same level of work and the
reality is you're probably
gonna get a better quality
of work at the end of the
day because when we
arrested when we have
taking care of ourselves
when we had reading room
away from our creative
projects that are taking up
every single brain cell we
come up with the best ideas
right we come up with the
best ways of doing things
and so I think I started
this and I didn't finish
this by saying I got a text
right before this started
about how like. A friend's
publisher was like Hey we
need it's Friday today was
we're recording this- and
was like Hey we need this
thing by Monday and he's
like no like I'm not doing
that to my team my team has
worked so hard but I think
we that's some of what we
need to normalize as well
right I would say lead by
example you know the same
what what I needed was
saying you know
demonstrate. That behavior
and behavior that you want
to see out of other people
right and do call them out
in a respectful way an
expected they might not-
issues as needed said might
not be at that level yet it
might take a I mean swipe
at you and you've got to be
ready to accept that with
grace and not are not
necessarily accept it but
riff reflected with grace
and not. Not just become
the part of the all right
so it's all it's all the-
and- you know we're all
students and teachers
whether we want to be or
not like your behavior is
teaching everyone in your
orbit- how they you know
it's an example good or bad
right so. I try to remember
that and whether it's in my
industry or just in life
like. You you might not
want to be a teacher you
might not want to be an
influencer or role model or
whatever but you are. In
your mostly influencing the
people that are around you
which tend to be the people
you love the most. Right
so. I think you just take
that to your communities
that you care about and go
this is how you do it you
don't say that you just do
it you know. The people who
have power in this industry
to influence people in the
right direction- whether
that's people who are in
charge of studios are in
charge of companies are in
charge of communities- and
then there's individuals
who are responsible for
themselves in a responsible
you know not to go online
and you know tell their
favorite developer that
they hate them. You know
take care of yourself while
also thinking about what
kinds of impacts you can
have in in in your ways
right in your ways. Make
ripples where you can and
that might be you are a
manager and you are going
to learn about. How to be a
more ethical a manager that
integrates mental health
into your work place and
you're going to fight for
your employees to your
bosses you might. Right
like that's the thing that
you can do that is not
public facing but I have a
big impact on. The people
you have power over right-
you and your friends are
playing at lot like. Games
and you're in a lobby and
someone is saying. Like
awful things like call it
out because if you can
right if you are in a space
to do that. Like call it
out be that person make it
not normal. And not okay.
To hear abusive predatory
language in. In Gaming
spaces. Now I say all of
that with the recognition
that this is a mental
health panel and we all
need to take steps back. We
all need to check out
sometimes we all need to
take care of ourselves we
don't all do well in
confrontation. You know so
like don't feel bad if you
need to take time for
yourself and if that's-
like six months. So be it
thank you so much. I think
we're out of time really
quick before we go all I
mean I know you have your
hot line I would love all
three of you plug. Plug a
mental health resource that
you care a lot about that
you think is valuable go.
I'm our hotline you can
find out more at games
hotline dot org we're at
games hotline on all the
things if you want to use
this right now you can go
ahead and do that just tech
support. Two two three
three six eight anywhere in
the U. S. and- we'll get
with you we'll talk to you.
We'll support you. Take
this. .org is a- as a-
another lovely organization
full of mental health
professionals and people
from the games industry and
that. That cross section-
and they take. They take
their work very seriously.
And I've been supporting
them through Devolver and
Good Shepherd but also
personally. With my time
and also. Putting my money.
About this because this is
an important issue. All for
example I want to just
reply both of your arms. I
think. It's great that
there is an ecosystem.
Right are you willing to
have. Choices a new wants.
And just to go back to the
neatest point. I think that
B. the biggest thing people
can do is identify. Who
they are we- yes. Right
who. Is your we- finding
your communities where you
truly. Feel. Included an
authentic. Is the most
thing that I all of us you
know strive to DO and I
guess Jordan Voght are
nonprofit Gaming
professionals for those U.
elegy guy Hey. Of course
that is 1 lands I think
everyone out there
continuing to find
communities around play
around identity around
discussion. Where you'll
feel your your authentic
self. Is the most important
thing you can do. Obviously
he's very sick mental
health resources can
augment that. But they
should hopefully just be
augmenting your day to day
experience in round games.
I mean it might thank you
all so much for doing this
this is an absolutely
wonderful discussion I.
Hope everybody has a
wonderful E3 take care of
yourselves I. Got. Thank
you.
Any welcome back folks
right now this very moment
this is the closing the
first day of the most
wonderful time of year
notice E3 so thank you my
dear friends are joining us
on only the beginning of
what is surely bound to be
a wild ride. Ups and-
exciting things yet the
common joining me for this
exciting moment in the
close of this beautiful day
that's not other than
Jordan. And Phil choose
stunning lads you use it a
couple times today me on
the other hand. I'm Kurt.
You you're probably
wondering dammit Lucius art.
Because the combined into
one she get me so here we
are. Anyways so- as we
close out the first. View
the full day beautiful of
course objectives- let's
kind of take a moment to
reflect on some of the most
exciting is heard and maybe
some of the most. Okay in
regard I want to start off.
I think it over to Jordan
because he didn't have a
chance to be on the Ubisoft
stream but he's an
assassin's creed boy I want
to hear all about what he's
got to say about bell hello
or anything else you're
excited about I'm not going
to. Put your corner how
dare you put me into a box
and I know I was with a box
now it's totally. You got.
I would say a thousand
screed ball hall IBM how
disappointed because the
siege of Paris expansion is
scheduled for summer of
this year so considering
that E3 is in summer I kind
of expected us to. See a
little bit of. Something of
what it would be I mean we
did get to see like a tiny
little bit but I was
expecting some sort of game
play trailer or some story
trailer or anything. Like
that- I'm super excited
about the idea of the whole
black box mission style
coming back- those rain
unity those run syndicate
and they cut them in
origins and they haven't
been seen since. So I'll be
really cool not sure it's
going to work because they
were like super stealth
assassin he focused and if
you think of. Like Odyssey
involves all I'm not sure
like super stealth
assassinations which you
thank for those games but I
mean maybe it'll work who
knows we'll see. It also
educate take this coverage
or common they got some
they got the- they bring in
education through the
ripples of the games and-
Phil I know you're gonna
become- a Rocksmith text
for in demand- expert on
the discovering. Valhalla
through assassin's creed.
Yeah I was saying a little
earlier did I do like the
idea that Ubisoft is kind
of using these video games
the teacher will stop- when
we're doing are you south-
Joe was talking about how I
played a whole lot of
rockstar rock band and
guitar hero in. How
worthless all that. Fine
your shocking it's shocking
that like the plastic
buttons don't translate
into what you gonna do with
fingers to do strings and
yeah I don't. So now
rockstar is gonna long
hours in college yes yeah
right with is gonna be the
dark souls of. Tucker
GamePass so that's going to
force you to have to deal
with it and you really can
genuinely good and that
other dark souls for
yourself right. In real
life but yeah. Yeah so I
mean do they have- I'm I've
got a guitar some. I think
I could. They got up in.
It'll be easier I want to
get a weird dongle I can do
with my with my phone all
the time seems cool- I
don't know that the-
discovery tour mode is
going to get me to actually
play ball of finally.
Because I still don't have
a hundred hours. But you
don't think about it so
that's nice but will get
you to shred in Valhalla.
The rock. Three of the
major things educate- we
also re was X. extraction
which of course will get
the chance to are you talk
about early and play a
bunch- but that that's-
what Fenway was that you
were yeah I was able to
raise both. What what
school did you go to it
that you were like learning
how to hunt alien inspected.
They're preparing us for
something okay and what if
there's if there's any you
know rainbow six is a very
tactical- precise shooter-
I'm not saying it's
training me to be any more
tactical and extreme
situations. I don't know
where I'm going with us
basically. All right Hey
things or whatever do you
really miss sweets like
way. That any gun you a
full report is coming or is
out all right I don't
actually know I had a look
at the news. And your Rhoda
the number of running to-
yes yeah Razer I'm so sorry
I've derailed yes I've
derailed this entire
conversation I apologize I
think I had do you think I
knew where I was going
Jordan. He felt.
Extractions and what we
were doing the extraction
yeah so it's fun I play
like two hours of it- and
you know you it's- it's
cooperative river six each-
but it's very stealthy. And
that's what I'm into about
it- especially since you
know you're talking about
flex but flex Bucks
missions going back to all
of that we could be back in
a ball to because you know
what I missed. Still things
where splinter cell what's
going on. Extractions cool
I like it was funny speaker
only go to like shoot the
aliens before they- called
friends. And educational
because you're learning
about the aliens and that's
the whole. Check part of
Ubisoft as the new the new
angle learning. Saul is-
George about you you can
chance to talk extraction
earlier guidance. As I say
I I'm intrigued to try
extraction I'm like how did
they decide which operators
to pick how will this game
evolved differently from
see if these gets a new
operator does that come to
extraction do they get
different operators going
forward. What is it like
now playing with these
characters in a three man
team as opposed to a five
man team got to kind of.
Shore up a bit more holes
in your defenses and what
not. It's just. A different
feel a different vibe and
I'm intrigued to. At least
see what it's like- it's
been a long time since I've
played with. Team rainbow
in a P. V. E. setting I'm
so use now to playing seeds
and doing PVP. I I 1 I'm a
segue out of that I think
everything you just said is
still a valid. I think
it'll be really exciting
cool to see. C. a tactical
approach to a you know left
for dead style format but
it's going to expire so
this is this is another
arbitrary connection you
know who has tons of. Other
plans to publish a list of
games. Devolver they have a
lot of. To squeeze one out
because their their
presentation save if you
want you know at least
doing something different
at least the- they showed
something whether was. As
many games you want to
think they gave you
something to look at- which
is a lot of chili dog
consuming- but this gonna
just gonna leave it to a
different corner of things
that I want to touch. On
with Jordan specifically
and you fill because I
think you like I say we
felt a break that's tight
because end up with a very
different opinions on it.
Standing the like the one
thing yeah the one thing- I
was most excited about
with- with Devolver and
this is a this. Is a
decision no one's gonna be
happy about except for
maybe me and the other
people who are. Like me who
are only. You Devolver is
putting out a game. In
another game demon throttle
as a physical only it's not
gonna be extra it's not
gonna be digital the only
way you can get it by
buying a physical copy for
the Nintendo switch and I
don't care what anyone says
I don't care if it makes no
sense at all I don't care
if the anti consumer to
some degree I'm here for it
it's a bold nonsensical
choice I don't I it's a I
don't. I don't even look at
your- your name. Time to do
it but I was like that was
enough to treat me like I
want that I'm not you know
what I'm not going to treat
as a collector's item I'm
open minute game throw down
the stairs all look that
cartridge we Nintendo which
states that we all love so
much- so- you're on the
spot so where you stand do
you think that's a good
idea organize. Okay well
Jordan what do you think I
need to hear both arguments
right so I can make a real
I can be the judge why this
is it's going backwards we
used to live in a world
where games only released
physically and like I
understand that that's how
games used to come out and
then all of a sudden we're
like we have these online
marketplaces and now people
can actually buy games that
actually having to go into
a store and find. The game
and Devolver wants to go
backwards on this and be
like oh no it's not going
to be on the Nintendo eShop
like this is not like- this
is a cool exclusive first
which is the game you can
only buy first which is
like so this is a cool
exclusive in that
exclusively physical and
there's no digital version
of the game to buy. Shortly
review it like seventy
years from now you don't
you can't find a physical
copy I don't care if the
tweet says we'll keep
making copies of this game
for as long as you know the
bench really productive
going to stop and you're
not gonna be able to find
this game I mean maybe it
will be good but assuming
that it is and people want
to play I just this feels
like a path that's actually
that's actually what the
last thing you just said
that's actually the reason
why 1 is because like what
if the game is really
really good. And then I
have no way to play it I
need to do is get it now
and this is coming from the
dude who doesn't own
anything like I like cut
out material because of my
life I only have the
digital version of both the
PS five and Xbox as I have
no way I like I think lows
having to plug in my PS
four is a Blu ray player
just to watch a movie like
all just write this
somewhere else that's the-
type. Of prophetic person I
turned into you. But I'm
all here. His call.
GamePass anyways Philbrick
aside. Okay well on one
hand just because things
are did doesn't mean you
have a I really like a
positive such going on like
what about actually owning
stuff if it's a physical
only did you definitely
don't and if it's digital
you can get that license
revoked anytime right. On
the other hand- that's
really your cheating to
have to do it like I don't
go to the store ever never
again so. I don't know I
think I think I'm leaning
toward. Jordan Voght if you
but I definitely hurt I
also definitely don't want
corporations to tell me.
What I can only. So I don't
know that's kind of
waffling. We're going to go
Jordan Voght on account of
convenience but- with
Chester a member you as one
of the- nonetheless. Unless
it's something appreciate
in the midst of you know a
lot of conferences with a
lot of the same things
nothing everyone's gamer
things the same but you
know Namco. Either way well
when I haven't talked to
something. Completely off
the rails which is to be
expected so- we don't have
much time left
unfortunately- there's a
lot of things I wish we
could talk about like in
the other indie games that
are necessary there in the-
the- the folder. E3 you
like. The tribeca GameSpot
like yesterday but-
absolutely fantastic
there's like not a single
game that wasn't shown
during that entire thing
that I was like I 1 played
out. I want to play that
one. I don't play that one.
Is there any kind of moment
for either one of you
Jordan Voght started you-
that. Didn't get to see the
spotlight today the first
TV three that you want to
call you know some
attention to. This moment.
I'm I'm not sure if it's a
moment if more so in
observation of several
moments I think people need
to look at what happened
with Gearbox today with you
Ubisoft today and- then
compare that to like. If
the dads and wholesome
direct and see that. Indie
games are like still coming
out strong but a few triple
a projects like might have
been delayed like over the
past the this. Course of
the year that we don't
really want to talk about
all the things that
happened so tomorrow when
we're watching Xbox with
those that and- in the days
after watching like
Nintendo it's a look that
maybe don't have super
super high expectations
like. Still hope to see a
lot of those cool triple a
giant flag. Apple apple EIC
type games but maybe curb
your expectations to be
like we might only see
like. Two or three of them
instead of the. Six to
eight that we were kind of
hoping for this year.
Obviously doing a lot more
words than feels about you
because we do have to wrap
it up so filament
challenger three words.
Something you're excited
about going into tomorrow-
going tomorrow yeah.
Starfield something
something. That's a really
good one- we don't I don't
wanna say reprieve sheet
that you chose to take the
time with us today here
games by the checkout E3 so
please from us to you we
appreciate it dear friends
companions creatures and
others thanks for being
here with us and with that
said don't go anywhere I
mean you can go and enjoy
your day but tomorrow
please make sure to come
back because we have
microsoft in Bethesda
joining joined by again.
Tammy Lucy in Jordan we
also have square Enix with
him Lizzy and fill and
following the wrestling
with that from what PC
gaming show future game
show and then I'm going to
come back here again at the
end of the day the close
all out and make a mess of
things all over so once
again thank you folks
congratulations E3 happen
again yeah but you made. It
they want. Your good.
Jordan Voght good still.
These are sort of this I
guess yeah. Yeah that's
true all right it's all
over- 5 follow these dudes-
these creatures on Twitter
follow me on Twitter if
your heart doesn't so
desire. Until next time be
well drink water conceal
Mario.